[Musique]
Jérôme CL, bonsoir.
Bonsoir Sky.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Ah bah ça
commence pour une question difficile se
présenter succinquement.
Comment je vais me définir peut-être
comme une particule élémentaire avec pas
mal d'états superposés ? Voyez indéfini
qui sont tous vrais qui coexistent tous
en même temps et puis ça vibrillonne de
l'un à l'autre. Alors, en gros euh j'ai
plusieurs cercles. Un cercle militaire
passé,
un cercle
qui est celui des réflexions, des
prospectives, un cercle qui est
peut-être celui de l'enseignement, un
cercle aussi qui est celui bah des
cercles de pouvoir hein. Voilà. Et puis
ces cercles coexistent entre eux,
peut-être le cercle des renseignements
aussi. Voilà, ces cercles coexistent, on
peut passer de l'un à l'autre et ça me
définit plutôt pas mal. Voilà. Donc de
façon plus prosaïque. Oui. Une
expérience militaire
en tant que pilote, une expérience
auprès des des instances dirigeantes
avec un certain nombre de travaux, que
ce soit le livre blanc, que ce soit des
rapports présidentiels, des choses comme
ça, des travaux dans les services de
renseignement et puis dans les cabinets
ministériels aussi. Voilà. Donc ça ça me
définit plutôt pas mal. On pourra
revenir sur l'ensemble de ces travaux et
partant de là, j'espère que ça
crédibilisera un petit peu mon propos.
Alors, on va commencer par le début.
Donc, pilote
pilote sur quel type de zing ?
Sur Transal.
Transal, c'est la bétaillère à emmener
les chars. C'est ça.
C'est un véritable avion de guerre.
C'est un avion d'armes.
C'est pas c'est pas un truc de légumier.
Ça m'est arrivé.
Ça se met pas sur le
ça m'est arrivé à plusieurs rep. peut
faire des petits tonneaux barriqués avec
un transal ou tonneaux fa
Ah des tonneaux barriqués. Il paraît que
les anciens le faisaient mais c'est un
temps que les jeunes de 20 ans he voilà
vous connaissez la suite. Voilà, il peut
faire beaucoup de choses le transal et
il peut être sous le feu en effet ça a
pu m'arriver j'ai des dates précises en
tête des faits précis en tête c'était
deag ou à l'arrivée ça peut être par
exemple en 2000
7.
Alors j'ouvre une parenthèse je préviens
ma communauté.
Aujourd'hui on va faire sport. OK.
On va
Ah bah allez-y,
on va faire sport. C'est on a pas tous
les jours la on a pas tous les jours la
chance d'avoir un pilote.
On aime beaucoup la mentalité des
pilotes dans l'armée de l'air et dans la
marine. Et donc on va envoyer un peu de
steak un peu plus que d'habitude
aujourd'hui pour deux raisons. La
première comme je l'ai expliqué avec
pilote en face. La deuxième, c'est que
on trouve que les prospectivistes, les
analystes et ceux qui sont censés
anticiper les menaces pour notre pays et
ben ils sont,
on va dire moyens. D'accord ? Moyen,
c'est juste un peu mieux que médiocre,
on est d'accord ?
Donc alors pas tous, bien entendu, pas
de généralité ma mais quand on voit la
la situation du pays, c'est compliqué.
C'est compliqué et on pense que ils ont
quand même aussi alors je sais pas s'il
faisait des rapports extraordinaires qui
n'étaient jamais lus où on a une
expertise en terme de politicien à
l'ouest. On aura peut-être l'occasion
d'en reparler. Continuez continuez un
petit peu votre parcours. Donc pilote du
Transal euh ça s'est bien passé, vous
avez été sous le feu. Quelques dates
rapides.
Ouais. En 2007 notamment attentat sur
Guillaume Sor à Boaqué. Voilà son avion
50 m en face de Montransal.
qui prend un missile son garde du corps
tué
au décollage.
Non non au tarmac à l'arrêt. Puis après
des tirs de Kalashnikov dans la foule.
Voilà. Bon ça j'ai pas véritablement
sous le feu moi-même mais mon avion
était quand même potentiellement
incriminé. Voilà donc ça c'est c'est une
expérience forte.
Parcours militaire, vous avez fait votre
service ? Bah forcément.
Alors mon service colonel
mon service oui effectivement j'ai été
jusqu'au grade de lieutenant colonel.
mon service. Je sais pas si on peut
parler de service. J'ai fait l'école de
l'air et de l'espace donc tout jeune
après ma prépa et donc de fait c'est
intégré et disons que j'ai fait mes
classes. Voilà mes stages de combat, mes
stages de survie. Je passé par toutes
les portes du slalom dans dans mes
jeunes années. Voilà à la vingtaine
trouvé sur internet passage à la DGS.
Ah oui, ça doit être vrai puisque c'est
écrit.
Puisque c'est écrit. Non, on préfère
vérifier. Ouais.
Passage.
Ça veut dire vous amiez les cafés, vous
amis un copain, vous enz quelque chose
d'autre, vous restez un petit peu, vous
faisiez quoi là-bas ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à la DGSE
lorsque on y va en tant que militaire ?
Si vous regardez bien dans les fiches de
recrutement, en général, c'est pour être
analyste ou comme on dit officier
traitant, hein, voilà, officier traitant
étant un analyse sur le terrain, c'est
ça.
Ah, pas du tout. un officier traitant,
c'est sur le terrain dans la mesure où
ça traite des sources, hein. Quand on
dit agents, en fait, on dit agents à la
DGSE. En fait, des agents à la DGSE, ce
sont les sources. Les véritables agents,
ce sont des des officiers traitants. Et
la différence entre agent et honorable
contributeur, c'est quoi ?
Honorable correspondant, sans doute vous
les dire. Voilà. Ben, un honorable
correspondant, c'est un agent qui n'est
pas rémunéré. Donc, une source qui n'est
pas rémunérée, qui le fait en général
par soucis patriotique. Voilà. ou truc
où euh il y a plein de leviers hein pour
lesquels euh pour lesquels on peut être
amené à collaborer euh à coopérer avec
des services de renseignement quand on
est agent
ou à retourner une source.
Alors retourner une source c'est encore
autre chose. Mais les leviers c'est
effectivement c'est l'argent, c'est la
reconnaissance, c'est le sexe et c'est
le patriotisme. Voilà donc les
honorables correspondants en général
il peut y en avoir d'autres. Ça peut se
se raffiner
et bien si vous regardez la réponse que
je vous ai fournie, ça peut osciller
entre analyste et officier traitant.
Voilà. Après pour le reste, je peux pas
vous en dire plus. Voilà.
Enseignement en science P.
Oui.
Prospective
et stratégie.
Et stratégie. Donc c'est c'est vous qui
avez repris en main
les les jeunes cerveaux français pour
protéger le p le territoire.
Alors l'ambition est forte. Vous croyez
pas si bien dire. C'est vrai que j'ai
cette ambition dans ce cours que j'anime
depuis 5 ans de les former à ce qu'on
appelle la préparation et l'aide à la
décision. Et quand on voit tout le bien
que vous pensez des prospectivistes,
sans doute à bon droit d'ailleurs, il y
a du boulot. Voilà. Très clairement la
préparation et l'aide à la décision
c'est quelque chose qui fait que on sort
à la fin des bons rapports et des bonnes
politiques publiques ou pas. Voilà. Et
donc précisément, il faut que euh les
jeunes qui ont vocation comme ça en
étant diplômé de sciences pot, de
polytechnique et cetera et qui ensuite
vont en cabinet mystériel ou dans des
euh cabinets de conseil en stratégie,
bref, qui sont dans les grands
transformateurs de la société et bien
soit capable de véritablement incarner
et impulser. C'est-à-dire que très
concrètement, pour ce qui est de la
chose publique, les administrations vont
pas euh s'autoallumer, elles vont pas
euh euh elles vont pas euh
s'autoinspiré. Non, elles vont être
capables de mettre en œuvre si vous
impulsez, mais elles vont pas le faire
d'elles-même. Donc si le canard n'a pas
de tête, euh faut pas compter que
quelqu'un s'en charge à votre place.
Donc dans les cabinets ministériels, il
faut impulser. Or, typiquement euh bah
c'est quand même un lieu où euh le
rythme était freiné et où paradoxalement
là où il faudrait pouvoir penser, on n'
peut-être pas le temps de penser
suffisamment. Et donc mon cours à
Science Pose, c'était un peu cet objet,
c'était saisissez-vous de ce rôle de
chef d'orchestre ? Ne suit ça n'existe
plus.
Ah si si il existe encore. Oui, c'était
mais c'est encore pardon. Oui, faites
bien de préciser euh c'est un ongoing
process donc on continue à l'améliorer.
Il continue. Et l'idée pour eux c'est
véritablement de se saisir de ce rôle de
chef d'orchestre, de ne pas suivre
l'orchestre et la musique mais
d'impulser. Et donc il y a tout un tas
de méthodes d'outils pour faire de la
bonne prospective, pour faire de la
bonne, j'allais dire du bon de la bonne
préparation et de la bonne aide à la
décision pour véritablement avoir des
recommandations opératoires infinées sur
tout un tas de sujets sur lesquels
stratégiques hein, sur lesquels on
pourra revenir au fil de l'entretien
bien sûr. Alors, avant de poser ma
première question sur qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'état de la prospective en
France, par rapport à à vos vos jeunes
têtes blondes que vous formez, vous
formez plutôt en leur expliquant que si
la prospective il la sentent caricubi
qu'ils sont prêts à sacrifier auprès de
leur hiérarchie pour porter leur leur
prospective ou vous vous formez des gens
qui vont vont apprendre à se taire pour
pouvoir avancer dans la hiérarchie ?
Est-ce que j'ai vra Est-ce qu'on forme
des des
des têtes brûlées pour le pays ? Alors
tête brûlé dans le bon sens du terme
où est-ce qu'on forme des gens qui sont
comme on on a l'habitude de voir là pour
prolonger les courbes dans des salons
feutrés ?
Alors euh j'aurais tendance à dire si je
suis là devant vous c'est qu'à priori
mon ADN n'est pas vraiment à former des
gens qui prolongent des courbes. Il faut
voir quelle courbe dans des salons
feutrés. L'idée encore une fois c'est
pas de de prévoir mollement, c'est de
préparer le futur et donc d'explorer.
Quand vous dites euh est-ce qu'il s'agit
pour eux de porter leur prospective
courageusement auprès de leur hiérarchie
? plus que ça, mieux que ça, il s'agit
d'impliquer leur hiérarchie dans leurs
travaux prospectifs. Parce que si la
hiérarchie, c'est ça l'élément
fondamental, est pas impliqué dans
l'élaboration des scénarios, et bien
c'est comme si j'allais dire c'est c'est
l'équivalent d'un peigne pour les
chauves parce que ça n'adhère pas. Il
faut véritablement que ce soit de la
coconstruction. C'est un terme qui est
galé, on l'entend partout. Construction,
coproduction, il y en a plein qui en
parlent et peu qui en font. Mais
véritablement, il faut qu'il y ait cette
gestation, cet exercice véritablement
euh conjoint, symbiotique, j'allais dire
avec euh le avec les dirigeants pour que
ça puisse prendre. Typiquement euh dans
un cabinet de conseil en stratégie, si
les dirigeants sont pas impliqués dans
la réflexion, dans l'exploration des
scénarios, dans la construction de ces
scénarios, c'est pas en leur plaquant
une vérité comme ça après coup savamment
penser, gérer, euh rédiger, euh ciseler
en cabinet et on dit voilà chef, voilà
chef notre point de vue que ça va
prendre. Alors je suis pas non plus
naïf. Je sais bien que les décideurs ont
pas le temps. Je sais bien que il faut
arriver à un travail abouti et ensuite
il y a tout un travail pour faire en
sorte qu'il se l'approprie. Mais ce
travail d'appropriation, s'il y a pas et
j'en reviens à votre question, une
volonté pour le porter courageusement,
l'incarner sans sentir véritablement
pénétré, ça ne peut pas marcher. Ce qui
signifie aussi que le prospectiviste
doit faire corps avec sa prospective. Il
s'agit pas là de prolonger les courbes
et de voir d'explorer le futur comme si
c'était des objets devant nous, mais
véritablement de reconsidérer le réel
présent et voir comment on peut
reconfigurer une vision de la réalité.
Alors ça va vous sembler ésotérique mais
comme on a un peu de temps, on aura le
temps de rentrer dans le détail. Mais
c'est véritablement ça. S'il y a
vraiment quelque chose à retenir et
quelque chose qui doit entrer dans la
tête des dirigeants lorsqu'on leur
soumet un travail de prospective, c'est
que c'est moins une exploration des
objets de l'avenir qu'une
réinterprétation de la réalité présente.
Et c'est ça qu'il faut arriver. C'est ça
qu'il faut arriver euh à
opérationnaliser parce que tout ce que
je vous dis là au final ça doit rentrer
dans les mains et ça doit donner lieu à
des prospectives hein. C'est de la
théorie prospective revue pour avoir une
théorie pratique euh pardon une
prospective pratique qui soit
véritablement opératoire au bout du
compte. Bon, la prospective en France,
les révolutions arabes, on a rien vu
venir avant ça. La crise financière, on
a rien vu venir. Les Russes, on a rien
vu venir. Qu'est-ce qu'on a rien vu
venir d'autre ?
Mais est-ce que vous êtes dans la
prospective ? J'ai volontairement
pas provocateur mais dialectique, on va
dire avec vous.
Est-ce que c'est de la prospective là ?
Est-ce qu'on est dans l'échelle de temps
?
C'est dans le bilan là. Oui, mais est-ce
que c'est véritablement est-ce que
c'était un exercice prospectif que de
prévoir les printemps arabes, que de
prévoir l'agression russe, que de
prévoir la crise financière ? Là, on est
dans la prévision. La prévision c'est
l'anticipation plutôt.
Alors on est alors tout dépend mais là
on va revenir sur quand je vous disais
réexplorer la réalité présente pour
envisager le futur, ça veut dire
commencer par s'interroger sur le sens
des mots. L'anticipation je vais la
définir dans l'acception qui est la
mienne. Ça a deux p c'est la prévision.
Et là on va avoir des modèles qui vont
prolonger autant de courbes que possible
et les prolonger le le mieux possible.
Là, on est dans la prévision avec des
modèles quantitatifs ou des modèles plus
qualitatifs. Avec ce que vous ce dont
vous parlez là, on est plus dans le
qualitatif. Et puis il y a la
prospective en tant que telle qui elle
est une forme d'exploration. Je reprends
parler de la prospective française.
Gaston Berger, père de la prospective
française qui était à l'origine un
philosophe et un philosophe de l'action
et tourné vers la philosophie de
l'esprit aussi et qui disait "La
prospective, c'est voir plus neuf, voir
plus large et plus profond." et une
bonne prospective doit dégager un parfum
d'éternité. Et vous, vous me parlez de
qui ? Un événement qui va arriver dans
l'année, les 2 ans, les 3 ans à venir.
Mais la prospective à moins d'une
génération, c'est-à-dire la prospective
qui n'intègre pas le possible
renouvellement des mentalités, des
esprits. Mais c'est pas une prospective.
La prospe connaissez le la théorie du
signe noir ?
Oui.
Vous connaissez le roi dragon ?
Non.
D'accord. Et donc le le pour pour
revenir à ça en France à l'heure
actuelle, est-ce qu'on est dépassé,
borgne, aveugle, on tâtonne, on réagit
d'une façon symptomatique ou vous avez
l'impression, vous en tant que
professionnel de la prospective et de la
stratégie qu'on est sur des bons rails
où vous avez l'impression d'avoir
un jeune pilote qui se retrouve un peu
dans la tempête avec un un technicien
derrière qui est aussi bon il se rend
pas bien compte mais il essayent ils
sont volontaires,
ils essayent mais on aurait besoin d'un
d'un vieux barbu derrière le manche qui
pilote avec ses fesses quand il y a tout
qui tombe en rideau.
Pour répondre à votre question, ce
diagnostic, il me semble totalement
juste. Je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
fait de la France. Je pense que c'est
euh
mondial, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas un
pays qui s'en sort mieux que les autres
de ce point de vue-là.
Faut pas faire son français là. Il faut
pas se comparer au dernier de la classe.
Ah non, mais il y a pas de premier, il y
a pas de dernier de la classe. Là, c'est
écart type zéro et euh et un profil de
note carré, vous voyez ? Donc en fait
plat, si vous préférez. Donc là, on est
tous au stade que vous décriviez fort
bien. C'est on s'en on essaie de fly the
plane. Voilà. faites voler l'avion et on
et on en est là. Voilà. Donc les
éléments de vol, l'assiette, la vitesse,
la vitesse c'est la vie, l'altitude. On
se prémunit, on reste au-dessus de la de
la des hauteurs de sécurité et on essaie
de rien de se percuter. Voilà, on en est
là. Mais euh contrô
c'est ça mais pas davantage mais on en
est tous là et pas la France euh la
France plus qu'un autre pays l'Europe
plus qu'un autre pays parce que ce qui
se passe actuellement et c'est euh
renvoie à un diagnostic qui est vrai
depuis Paul Valérie en fait et qui est
encore vrai aujourd'hui. Je vous invite
à relire la crise de l'esprit et la
liberté de l'esprit, les deux de Paul
Valérie. Bon et en gros en substance, il
vous explique et ça a une acuité toute
particulière aujourd'hui avec le
numérique et puis la conjugaison de
l'ensemble des crises systémiques
thématiques, environnemental,
sécuritaire, technologique et autres. il
vous explique qu'en fait le monde est
devenu indéfini,
c'est-à-dire qu'on n plus capable de
nommer les choses et notre incapacité à
nommer les choses et je reviendrai pour
l'illustrer, hein, mais tout de suite
même là, voilà, la guerre aujourd'hui,
on ne sait plus véritablement ce que
c'est que la guerre. Al, on dit c'est le
retour de la guerre, la guerre haute
intensité. Oui, mais la guerre hybride
et qui dit guerre dit paix, mais paix,
on sait plus la définir non plus avec
une notion de victoire. Il y en a pas un
pour s'entendre sur savoir ce que c'est
que la victoire. Est-ce qu'on met
derrière le mot victoire par exemple
derrière la guerre en Ukraine ? Et donc
il y a une crise des mots, il y a une
crise du nomos, hein. On sait plus
nommer les chose. Et ça Paul Valérie
l'avait dit, on est dans un monde
indéfini. Pourquoi ? Là aussi, il a
expliqué pourquoi il a expliqué que le
monde en fait se retrouvait être l'image
exacte de l'esprit de l'homme.
C'est-à-dire que d'une certaine manière,
on a on s'est tellement dissous dans le
monde que l'on a à raisonner et le fait
technologique a amplifié tout ça et avec
le numérique ça a atteint son acmé que
finalement l'homme a imprimé son esprit
dans le monde. Or, comme l'esprit
humain, pour autant qu'on puisse le
définir et on y reviendra, c'est d'abord
une grande puissance de transformation
intérieure extrêmement volatile,
extrêmement instable, extrêmement
insais. Et bien par la même, en se
regardant dans le miroir, le monde est
devenu insais, imprévisible. Et que donc
que la crise de la prévision, c'était
quelque chose qui allait nous guetter,
disait-il, mais nous guetter en 1939.
Donc aujourd'hui, ça nous guettete pas,
ça nous saisit. Donc aujourd'hui, c'est
flight the plane. Donc si vous voulez
malgré tout penser l'avenir parce que
penser l'homme et penser la société,
c'est forcément penser ce que peut être
demain. Il faut forcément pouvoir se
projeter. C'est la propriété, c'est un
postulat qui dit que bah demain cette
maison là à laquelle nous est
m'appartiendra encore. Les relations
sentimentales un peu durables, c'est se
dire que votre femme sera ou votre
conjoint sera toujours là encore 24
heures plus tard. Tout est basé sur le
fait que demain sera encore là. si on
fait ça ce soir et bien c'est quelque
part on postule que ça a un sens et si
ça a un sens oui parce que bah demain le
soleil va se lever donc on est on est
vraiment mis en demeure de penser
l'avenir mais sans pouvoir prédire donc
que peut-on faire ? Et bien il faut
réexplorer et c'est là où la prospective
prend le relais et c'est là où il faut
revenir à une autre façon de penser le
socle de connaissance et la façon de
nommer ce qui nous arrive à commencer
les crises. Et là c'est Michel Fouco qui
prend le relais. Il prend le relais en
1966 et on l'a pas entendu. On se
souvient de quoi de Michel Fouco ? On se
souvient de l'histoire de la sexualité.
On se souvient de surveiller et punir
qui là aussi prend une grande acuité
avec si on met ça en regarde de 1984
George Orwell he on en a beaucoup parlé
pendant la crise Covid. Il y av Gramchi
et Georgewell il il se donnent il se
renvoyit la balle et on entend parler
que de ça pendant pendant la crise
Covid. Donc très bien, mais pour autant
on se souvient pas des mots et des
choses de Michel Fouco. Or, c'est de ça
qu'il faut se souvenir aujourd'hui. Donc
si vous voulez, la bonne prospective,
c'est réexplorer à nouveau frais en
étant capable de regarder ce que l'on ne
voit pas bien, de porter notre
attention. Porter notre attention, c'est
faire exister les choses, ce qui
n'existe pas, c'est-à-dire ce qui hors
le décor. Et pour autant, c'est
exactement ce qui va nous permettre de
réexplorer les choses à nouveau frais.
Vous parliez du signe noir, ce signal
faible. C'est bord de spectre, c'est ça
qui nous intéresse en prospective. C'est
pas la gosienne avec la fréquence
centrale que tout le monde voit.
Aujourd'hui, il y a la guerre en
Ukraine. Bon, personne peut la
méconnaître bien, mais elle pose tout un
tas de questions qui sont en bord de
spectre et c'est ça qu'il faut
réexplorer. Alors, réexplorer comment ?
Je ne sais pas si vous me laissez le
temps de prolonger ou si
si si, je voulais juste caser un
commentaire. Allez-y, allez-y.
La guerre, la guerre en Ukraine, l'échec
de la prospective ou la prospective en
échec. Je vous laisse terminer, désolé.
Un commentaire de JSR.
Oui. Bah je renvoie JSR à ce qui a été
dit, à ce qu'on a pu dire. Euh vous
continuez votre raisonnement, on
reviendra sur J.
Voilà. Et on reviendra. Voilà. Et donc
réexplorer à nouveau frais. Et là vous
prenez Paul Valérie aussi et puis
ensuite et ensuite Fouo. Je prends il y
en a d'autres mais je prends quelques
quelques références centrales qui
permettront à nos spectateurs de de se
reporter, de regarder ça, posé. Euh il
nous dit "Bah oui, il faut faire preuve
d'imagination. On va essayer de voir les
bords du spectre." dont je parlais de
ça, mais faire preuve d'imagination, il
prend l'exemple de Jul Verne, il prend
l'exemple de WS, il prend l'exemple
d'Edgarpo, enfin vous voyez venir, on
pourrait prendre l'exemple de Barjavel
plus plus récent. Ça veut dire être
capable de s'inscrire dans une forme de
féerie où on imagine les technologies
qui vont faire l'avenir et puis on les
là on prolonge les courbes. C'est-à-dire
que si vous regardez Julverne, il a pas
inventé grand-chose. Euh WS la machine à
voyage dans le temps, il a pas inventé
grand-chose parce qu'il voyageait dans
un temps pensé, un temps très mécanique,
un temps qui est celui le temps longueur
de Berkson mais il a pas voyagé dans le
temps invention. Voyez ? Or, ce que nous
propose Fouco plus tard, c'est de casser
la croûte de nos connaissances qui sont
toutes humaines, proprement humaines, de
s'apercevoir que toute vérité, et c'est
ça qu'on recherche en prospective, c'est
une autre vision de la vérité, du réel.
Bon, que toute vérité finalement est
portée par les mots, par un épistémé qui
est tout humain et de casser cette
croûte pour voir ce qu'il y a de plus
fondamental. Et c'est là où on doit
commencer.
Je vais me faire je vais faire un
commentaire. Je trouve ça très joli.
C'est bien pensé, c'est bien référencé
concrètement.
C'est beau. C'est franchement j'ai
l'impression d'entendre quelqu'un qui me
décrit sa nouvelle voiture.
H
mon comp,
elle roule he roule.
Ouais. Ouais. Non mais d'accord, je vais
vous dire à l'usage
concrètement ça donne quoi ? Parce que
là c'est concrètement c'est beau. Le
côté opératif ça ressemble à quoi ? Bah
écoute pardon. Et on va prendre le
centre d'analyse d'un célèbre ministère
d'un célèbre pays paumé dans le
Nomansland de la géopolitique mondiale.
Bon, ils ont jamais rien anticipé de
concret. Ils ont pondu des rapports à
grand frais. Ils ont dit peut-être que
méfiez-vous d'eux, il faudrait peut-être
ainsi de suite. Bon, résultat les
courses, ils ont rien anticipé.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ce service ?
On le prend, on le casse en morceaux, on
garde les morceaux, on regarde qui a
fait quoi, qui avait publié quoi. On
s'en prend directement au de la
hiérarchie.
à celui qui n'a pas identifié que bah
peut-être que son équipe c'était pas les
couteaux les plus affutés du tiroir ou
que peut-être ça venait de sa propre
faute parce que quand même les couteaux
du tiroir ont fait remonter des choses
qu'il n'a pas écouté qui s'occupe de
faire un audit
de nos cellules de prospective et
d'analyse qui les prend les ouvre de
haut en bas et met les doigts et fouille
un petit peu pour savoir s'ils étaient
bons ou s'ils étaient pas bon qui
vous avez des sacrées questions. Bon,
mon but n'est pas d'être l'inquisiteur
non plus de la prospective et puis de
c'est pas une d'être inquisiteur, c'est
c'est d'avoir un retour sur
investissement. Mais déjà faut savoir en
fait
la France est un pays hyper fiscalisé
alors tout le monde râle sur bah quand
même les infirmières 1500 balles par
mois c'est quand même déconné les
pompiers pas profession à risque quand
même déconner mais les analystes il y a
personne pour les prendre et les scouer
très fort et leur dire bon quand même là
tu es un petit peu mauvais là donc c'est
pas une histoire de faire de
l'inquisition c'est de dire voilà tu es
mauvais tu dégages ou tu es bon on va te
mettre à la place de ton chef parce que
c'est ton chef qui est Ouais,
si vous voulez, je pense que alors je
bote pas en touche hein, soyons clair,
mais je pense que le
on fait un petit mot derrière le le
diagnostic à mon sens est plus complexe
que ça parce qu'il y a une Non, alors
laissez-moi développer. Bah laissez-moi
développer. Si vous condamnez d'emblé
parce que j'ai employé le mot
complexité,
je condamne pas. Le résultat, il est là.
Mais le quel résultat ?
Bah la France géopolitiquement parlant
est une puissance de moyenne
impuissance.
On a rien vu venir avec les Russes,
rien.
La veille, le directeur du de la DRM, il
était encore "Oh, peut-être que mais non
! Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?"
Je pense qu'il y a vraiment deux choses.
D'un côté, il y a les hommes, de
l'autre, il y a les lois qui font les
hommes et que les hommes font. Voilà. Et
là, il y a j'allais dire si naufrage il
doit y avoir, ce que je ne partage pas
totalement, ce que je partage pas du
tout même. Euh,
il est collectif et si vous voulez,
il y a personne de responsable.
Mais la responsabilité individuelle, ça
nous vient du christianisme. Ça vient
d'un postulat qui est que l'homme est
doué de libre arbitre. Mais voilà, une
belle fable. On pourrait revenir. Vous
me parliez justement d'être opératoire
dans la prospective. Il faut commencer
par réinterroger ce qu'est vraiment le
libre arbitre. Le monde entier repose
sur la responsabilité individuelle, y
compris d'ailleurs l'Orient alors même
que on peut pas les taxer d'avoir été
irrigué par le christianisme. Et pour
autant cette fable fonctionne et au
titre de cette fable là, on voudrait
qu'il y ait Infiné toujours responsable
pour l'ensemble des mots. Ça fonctionne
pas. C'est vrai que la stratégie enfin
c'est pas la stratégie, c'est la
mécanique du bouquet émissaire est
extrêmement tentante parce que il faut
une victime expiatoire pour tout soit
mais quand bien même ça soulage, ça ne
règle rien. Ça c'est la première chose.
La deuxième chose, c'est que si on veut,
j'allais dire modifier, repétrir la pâte
de l'intérieur, ça ne peut se faire ce
qui s'est fait dans le temps long, parce
qu'il a fallu quand même plus de 2000
ans pour en arriver là et davantage, si
on replace ça à des aires plus
préhistoriques, ne peut se changer que
dans le temps long ou au moins au moins
à l'échelle d'une génération. Que
croyez-vous que j'essaie modestement de
faire en formant mes jeunes à science Po
? Je peux vous couper ?
Oui. Bien. Vous êtes là, c'est
un avion qui se plante. Bon, la plupart
du temps, c'est la faute du pilote. On
est d'accord ?
Alors, non, on n'est pas d'accord. C'est
non, c'est euh effectivement c'est de la
faute du pilote. 70 % un peu plus
maintenant euh d'accidents sont
imputables au facteur humain parce que
les machines sont de plus en plus
perfectionnées. Mais vous savez bien que
les les accidents bah vous me donnez
l'exemple de montrer en quoi c'est
véritablement complexe et ce qui est
valable pour le coup, pas pour la
prospective, c'est encore autre chose,
mais pour la prévision dimension, une
des dimensions de la de l'anticipation
est valable effectivement aussi dans le
cas aéronautique. des plaques de
rezenériens
pour nos spectateurs rapidement.
L'alignement des plaques, voilà. Bon,
chaque plaque a un trou. Si les trous
s'alignent, l'accident et la connerie
trouvent son chemin. Si les trous ne
s'alignent pas, et bien chaque plaque
empêche finalement le trou d'avant de de
laisser passer l'erreur et il y a pas
d'accident. Et donc l'alignement des
plaques fait qu'il peut y avoir un
accident. Une des plaques est humaines
et il est vrai que sur le plan
technologique, on arrive quand même à
éliminer la plupart des défauts et
souvent l'Airfance 447, c'est un
problème humain. En effet, problème de
pitau peut-être, mais manque de sens de
l'air de la part des pilotes. Et voilà.
Bon, à ceci près aussi que il est plus
facile de faire reposer la
responsabilité individuelle et de mettre
en cause la responsabilité individuelle
de pilotes morts que d'arrêter toute une
flotte d'avion. Mais en l'occurrence, il
y avait une responsabilité humaine. Donc
euh oui,
ce commentaire n'engage que vous.
Ce commentaire n'engage que moi. Mais
pour le coup, bon euh on est quand même
assez d'accord pour dire que ça reste ça
reste un enjeu plus léger à aborder.
Voilà. Euh et donc oui, euh
essentiellement la faute humaine mais
pas exclusivement.
Donc le navire France,
notre air françis,
notre patrie,
les pilotes,
ils sont bons, pas bons. Est-ce que je
prends un billet pour Air France One ?
Est-ce que
les écoles qui ont formé les pilotes de
Air France One, ils étaient bons ? Ils
sont capables d'anticiper, ils sont
capables de faire le tour de l'avion
correctement avant de monter dedans. Ils
sont capables de mettre le nez, de
regarder les les fiches du mécano. Ils
sont capables d'avoir une discussion
avec le mécano. Ils sont capables
d'avoir une discussion avec le mec qui
balit la piste, qui change les pneus.
Est-ce qu'on a des bons pilotes ou
est-ce que on a des pilotes ? Bah voilà,
ils font du tour de couillon. font du
transport.
Voilà, il continue les courbes, il
volent, il fait beau. Bon bah là, il y a
la tempête. En mettant de côté, j'allais
dire tout l'agurnament tau prospectif
qu'il faudrait faire et le changement de
mentalité des esprits et qui ne tient
pas à un seul homme mais à l'ensemble.
Je mets de côté ça mais je le rappelle
quand même parce que c'est le cœur du
propos. Je trouve qu'ils ne sont pas si
mauvais que ça. Et je vais vous dire
pourquoi. Je vais vous dire pourquoi.
Non mais quand on voilà quand on
s'analyse, on se désole. Quand on
compare, on se console.
On se rassure.
Voilà, on se rassure. On se console. On
se dit qu'on n pas si mauvais. Pourquoi
? Parce qu'il y a quand même une
puissance d'inspiration. je dis
d'inspiration qui me semble-t-il
existe en France. Alors, tout dépend de
l'objectif qu'on se fixe, hein. Encore
une fois, là aussi je je fais une note
de bas de page rapidement mais euh on
peut pas euh prouver euh la supériorité
d'un système de valeur sur un autre,
hein. La
l'éthique n'est pas du même ordre que la
vérité, la recherche de la vérité.
L'éthique dans la prospective. Ah bah
bien sûr, mais
alors qu'en face de nous alors qu'en
face de nous on peut être
potentiellement
en face de nous, on peut avoir
potentiellement des puissances sans
éthique, sans foi ni loi.
Attention, ce qu'on entend par
draper dans l'étendard de la vertu. Mais
la prospective est une éthique de la
vérité, c'est-à-dire
il s'agit de quel est quels sont les
devoirs et les prescriptions auxquelles
on doit s'astreindre pour finalement se
forger une vérité. Et sur ce sole de
vérité, c'est comme ça que fonctionne la
philosophie, un terrain de jeu sur ce
socle de vérité, sur ce terrain de jeu
est dicté des règles dont on estime
qu'elles porte des valeurs, dont on
estime, mais on ne peut pas le prouver,
qu'elles porte des valeurs supérieures
aux autres. Donc une fois qu'on s'est
fixé un certain nombre de valeurs pour
aller vite les valeurs portées par la
France et les valeurs portées par
l'Union européenne et l'Europe en
général
valeurs de façade ou les valeurs
réelles.
Et bien là c'est là où je trouve que la
puissance d'inspiration de la France est
plutôt plus forte que les autres.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'il y a quand même
une vision de cette fameuse autonomie
stratégique européenne qui vise à ne pas
s'aligner
sur l'allié pour autant historique et
indéfectible américain qui pour autant
ne veut pas se dissoudre dans une Union
européenne qui parfois est un peu
asceptisée et qui parfois porte des
valeurs que l'on peut considérer comme
étant de façade voilà et qui trouve
cette voix médiane courageusement il
faut quand même le rappeler parce parce
que c'est quand même plus facile et vous
voyez les les quelques références
auxquelles que je peux avoir en tête.
C'est plus facile d'hurler avec la
meute, c'est plus facile de s'aligner
que d'essayer de porter une voie
médiane. Aujourd'hui, à grand trait, on
est dans une rebipolarisation entre les
États-Unis et la Chine. Bon voilà, ça
c'est pas un scoop, hein. Voilà. Mais ce
qui est un ce qui est quand même
compliqué et ce qui est quand même
courageux, c'est de se dire est-ce qu'on
va essayer de porter une voix médiane,
la voix européenne ? Et l'enjeu est
fort. Pourquoi ? Parce que euh et là ça
n'engage que moi, mais je me drape
derrière Paul Valérie, voyez, pour c'est
je me je me réfugie derrière cette
autorité intellectuelle et morale pour
dire que je pense que
l'Europe est est le continent de
l'esprit avec un grand eux. l'axe Athè,
Rome, Jérusalem euh à irrigué, enfanté
euh et les États-Unis sont une côte
arraché de l'Europe, tout ce qui fait
euh
pousser jusqu'à Babylone si vous voulez,
tout ce qui fait l'homme. Voilà. Et donc
ce rôle euh c'est un rôle historique,
c'est un rôle qui est euh encore actuel
et qui ne s'arrête pas à quelques
décennies, des quelques décennies qui
nous séparent de ce diagnostic fait par
Paul Valérie et donc il faut le porter
aujourd'hui, mais il y a une nécessaire
réinvention. Alors là, je je vous vois
en parlant de réinvention, tout le monde
veut réinventer tout. Mais pour le coup,
il faut vraiment réinventer l'esprit.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on est dans une
forme de disparition de l'homme. C'est
ça don ce dont on s'aperçoit pas, mais
pas la disparition liée au changement
climatique. Une disparition liée en fait
à ce qui devient notre incapacité à
nommer les choses. Or, l'homme existe
depuis de siècles. En gros, depuis que
les sciences humaines sont des sciences
humaines. Avant, il y en avait pas. On
faisait de la philosophie sur tout un
tas de sujets, mais l'homme n'était pas
central.
Et ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
avoir en tête parce que l'homme est
central mais en même temps il est en
train de se déconstruire avec son
incapacité à nommer les choses. Et donc
il faut réinventer l'esprit qui va nous
permettre de nommer et de se positionner
par rapport à ce qui fait vérité. Prenez
tout autour de vous. On discute de
savoir si un tel a bombardé le barrage
ou un tel a bombardé le barrage. Il y a
une déferlande de vérité. C'est
quand même important quand même.
Bien sûr je dis pas que le sujet est pas
important. Je dis qu'on assiste en fait
à une incapacité
à trouver les faits, à euh avoir des
vérités. En fait, il y a une somme de
vérité alternative
tel que les mots perdent leur sens.
On reviendra on reviendra sur les
et c'est ça qu'il faut arriver à
relancer.
On reviendra sur
et ça me semble être proprement
européen.
On reviendra sur les troub les
troubadour du mot médiatique
qui se sont d'ailleurs fait piéger pour
l'histoire de Nordstream une première
fois. Je pense que il faudrait qu'ils
prennent un peu plus de temps pour
construire leur raisonnement. Ce qui
éviterait peut-être de radicaliser une
grande partie de la population par la
suite. Mais ça ça c'est juste un
constat. Pour revenir, pour appeler un
chat un chat, je vais vous demander de
penser contre vous-même et d'enlever vos
lunettes roses de philosophe.
Penser contre son cerveau, c'est
exactement ce que pensait Michel Fouco
et c'est ce qu'il disait. Pour revoir
ça, il faut penser contre son cerveau.
Riche déduction. Et donc pour revenir,
pensez contre vous-même. Vous le faites
comment ? Quand vous venez de me dire
voilà
la France, l'Europe, la vertu de
l'homme, cette grande voix diplomatique,
cette voix humaniste,
se projeter et rayonner dans le monde
pour pacifier le monde, franchement,
vous m'avez conquis. Lancez-vous en
politique. Vous m'avez conquis là.
Mais c'est parce que je le pense
regardez regardez parce que je le pense
c'est parce que c'est pas beau. C'est
vital.
Je suis d'accord avec vous. OK, c'est
vital. Maintenant, je vous demande de
penser contre vous-même avec des gens
veulent, vilains, méchants, prêt à tout
pour nous casser la figure parce que on
leur a fait des crocheppieds dans le
passé qui pour eux sont impardonnables,
qui selon leur culture, leur voix, leur
façon d'être, bah je vais me mettre à
côté du pont puis je vais regarder ton
cadavre passer mais je vais pas oublier
puis je vais surtout pas pardonner
le temps long chez d'autres puissance.
Donc enlevez vos lunettes, on se fait
une petite prospective là.
On est dans un océan de requin, on est
là, il y a une expression à la mode chez
les militaires qui est en train vraiment
médiatiquement de percer, c'est
l'Europe, c'est un troupeau de
brontosaure au milieu d'un épisode de
Jurassic Park avec les tyrannosaures.
D'accord ? Donc je voudrais savoir,
est-ce que vous êtes capable de vous
faire pousser les dents ou il faut que
je vous coince dans un coin pour que
vous vouliez qu'on puisse les voir ? Je
vous écoute.
Si vous voulez une pierre, vous l'avez
dans les mains, elle est ce qu'elle est.
Vous pouvez la tailler, il faut la
tailler, mais il faut savoir quelle
pierre vous taillez. Soit vous avez
affaire à du granit, soit vous avez à
faire une pierre tendre. Si vous avez
affaire à du granit, il y a pas de
problème. Mais vous ferez jamais d'une
pierre tendre du granite. Faut savoir
dans quelle compétition, dans quel dans
quel couloir de natation on nage. Ce qui
ne veut pas dire que l'Europe doit
abandonner toute volonté ou toute
ambition de puissance militaire,
martiale, stratégique, bien au
contraire. Mais quand vous n'êtes pas
capable et véritablement il y a eu quand
même du retard de prix même s'il y a des
efforts et s'il faut pas abandonner
cette arène là, mais quand vous n'êtes
pas capable de supplanter selon des
règles et un terrain de jeu les autres
compétiteurs, il faut il faut réinventer
le terrain de jeu et changer les règles.
Il y a deux façons d'innover. On fait de
la prospective, on est bien d'accord
hein. Donc on reste quand même au bon
niveau de réflexion puis après on verra
le cas précis des des gens sur lesquels
vous voulez qu'on pousse les dents. Là
je suis en train de m'imaginer. Je
prends des étudiants de sens, je les
lâche dans la jungle et je leur dis
réinventez votre
territoire. Attendez, je viens déjà sur
l'aspect plus profond, la strade
profonde et puis après on viendra sur la
strade de surface.
D'abord d'abord le Chad histoire de les
faire bronzer un peu avant.
Voilà donc la partie innovation soit
vous faites du de l'océan rouge comme on
dit, soit de l'océan bleu, du red Ocean
ou bleu Ocean.
Elon Musk, lui, il a innové en faisant
du blue ocean. C'està-dire qu'il a dit
"OK, vos règles sur les bagnoles, elles
sont bien. La voiture c'est ça,
battez-vous entre vous et faites-vous
une place au soleil." C'est parfait. Et
moi, j'arrive avec Tesla et je dynamite
les règles et j'invente d'autres règles.
Et ça a marché. Voilà. Bah là, c'est la
même chose. Quel est le l'ADN
fondamental de l'Europe ? Je vous l'ai
dit, je vais vous le redire. C'est
l'esprit. Donc et on le voit déjà dans
une espèce d'adolescence un peu ingrate
boutonneuse là que c'est ça qu'il lui
faut. C'est-à-dire que là elle est sur
la RGPD quand d'autres sont sur l'IA.
Euh elle est sur le DSA quand d'autres
sont sur le deep learning. Ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas faire de deep
learning et avoir des algorithmes. Ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut laisser les
ordinateurs quantiques. Ça veut pas dire
et cetera et cetera. Mais ça veut dire
qu'elle est davantage sur la puissance
de la norme. Et si on va un cran
au-dessus, quand le langage et que la
capacité à nommer les choses, à faire
exister le réel va se déconstruire à la
faveur, si je puis m'exprimer ainsi, de
technologies telles que Neuralink où on
va arriver à une forme d'apauvrissement,
voire peut-être d'obsolescence,
d'évanescence du langage. Et bien, il
faudrait être capable d'être au cœur de
ce qu'est l'esprit. Là, on est dans une
prospective forte et j'ai mes lunettes
roses. Alors, je les enlève. Voilà. Mais
sur le dessus, sur le dessus, mais sur
le dessus, il y a effectivement la
capacité ici et maintenant, dans les
quelques années à venir, d'affronter
des menaces qui elles sont encore
solides, s'expriment selon les termes de
la puissance actuelle et sur lesquels
toute naïveté et toute lunette rose est
à proscrire. Et là, il y a eu des
initiatives fortes dont, j'allais dire
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire qu'elle
compte pour rien. Voilà, je vais les
citer, je vais en citer quelques-unes et
puis ensuite on verra pourquoi c'est pas
suffisant et encore il faudrait se
positionner autrement. C'est quelques
initiatives fortes. Euh c'est notamment
le fond européen de défense. des
initiatives comme la facilité européenne
de paix qui permet quand même une aide
substantielle
à la guerre en Ukraine et d'aider nos
camarades ukrainiens face à une Russie
dont on dit je pense à bon droit qu'il
faut ménager un équilibre parce que
géographiquement ici et maintenant ou
dans les 10 ans qui suivent elle restera
quand même en Europe et que si on veut
une architecture de sécurité européenne
qui peut être le soubassement d'une
autonomie stratégique européenne et
bien, il faut la reconstruire et donc
tout ça est à faire et tout ça se fait.
Est-ce que c'est suffisant ? Pas encore.
Est-ce que ça doit pour autant ça doit
pour autant être le seul axe et que l'on
doit laisser la partie bienêtre rose ?
Non, les deux sont amenés de concert. Et
quand on entend parler aujourd'hui de
communauté politique européenne, ça fait
sourire. On se dit "Oui, ils sont
rencontrés à Prague, quel est le sujet
?" Bon, le sujet c'est la rencontre. pas
que ça. Si vous compez ce que fait la
communauté politique européenne
nouvellement réunie avec euh le Conseil
de l'Europe par exemple, et ben le
Conseil de l'Europe à vocation à
intégrer des nouveautés. C'est hors
Union européenne, je le rappelle pour
spectateur, mais c'est hors Union
européenne mais sa vocation à travailler
à l'intégration européenne, à sa montée
en puissance. Très bien. Et bien la
communauté politique européenne a
vocation à préparer un peu la décision,
les textes, les sujets de façon
informelle à être en quelque sorte une
initiative européenne d'intervention pas
exclusivement militaire mais sur les
enjeux l'ensemble des enjeux qui ont un
sens. Donc par rapport au pays qui nous
regardent avec les dents à serrer,
l'Europe ne fait pas rien. Et c'est là
j'en reviens avec toute première
question sur les pilotes français
sont-ils bons pas bons ? Ils sont plutôt
inspirés parce que pardon pour le
Cocorico, mais ça reste quand même la
figure de prou de cette autonomie
stratégique européenne. S'il y a encore
une volonté stratégique comprenait le
bien en Europe, c'est quand même le fait
de la France. Voilà, parce que pour la
partie allemande, ça reste quand même
porté par une certaine forme, je le dis
sans véhmen mais par une forme de
mercantilisme quand même. Voilà,
économie, énergie, voilà, commerce avec
la Chine. C'est pas un jugement de
valeur, c'est un constat. Là, j'allais
dire les intérêts sont absolument
orthogonaux. Donc je pense que ça c'est
une petite prime quand même au moins à
l'inspiration française. C'est peut-être
pas suffisant.
Bon, allez, on va s'inspirer. Donc là,
j'étais en train de regarder vos deux
étudiants de chancepoep en train de
dépérir dans la jungle amazonienne
par manque de formation.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire pour avoir
qu'est-ce que c'est un bon
prospectiviste, un bon analyste ? C'est
quelqu'un qui pense en dehors de la
boîte. C'est quelqu'un qui va chercher
de l'information coûte que coûte par
tous les moyens. C'est quelqu'un qui
pense, on va dire pour reprendre les les
éléments de langage de nos directeurs de
com.
[Musique]
Donc c'est c'est quoi ou c'est
la gaogé ?
Vous voyez ce que c'est la ga ?
La gogé redéfinir le terme s'il vous
plaît.
Les enfants de Spartiat
vers 7 9 12 15 je m'en rappelle plus. On
les foutait tous à la porte. On disait
maintenant tu vas dans la forêt, tu
reviens si tu survis.
Ah, la méthode Sparciat. OK, d'accord.
La méthode Sparciate, c'est battez-vous
entre vous, déchirez-vous parce que en
face ils sont encore plus méchants. On
élève des raptors on élève des
directeurs de com. Et comment on fait
pour élever des raptors ?
Est-ce que la situation nécessite des
raptors ou est-ce que la la situation
nécessite une vision, une inspiration ?
Les deux, mon général,
est-ce qu'on plane ou est-ce qu'on
commence à être actif ?
Les deux, mais les deux, mon général,
simplement, c'est pas forcément les
mêmes. Est-ce que Est-ce que comment
sous l'ancien régime, on envoyait les
moines se battre ? Et est-ce que les
Vous saviez déjà que c'était des moines
?
Est-ce qu'on envoyait les comment les
bon, il y a les moines soldats, les
templiers, d'accord, mais est-ce qu'on
envoyait les moines se battre et est-ce
qu'on envoyait les guerriers méditer ?
Bon, euh, je pense qu'à chacun son rôle.
Donc il faut ceux qui sont dans
l'inspiration et qui font de la
prospective sont dans l'inspiration et
font de la prospective, ce qui veut pas
dire déconnecter du terrain. Voilà, on
est d'accord. Je vais revenir très de
façon très pragmatique à votre première
question. Ce qu'est un bon
prospectiviste et comment s'y prendre au
moins dans les grandes lignes. Voilà. Et
puis ceux les Raptors comme vous dites
pour reprendre votre terme euh là c'est
tout autre chose. Et là il faut aussi
faire de la stratégie. C'est encore un
autre volet la stratégie. Même si
prospective et stratégie effectivement
ça s'articule, on est d'accord mais
c'est encore un autre volet. Donc sur le
volet prospectif, qu'est-ce qui fait un
bon prospectivisme ? C'est effectivement
déjà quelqu'un qui va faire c'est corps,
âme esprit. Pardon d'être ésotérique
mais je vais être très concret.
On va polir notre pierre.
Corp. Exactement. Corp faire l'état de
l'art d'une question. Mais faire l'état
de l'art d'une question c'est pas se
dire "OK, alors l'environnement,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? La démographie,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? L'économie,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? La politique,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? la sécurité, le
culturel, le cultuel encore que s'il
faisit encore que s'il faisait ça, ce
serait déjà pas si mal. Mais
voilà, ce serait déjà pas si mal.
Compris la blague sur cette chaîne.
Voilà. Mais cela dit, c'est pas ça.
C'est pas ça. Pourquoi ? Parce que quand
on fait ça, on repart avec les mêmes
bases, les mêmes courbes et on les
prolonge dans le même sens et nos
atavismes prennent leur lait. Et voilà.
Donc c'est mort. Quand on part comme ça,
c'est mort. Ce qu'il faut, c'est
réinterroger ce qui semblait être un
fait, ce qui semblait être une pierre,
un truc dur, un truc qu'on ne discute
pas, un 1 + 1 é= 2. Voilà, il faut
rediscuter les choses. Je prends
l'exemple du changement climatique. Plus
un poil polémique, donc c'est bien.
Voilà, le changement climatique. Euh,
personnellement, je fais ma thèse à
Polytechnique. Je m'y intéresse depuis
2003. à cette époque-là euh quand vous
disiez et là je le dis assez clairement
quand vous disiez au ministère des
armées de la défense à l'époque tiens je
vais faire une thèse sur le changement
climatique parce que je pense que c'est
bien d'avoir une vision scientifique des
choses pour ensuite euh instruire ce que
pourrai être les conséquences en terme
de sécurité internationale du changement
climatique.
Quelle année votre thèse ?
Euh soutenu en 2010 25 mai 2010 ou 2008
les répercussions du réchauffement
climatique sur le livre blanc de la
défense française amphithé foche.
Ouais non mais attendez. Attendez euh
quand j'ai fait mon master avant de
préparer la thèse 2003, voyez, et ce que
vous mentionnez là, c'est euh j'allais
dire c'est les débuts euh les débuts
d'une réflexion euh qui aujourd'hui
honnêtement a pas beaucoup évolué. Voilà
pour ce que j'en sais. Voilà, mais euh
pour ce que j'en sais. Et donc euh ce
sujet-là euh si vous voulez, si vous le
prenez euh en prenant les modèles, et
bien vous arrivez à une situation qui
est oui, il y a un changement climatique
bien sûr. Euh est-ce qui va être
catastrophique ?
les les climatologues qui sont les plus
mesurés disent "Ce sera pas forcément la
catastrophe annoncée mais ça va donner
un monde." Je cite Hervé Leeut par
exemple qui était mon directeur de
laboratoire qui est un de nos plus
éminents éminents climatologues qui dit
"Ce sera un monde différent." Alors je
dis "Mais Hervé quand tu dis ça sur BFM
TV là ça percute pas. Enfin personne te
comprend pas ce que tu veux dire." Bah
oui, il me dit "Pece que je veux pas
alarmer euh je veux dire véritablement
les choses, les objectiver, ce sera un
monde différent." Donc effectivement, il
y aura peut-être plus de d'inondation,
plus de tempête, plus d'épisodes chauds.
Euh ça va être inconfortable, les
assurances vont être plus chères et
cetera et cetera. Ça va accroire la
facture la la fracture entre les riches
et les pauvres, mais ce sera peut-être
pas un monde, même si c'est pas exclu
hein, à plus de 4 degrés, qui soit
totalement invivable. Bon et donc cette
version là est difficile à entendre
parce qu'elle est pas peut-être pas
suffisamment catastrophiste et donc elle
ne suscite pas suffisamment de réaction.
Et donc là où je vais en venir c'est que
quand on établit l'effet hein, je vous
disais corps âme esprit corps, on
établit l'effet l'état de l'art, on
regarde véritablement la vérité qu'il y
a derrière les choses que l'on ne
réinterroge plus. Est-ce que quand on
fait de la prospective qui n'est pas de
la prévision mais de l'exploration et de
l'anticipation, est-ce qu'on doit se
dire le changement climatique ? Bon bah
ça va être une catastrophe. Il faut tout
arrêter. Il faut changer de monde. C'est
4 vols maximum par tête dans le monde.
Voyez à qui je fais référence. Et on
décout à fait. Et on décarbone à marche
forcée.
Oui, c'est ce que dirait c'est c'est une
solution sans regret. Évidemment qu'il
faut pas il faut décarboner autant que
possible. Est-ce que ça doit être la
seule voie ? Évidemment que non. Déjà
parce qu'on est en retard et que et que
ça suffira pas. Voilà. Donc ça c'est
déjà un constat pragmatique, c'est que
quand bien même la catastrophe serait
telle que ça ne suffirait pas. Là c'est
un vrai problème. Ensuite, on l'a
souvent dit hein, c'est opposé des
problèmes économiques et sociaux avec
des problèmes environnementaux. Il faut
bien vivre aussi tout de suite. Moi, je
suis pas prêt à laisser mon téléphone
portable. Vos caméras là, elles sont
faites de terre rare. Bon bah voilà,
tout est dit hein. Le monde est pétri,
ça va pas se changer comme ça d'un coup
d'un seul. les voitures électriques,
elles sont pas forcément euh vertueuses
parce que peuvent être alimentées par de
l'électricité, fait par une centrale à
charbon et cetera et cetera. Donc quand
on réinterroge toute cette complexité,
on se voit que cette façade, elle est
pas aussi évidente. Et puis si on va
plus loin, on nous dit quoi ? On nous
dit bah il faut décarboner parce qu'on
vit dans un monde fini et sous-entendu
qu'on ne quittera pas, dont on ne peut
pas imaginer que l'on puisse vis-à-vis
de ce monde euphémiser notre présence
autrement et dont on n'envisage pas
finalement qu'on puisse faire autre
chose que prolonger les courbes de la
vie et qui vont s'opposer aux courbes de
l'environnement. Donc finalement le
travail prospectif est complètement
annihilé à ce stade-là. C'està-dire que
par exemple et c'est pas une
prospective, j'allais dire des plus des
plus des plus de plus haut de volet.
Elon Musk nous dit "Bon bah moi mon idée
c'est peut-être qu'il faut coloniser
d'autres planètes."
On Gérô Cletche, il nous dit quoi ?
Et ben moi je vous dis qu'en fait
l'homme va changer dans sa nature dans
les 25 prochaines années et que l'homme
tel que vous le connaissez dans la façon
dont il se représente qui a selon Michel
Fouco que 200 ans d'existence de vie.
cet homme-là moderne, post-moderne, vous
pouvez décliner comme vous voulez,
moderne, post-moderne, c'est pas trop
mal comme qualificatif. Industriel,
voilà, industriel, euh celui qui a
raisonné un homme cartésien en fait,
hein. On est toujours l'homme cartésien,
hein. Toutes les philosophies qui sont
venues après, on les a pas prises en
compte. On est cartésien, on a raisonné
la nature euh pour améliorer notre
confort et puis faire en sorte de nous
augmenter la l'économie est une
gigantesque augmentation de notre corps.
Bon, très bien. Pour satisfaire des
besoins toujours plus importants, bon,
on est là-dedans. Bah, cet homme-là, il
va disparaître dans moins de 25 ans. Et
donc, en fait, on essaie de régler des
problèmes qu'on aura pu dans 25 ans.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ? Parce
qu'en fait, on aura changé.
OK. Pour devenir quoi ou quoi ou quoi ?
Alors ça ou quoi ou quoi, je ne sais
pas. Mais pour semble-t-il, je reprends
ce terme-là, euphémiser notre présence
au monde de telle manière que les
barrières que l'on se représente
aujourd'hui ne seront pas forcément les
barrières physiques ne seront peut-être
pas forcément les barrières qui seront
les bonnes. D'autres barrières pourront
se faire jour qui seront peut-être, je
le disais là rapidement, la barrière du
langage. La déconstruction du langage va
peut-être amener notre socle de
connaissance, nos représentations du
monde, notre représentation du réel à
changer. et changeant notre
représentation du réel a changé même nos
représentations des limites du monde et
ce monde là. Donc en fait, on est qu'on
dit souvent oui, il faut se préparer à
la guerre de demain avec les moyens
d'après-demain, en tout cas pas les
moyens d'hier. Bah pour la prospective,
c'est la même chose. Et c'est ça penser
contre son cerveau. C'est pas se dire le
changement climatique, il y a une
limite, il faut décarboner, j'ai
prolongé les courbes, comment on va
comment on va vivre dans un monde sans
carbone avec quel type de maison, quel
type de transport ? et se dire est-ce
que l'homme qui se confronte aux limites
du monde aura toujours les mêmes besoins
physiques, aura toujours les mêmes
questions existentielles, aura-t-il
toujours les mêmes problèmes ? C'est ça
la vraie bonne question. Je dis
toujours, juste pour plonger et pour
illustrer le propos, quand à mes
étudiants, je leur dis faites-moi une
prospective sur l'automobile
prostit, ils prennent des postites et
tout ça et en quelques bullet points
pour vous à l'horizon, alors je laisse
phosphorer un quart d'heure,
l'automobile dans 25 ans ou dans 50 ans,
c'est quoi ? Et ben la première chose
des la première des choses pardon à
laquelle ils pensent quand ils sont
lancés sur cette prospective, c'est à la
voiture. Et ben c'est mort. La
prospective là, elle est morte. Si vous
commencez à penser à l'avenir de la
bagnole en pensant à la bagnole, c'est
mort. Il faut penser, il faut revenir
aux questions fondamentales,
quelques-unes en vrac. Euh quelle sera
euh la rupture qui technologique par
exemple, et c'est déjà pensé dans la
boîte mais soyons simple, quelle est la
rupture technologique qui pour le selon
vous euh va advenir et sera hyper
impactante dans la génération qui vient
? Quel est le grand changement des
mentalités qui va advenir dans les 25
ans et qui sera impactant ? Quelle est
la question pour la vie ? Quel est le
combat pour la vie, hein, dans une
logique un peu polémologique, on y
reviendra, qui fera sens dans les 25
ans. Qu'est-ce qui pourrait être euh
qu'est-ce qui pourrait être le
conducteur un peu le l'aiguillon du sens
? Parce qu'on est toujours dans une
recherche de sens, hein. Si on est là,
vous et moi aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on
recherche du sens. Voilà. Euh dans 25
ans. Et quand vous aurez pensé tout ça,
vous penserez ensuite les transports,
vous penserez ensuite l'habitation, vous
penserez l'économie d'aujourd'hui. Vous
verrez qu'elle va être singulièrement
changée. Et au sein de tout ça, en
revenant, vous allez repenser la
bagnole.
Et la bagnole, peut-être que ce sera une
espèce de combinaison si tentait que se
transporter physiquement et encore du
sens, c'est le cas de le dire, que ça
réponde encore à un besoin. Et bien,
quelle pourrait être la voiture ?
Quelle est la chose la plus pertinente
qu'on vous ait fait remonter ? Et bien
la chose la plus pertinente. Alors je je
l'enjolive un peu pour le les besoins de
l'émission là mais Ouais ouais ouais un
peu pour les besoins de l'émission.
Respectez vos étudiants.
Mais non mais parce qu'en fait c'est
toujours un peu je fais un peu de
maillotique voyez donc je les aide un
peu et c'est normal je suis là pour ça
faut que faut quand même que je justifie
ma position donc je fais un peu de mon
salaire qui est pas bien non je fais ça
je fais ça à titre bénévole pour la
carte de visite. Non non mais vraiment
voilà à titre à titre bénévole
non c'est de la transmission de la
transmission et donc ce qui m'a été
remonté
si c'était de l'infiltration vous le
diriez
vous savez j'ai des lunettes roses mo
donc
là c'est du triple foyer
là c'est là c'est lunettes ros donc là
je vous exp
je serais peut-être capable de le dire
en plus situation la plus compliquée en
vol que vous ayez amé à gérer
je vous la raconte juste aprè je finis
juste sur la bagnole Et après je vous la
raconte la situation.
Changer le mot bagnole par France comme
ça on va savoir où vous allez aller.
Donc pensez pas à la bagnole, pensez la
France ou pensez pas à la France.
D'accord.
Oui mais juste pour la voiture et ben le
point qui est le plus important qui a
abouti de cette maillotique c'était au
fil de toutes ces questions
existentielles et l'entau noire que je
vous ai dressé c'était de dire en fait
la vraie question c'est celle de
l'individu et de l'individualité.
Paul Valérie disait non mais disait tout
change, tout est indéfini, on est dans
une dislocation permanente et pour
autant les règles de vie d'aujourd'hui
sont le mariage, la propriété, le code
civil, les guerres, l'aménagement, le
transport, tout nous laisse à penser
qu'on est des individus. Et ben
aujourd'hui, on est dans uneusion une
illusion pardon qui est qu'on se prend
encore pour des individus alors qu'on
l'est pas tellement. Et donc la question
liée à la voiture c'était de dire est-ce
que la notion d'individualité
dans 25 ou 50 ans aura encore un sens au
point que le transport individuel,
l'American Way of Life avec la liberté
incarnée par la voiture, parce que c'est
ça quand même, c'est d'abord la liberté,
la voiture, bon est-ce que ça aura
encore vraiment du sens ? Vous conjuguez
ça avec la question de la propriété
plutôt que l'usage ? parce qu'avoir sa
bagnole, c'est encore quelque chose qui
a qui a du sens aujourd'hui, même si on
est davantage dans l'usage. Des vendeurs
voiture pour le lètement complètement.
Et ben si vous conjuguez tout ça, vous
apercevez que vous allez avoir
énormément de nouveaux ressorts inédits
pour repenser précisément la prospective
de la voiture et qu'on est bien loin de
je pars de ma voiture et je tors un peu
les formes pour imaginer à quoi elle
pourrait ressembler dans 50 ans. Voilà
un peu l'état de l'art. Je reviendrai
sur l'âme et l'esprit qu'il faut pour
faire de la bonne prospective. Mais
l'état de là, réinterroger les modèles
et les évidences pour le changement
climatique, pour la voiture, ça commence
là. Faut commencer très très en
profondeur. Et donc la situation en vol.
C'est ça que vous me posiez.
Non, l'âme l'âme m'intéresse
l'âme.
Alors, vous pensez l'âme l'âme dans quel
sens
? L'âme au sens animation. Animée, doté
d'une âme. C'est la maillotique dont je
vous parlais quand je vous ai dit j'ai
un peu enjolivé. J'ai un peu enjolivé
parce que euh les étudiants
mon dieu
je suis euh
panéiste. Exactantéiste.
Alors pour pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas le terme,
alors c'est euh vous avez pasfari mais
sans Dieu. C'est ça.
Vous avez le panthéisme qui est Dieu est
en toute chose. Et puis vous avez le
pananthéisme ce qui était Spinoza. En
réalité, on dit soin qui était
panthéiste, mais il était pas
nonantéiste en fait. Euh qui est Dieu
est en toute chose, mais à l'image de ce
que croient les juifs avec le Timsum, il
y a une rétraction de telle sorte qu'il
monde exister tel qu'il est. Il est
immanent au monde mais avec j'allais
dire une touche de transcendance qui
fait que il est à la fois causer
conséquence de ce qu'il engendre tout en
étant un petit peu légèrement en dehors.
Voilà donc c'est Dieu est dans le monde
et un peu quand même en dehors du monde.
Mais bon ça ça va nous emmener un petit
peu loin mais voilà disons panantéiste.
Donc donc déiste. Oui. J'imagine qu'il y
a une entité dont on fait partie
intégrante.
Nous on appelle ça un ami imaginaire
mais c'est pas grave. euh revenons
revenons à nos moutons.
L'âme
et ensuite
l'esprit.
Alors l'âme c'est un deuxième temps du
travail du prospectiviste. Il est bien
réinterrogé et qu'il a cassé la croûte
de toutes les évidences qui se soit déjà
forgé une autre vision de la réalité
présente. Donc il fait son lit là, il
prédispose. Il faut quand même arriver
au bout du compte à un scénario et donc
il va falloir lier
scénario, une finalité,
un scénario, une histoire. Il y a pas de
de bonnes prospectives sans récit, sans
un récit bien ficelé.
Je glisse la question de la communauté.
Quel est le point de départ de la
prospective si ce n'est pas la finalité
pratique ?
Ah mais c'est la
ça c'est ça, il y a les listes il y a
les mais complètement. Mais non mais
c'est une finalité pratique en ce que
changer la mentalité au travers d'une
bonne exploration prospective. Je
prenais l'exemple du modèle du
changement climatique. Je prenais
l'exemple de l'automobile dans 50 ans.
Si vous associez euh si vous associez un
industriel à cette réflexion là, de fait
aller euh de la même façon voir ses ses
bureaux d'études. Forcément, ça va
changer son état d'esprit. C'est ça le
vrai changement. Il est comme ça. Il se
fait par infiltration. C'est vous qui
disiez ça, c'est je reprends votre mot.
Mais il est il est pertinent. C'est
évidemment ça. Il se fait comme ça.
C'est on se change soi-même et on change
la société par voie de fête. Quand on
essaie de la bouc,
on se change où on se travestit,
on se transforme de l'intérieur, on
transforme les idéalement les décideur
quand on peut les associer à la
prospective, ce qui est très rare.
Non, mais on les transforme
par petite touche.
Mais il faut être pragmatique,
il faut viser. Mais justement, mais être
pragmatique comme disait G, c'est
doucement,
c'est Mais oui, c'est viser un but
impossible. Mais il faut se laisser un
peu de temps. Qu'est-ce que c'est que 25
? Quand vous croyez que les Chinois qui
pour le coup, on peut leur emprunter ça,
cette cette ce rapport au temps, on a un
rapport au temps mais qui est qui est
qui est d'une qui manque d'ambition mais
alors c'est terrible si vous voulez. On
peut pas changer comme ça la course d'un
PBO du jour au lendemain. Par contre si
vous changez toutes ces tous ces
corpuscules un à un, bah vous
transfigurez le pack. Mais c'est
évidemment pas le même temps que ça
prend. Voilà. Il faut avoir cette
ambition de d'inscrire une action dans
la durée. Vous savez, une génération
c'est 25 ans, c'est pas beaucoup hein.
Bah oui, bien sûr. Évidemment qu'il faut
cristalliser les rêves.
Il faut cristalliser les rêves.
OK.
Bon, c'est difficile de vous sortir un
petit peu de votre zone de confort. Donc
on va essayer de le faire d'une façon
plus rusée pour essayer de que vous
compreniez en fait notre question
et surtout notre diagnostic.
Un petit coup de
Allez, un petit coup de un petit coup
d'eau.
Donc là, à l'heure actuelle,
on a des problèmes de monnaie, on a des
problèmes de soutenabilité de la dette.
H
euh qui comment
on va soutenir ou rendre crédible notre
dette ? Qui on va saisir, pas saisir ?
Quel visage chaleureux et châtoyant nous
avons présenté au marché financier. On a
un problème climatique qui risque
d'engendrer des problèmes de rendement
de culture, des problèmes
d'approvisionnement de sécurité
alimentaire, des problèmes de mouvement
de personnes en grand nombre, des
problèmes de désertification.
Tout ça est déjà présent he on est
d'accord hein
pas avec la même inertie.
Euh on va se retrouver avec une nazi du
sud-est avec un pot d'humidité très
compliqué pour la soutenabilité de la
vie même. Comme le problème énergétique
a pas l'air de se résoudre, ça va être
compliqué de vivre dans des tunnels avec
la clim, surtout au tarif de
l'électricité. On a des problèmes aussi
de comportement prédateur de certaines
puissances à gauche, à droite, au centre
y compris infiltré chez nous.
Docteur,
ça ressemble à un cancer.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On fait une
grosse chimiothérapie ou le vieux, on
lui met une paire de basket, on lui dit
"T'inquiète pas, papi, les mâs de genou,
le mal de dos, ça va passer avec les
baskets."
Là, j'ai l'impression d'avoir une équipe
sous-dimensionnée pour la mission,
qui n'a pas la bonne capacité à penser
en dehors de la boîte, qui s'est fait
retourner, piluler en long, en large et
en travers par les ennemis.
Et vous connaissez le vieil adage, on a
le droit de perdre mais on a pas le
droit de se faire surprendre. Et là en
plus on s'est fait surprendre. Ils ont
tous des têtes avec les sourcils
jusqu'en haut. La petite tête de chat.
Excusez-nous, c'était pas de notre
faute. La situation nous a échappé des
mains. Même pas même pas. Ça c'est
on élève des raptors à l'école, on fait
comment ? On continue les aimez vos
raptors ?
Ouais. Non parce que un moment il faut
commencer à mordre. Il faut lancer la
chasse. D'accord. Il faut lancer la
chasse.
Il faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui dise
"On lâche et on chasse. On chasse en
meut et on chasse pas pour faire joujou,
on chasse pour tuer." Donc on fait quoi
? On élève des bébés bisounours aux
lunettes roses. On élève des rapes d'or
avec des dents bien pointues capable de
concevoir un monde où en face ça
ressemble plus à des psychopathes
névrosés
en hiérarchie pour nous la mettre à
l'envers. Donc on fait quoi ? On
continue de se la faire grand.
Alors Paul Valérie nous a dit que
où on va à l'attaque,
c'est je vous l'ai dit, j'ai répondu à
votre question, c'est deux axes
parallèles qui ne sont pas
incompatibles. Le deuxième axe, mais
parce qu'en fait ce ne sont pas ni les
mêmes personnes ni le même exercice.
C'està-dire que
vous reproduisez le problème qu'on a
déjà eu. Non, il y a la prospective d'un
côté et puis à la limite il y a la
stratégie de l'autre et on va d'embler
enjamber, on va dire l'âme et puis
l'esprit qui nous amène à on a des
scénarios bien ficelés parce que je sens
que vous perdez patience sur la partie
élaboration des scénarios. Mais j'ai
bien compris, j'ai bien compris
tellement par terre, je dis c'est ta
faute. Je t'ai dit chose.
Exactement. Voilà. Et donc on arrive à
des scénarios, on les a, ils sont
exploratoires, ils sont suffisamment
disruptifs pour agiter nos neurones et
faire en sorte qu'on ait les chakras
ouverts et qu'on se dise voilà le monde
que l'on pourrait préparer. Et
maintenant, on app on a on arrive à la
partie prescriptive et donc on fait de
la stratégie et on dit ce qu'il faut
faire.
Juste avant, je on rebobine un petit
peu. OK.
Donc avant de s'ouvrir les chakras, on
va recruter chez les gens qui qui ont un
parcours de vie de quel type où on prend
le classique type de de qui nous a
emmené jusque-l, c'est-à-dire avec les
mêmes codes culturels pensés dans la
boîte, les mêmes écoles, les mêmes les
mêmes beuveries avec les mêm de qui vous
parlez exactement ? Est-ce que vous
pouvez caractériser cette population
précisément ? parce que là il faut
s'entendre sur les ter des rats de
bibliothèque. Est-ce qu'on continue de
sélectionner des rat de bibliothèque ou
est-ce qu'on on va chercher
en terme de stratégie et de stratégie
opérative s'agissant de protéger nos
intérêts et de faire la guerre
continuation de de la politique par
d'autres moyens. J'ai pas l'impression
que les auditeurs et stagiaires de
l'école de guerre soient des des rats de
laboratoire et des binoclars de
bibliothèque comme ceux que vous
décrivez. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, j'ai
pas l'impression qu'on ait le même
diagnostic là. Vous voyez là, je partage
pas en fait.
OK. Alors, ils ont l'air un peu plus
raptor ils sont là. Les raptors, ils
sont là. Si vous voulez que voilà, ils
sont là en terme de RH, ils sont là.
OK. Euh, vous êtes déjà baladé euh dans
les promotions de colonel qui se
baladaient à l'école de guerre
anciennement collège interarmé de
défense parce que
Oui, d'ailleurs, j'ai fait l'école de
guerre moi-même. J'ai eu cette cette
chance.
C'était du bisounours ? Non, c'était
plutôt du Raptor. Si on parle en terme
de bisouours et Raptor, j'ai eu affaire
à des auditeurs officiers qui savaient
ce que c'était que la guerre, qui l'ont
faite, qui ont une idée assez précise de
la façon dont il faut la faire ou pas.
Bah, si vous voulez, la guerre et on en
parlait au tout début de cet entretien,
c'est encore quelque chose qui c'est un
mot qui devient un peu euh un peu
amphibologique, hein, c'est-à-dire avec
plein de sens. Ben oui, parce que si on
parle de guerre hybride, c'est qu'on
sait plus vraiment euh ce que l'on met
derrière la guerre. Elle est tellement
multidimensionnelle qu'en fait la guerre
s'applique partout. Elle est
énergétique, elle est alimentaire, elle
est euh elle est économique comme vous
dites. Don blague de de à faire pendant
les pour pour dénicher.
D'ailleurs, on parle plus de guerre et
de paix. Vous voyez comme quoi nos
raptors sont quand même bien faits parce
que j'en je fais Non mais oui, mais
parlons de choses concrètes.
Comment débusquer un fumiste en soirée
stratégie ?
Comment on fait ? Je sais pas comment on
débuste
pose la question suivante. Je sais pas
comment débuste la pose. On pose la
question suivante. Quelle est la
différence entre la guerre et la guerre
économique ?
Mais en fait je crois que votre compas,
votre prisme pour apprécier euh ce qui
se passe euh
est perfectible. C'est-à-dire que
guerre, paix, c'est fini. Voilà, c'est
fini. Aujourd'hui, c'est compétition,
contestation, confrontation. Et on ne
sort pas de tout ça. C'est-à-dire qu'en
fait, on est toujours plus ou moins en
état de guerre, mais on n'est pas
vraiment euh quitté l'état de paix non
plus. C'est exactement la situation dans
laquelle on est, si vous voulez.
Par-delà, j'allais dire l'espace et le
temps et les thématiques sur lesquelles
s'applique la guerre. Donc la guerre
économique. Oui. Évidemment qu'il y a
des concurrents, il y a une concurrence
farouche si vous regardez l'Ukraine, si
on prend la dimension économique de la
guerre en Ukraine.
Quelle est la différence entre la guerre
et la guerre économique ?
Bah euh la guerre euh dans sa dimension
militaire euh se passe du qualificatif
militaire. A priori, si on parle de
guerre, c'est d'abord une guerre
militaire. Et puis si on veut rajouter
le qualificatif économique, c'est pour
dire qu'il va y avoir une guerre euh
faite entre des intérêts euh
commerciaux. Voilà. Bon et très
clairement et très clairement très
clairement, on sait bien par exemple
qu'il y a des intérêts commerciaux
économiques via l'énergie et via
l'économie de défense aussi qui à
travers cette guerre en Ukraine peut
servir davantage les intérêts
américains. C'est un euphémisme que les
intérêts européens.
Voilà. Pardon. Allez-y.
Donc la différence entre la guerre et la
guerre économique, c'est qu'en guerre
économique, un chômeur coûte plus cher
qu'un mort.
Elle est bien, elle est rigolote. Elle
est rigot.
Non, elle est pas rigolote du tout. Non.
Vous savez pourquoi elle est pas
rigolote ? J'ai l'impression qu'en
France la guerre économique, ils ont pas
bien saisi. C'est un prisme de lecture
qui est trop long terme pour eux.
Vous comprenez ? Donc c'est c'est
problématique
de mettre guerre un peu à toutes les
sauces, guerre informationnelle à toutes
les sauces, propagande à toutes les
sauces, guerre hybrido à toutes les
sauces, guerre cognitivo, hybrido à
toutes les sauces. Il va falloir parler
concret là. Pourquoi je veux qu'on parle
concret ? Je vois mon pays, ma patrie
menacé par l'incompétence de mes élite.
Comprenez, je pèse mes mots.
En guerre économique, c'est un peu du
toucheous. Prospective, c'est du
toucheous. Détecter les menaces ou là là
là. Détecter les menaces. Quand on les a
détecté, c'est déjà trop tard. On l'a
déjà. Mais
donc ça devient problématique parce que
pour affaiblir un pays, pour gagner la
guerre,
avoir des nécessiteux, des gens malades,
des gens stressés, c'est plus facile
après parce que ça leur crée ça leur
crée des troubles socio-politiques, ça
leur crée tout un tas de problèmes qui
médiatiquement parlant ne sont pas
analysés correctement par nos
journalistes pour dire voilà la
répercussion de l'usine qui est en train
de fermer, c'est parce que la politique
de guerre économique de tel type de pays
nous l'a mis à l'envers et donc on va
perdre notre compétitivité à 20 ans. Ton
père sera chômeur.
Bon ça ils savent pas l'expliquer. Le
prospectiviste professionnel,
le professeur,
il voit le pays à 5 ans dans quel état ?
Quelle est sa sa sa prospective et ce
côté proactif
pour redresser le pays ? On change
penant malant les cellules d'analyse.
On change plutôt ceux qui dirigent les
cellules d'analyse. On change la classe
politique qui est pas foutue d'écouter
l'analyse qui a fait remonter la bonne
information.
J'ai la réponse à votre question hein.
On change la manière de faire de la
prospective. Vous changez les hommes, ça
n'a pas de sens. Vous les changez par
qui ? Vous ceux qui sont en place et
puis vous en prenez d'autres.
Vous changez les institutions. Bon, OK,
vous allez créer un bureau avec un
nouveau nom et puis vous allez dire "On
va faire les choses autrement." Bah si
vous faites les choses autrement
réellement, oui, ça vaut le ça vaut le
coup de de créer de créer un nouvel
organisme avec un nouveau nom ou de
renommer. C'est important de nommer les
choses, hein. Bon, très bien, on le
disait. Mais si vous faites les choses
vraiment autrement, sinon ça n'a aucun
sens. Et j'allais dire là où vous êtes
beaucoup plus ambitieux que moi, c'est
qu'en réalité vous demandez euh
à des gens de faire des choses qui n'ont
jamais su faire.
C'est pas qui n'ont jamais su faire,
c'est dont ils n'ont pas le pouvoir.
C'est-à-dire que euh il y a une illusion
mais qui est connue, hein, c'est de
croire que l'État peut tout.
Aujourd'hui, on est dans une situation
et là pour le coup, j'enfonce vraiment
une porte ouverte, mais c'est quand même
bien de le rappeler.
Avec plaisir parce que je vois votre
résonnance se dessiner.
militaire de
résistance, c'est ça ? De de
s'approprier la défense nationale, c'est
ça. C'est
vous avez fait les jeunes de l'IED. Ça
ça va pas jusque là, mais c'est de dire
que on sait bien que l'État est dépassé
par le haut par les organisation
internationales, supranational, les les
multinationales et cetera et que si vous
demandez vous me parliez de la dette,
vous me parliez du commerce extérieur,
c'est tout comme bon, un chef d'état a
pas forcément la main sur ces leviers là
et donc vous pouvez pas lui demander
l'impossible. En fait, vous savez
l'expression un peu un peu triviale, on
dit la plus belle fille, mais c'est
valable pour les hommes aussi, on va
dégenrer cette expression, ne peut
donner que ce qu'elle a. Et ben là,
c'est la même chose. Si vous si vous
Oui. Bon voilà, si si vous demandez à un
état qui n'a plus la main, Mitteran
disait "Je serai le dernier des grands
présidents." Autre, c'était une façon de
dire qu'il serait le dernier à avoir la
main sur l'ensemble des leviers y
compris économiques qui font que on va
ou pas dans la situation catastrophique.
Je vous en laisse la le le voilà la
responsabilité, que vous décriviez.
Voilà. Mais il faut avoir la main sur
ces choses-là. Si vous n'avez pas la
main sur ces choses-là, et bien de fait
euh vous ne pouvez pas exiger ça de vos
élites. Et c'est un peu simpliste, me
semble-t-il que de vouloir les
stigmatiser euh pour des raisons et leur
jeis dire que leur principal tort c'est
de ne pas avoir un discours de vérité
encore que c'est de moins en moins vrai,
un discours de vérité sur ce qu'elles
peuvent vraiment faire, ce qu'on peuvent
ce qu'on est en tr en droit d'attendre
d'elles ou ce qu'on elles ne peuvent pas
faire et ce qu'on n'est pas en droit
d'attendre d'elles. Alors effectivement,
il y a un certain nombre de de comment
de positions politiques qui en
prendraient un coup parce qu'on se
dirait bon en fait
bah à commencer par la fonction de chef
d'état. Un chef d'état a réalité quand
même assez peu de assez peu de leviers.
D'ailleurs pour en revenir à ce que vous
disiez, un des leviers majeurs, c'est la
guerre guerre la guerre militaire. Chef
d'état et là je ne fais référence à
personne hein. Je là je généralise au
sens où je je dépersonnifie, désincarne
le propos. Euh la plupart des chefs
d'État et c'est pas c'est vrai partout
en France à l'étranger, prennent
conscience qu'ils ont un vrai pouvoir à
travers la chose militaire. C'estàd
qu'en fait ils peuvent déclencher une
intervention militaire parce que ça ça
répond. Ils s'aperçoivent avec stupeur
sans doute que là quand ils décident bah
il y a un avion qui bombarde sur Raka
dans les 48 heures qui suivent le 13
novembre 2015 par exemple. Euh voilà.
Bon il se passe ça. Là c'est action
réaction. J'ai un pouvoir sur les
choses. Est-ce que derrière
politiquement ça a un sens, ça règle les
choses ? C'est un autre sujet. Mais
l'intervention militaire accuse le coût.
Ça marche. Voilà. Euh sur sauver des
emplois pour une entreprise, sur le
commerci extérieur lié à la
compétitivité des entreprises, sur la
capacité à faire en sorte que des
ruptures technologiques viennent
réinventer des marchés. Euh ça
malheureusement euh le président un chef
d'état peut jouer sur les écosystèmes,
faire en sorte qu'on fasse dans le temps
de la prospective autrement créer des
conditions mais il pourra pas le
baguette mag. faire un commentaire à ça,
ça va peut-être vous paraître cosmétique
mais sur le renseignement économique
quand on voit ou le renseignement tout
court quand on voit notre ancien
ministre des armées avec un Pegasus sur
son téléphone, quand on voit notre
ancien premier ministre
se faire auditer par le Sénat, dire
voilà, bon bah moi avant le conseil des
ministres quand même, j'ai essayé de
dire que on évitait les téléphones
portables sur la table. Quand je vois X
Y chef d'entreprise, jamais se faire
auditer, jamais jamais voir en terme de
sécurité informatique. Quand je vois le
président de la République française
utiliser un iPhone, quand je vois la
DGSE se faire pone avec les montres
connectées en Opex, se faire remonter
jusqu'en France par un journaliste
Jean-Marc Manac, je me dis bon c'est
quoi ? C'est du laisser aller, c'est de
l'incompétence. Il faut changer quoi ?
Parce que il y a quand même des il y a
quand même des Non mais d'accord.
Non mais c'est des grandes phrases
c'est des grandes phrases. Il faut qu'il
y ait des têtes qui tombent. Faut qu'il
y ait une formation disséminée
avec
expliquer aux gens que bon, on est dans
un océan où il y a des requins, que le
business, la pépite qu'on a financé avec
de l'impôt public, bon si elle se fait
attraper parce que tu as aucune hygiène
informatique, ça va être encore de
l'argent public donné à une puissance
étrangère.
Il faut il faut faire quoi ? Il faut
leur prendre la main parce que changer
l'homme c'est bien beau. Nous, on a plus
envie de les attraper un par un et dire
"Bon, écoute, tu es mauvais, tu as fait
ça, ça ça comme erreur. On peut plus
rien pour toi et en plus tu deviens
dangereux."
Bon, je sais que vous voulez faire
tomber des têtes.
Non, je veux pas faire tomber des têtes.
Ça sert à rien de faire tomber tes
tomber. Faites-les tomber en disant "Ah
mais attendez, je pousse le l'exercice
jusqu'au bout
parce que celui avant de perdre sa tête,
il s'accroche."
Je je pousse l'exercice. Bon, il
s'accroche mais comme une corne sur un
rocher. Mais on va quand même on va
faire tomber des têtes. OK. Très bien.
On se dit ils sont incompétents, ils
sont ils sont négligeents, ils sont euh
naïfs, ils sont tout ce que vous voulez,
on les supprime et puis on en met
d'autres et il se passera la même chose.
Il se passera la même chose. C'est
humain.
C'est humain. C'est pour ça que je vous
dis faut changer l'homme de façon
grandoquante. Faut changer le DRH.
Non, faut je dire faut changer
l'atavisme humain qui est de d'aller à
la facilité. C'est-à-dire que euh tous
les la protection, la sécurité,
la protection, la sécurité, ça coûte,
c'est euh c'est ça prend du temps, c'est
long, c'est moins fluide, les
dispositifs existent mais il faut se les
approprier.
Un contrat de sous-marin français qui se
fait avoir par les Américains, ça coûte
combien ?
J'ai pas dit que c'était bien. J'ai pas
dit qu'il fallait pas faire en sorte de
plus sensibiliser, qu'il fallait
éduquer. Il y a une éducation forte.
Mais ce que vous dépignez là pour les
politiques, c'est vrai à tous les
niveaux et même parmi et même parfois
parfois je dis parfois parce que je suis
je suis poli et réservé mais c'est vrai
y compris de professionnel c'est vrai y
compris de professionnel cette espèce
d'hygiène numérique
qui fait que
on se fera pas intercepter une
communication qui fait que et cetera
le le la première hygiène elle est à
faire chez professionnel lui-même et il
y a un organisme qui s'appelle la DRSD
euh qui fait de la sensibilisation euh
sans arrêt au
DRSD direction du
du renseignement et de la sûreté de
défense. Voilà. et qui euh et qui euh en
gros euh voilà, c'est un des services de
renseignement, un des services de la
communauté du renseignement dont la
vocation est de protéger précisément
tout ce qui peut euh être
infrastructure, données sensibles, on
entend par infrastructure les données
également et faire en sorte de préserver
l'intégrité de tout le dispositif de
défense et de sécurité nationale. Voilà,
industriel compris. Juste une question,
quand ils en chopent un qui est un petit
peu non chalant, ils lui font "Ah pon
cucu, c'était pas bien." Ou ils lui font
"Bon bah tu vois ta paye de misère à
3500 € par mois devant en tant
qu'analyste avec 10 ans d'ancienneté,
bah maintenant on va te redonner les
cros, on va te repasser à 1500 €."
Quoi ? Les sanctions
c'est pas la République de Platon, ils
sont pas responsables sur leur tête,
voyez. Donc évidemment qu'il y a
toujours des sanctions. Un bon système
c'est un système qui a sa part de
récompense et de
sanction promotion sanction par quoi ?
Par
non, il faut raison garder. C'est-à-dire
que vous savez, il faut aussi avoir
conscience que pour parfaire un système,
on a souvent intérêt, mais ça c'est mon
côté lunett rose, vous le mettrez en
dénominateur commun de l'entretien,
c'est qu'il faut souvent dépénaliser
l'erreur parce que sinon les gens
cachent les erreurs sous le tapis.
Quelqu'un me disait mais je ne dis pas
qui
gestion du Covid là. Quelqu'un me disait
"Mais je je ne dirai pas qui, euh moi
mes techniciens, je les couvre, voilà et
après je règle l'affaire." Mais pour les
couvrir, je veux qu'il me disent s'ils
ont merdé ou s'ils ont pas merdé.
C'est moi qui vous ai dit ça avant le
tournage.
Voilà. Et donc vous attendez deux qui
soient franc et qui n'ait pas peur
d'affronter en fait votre jugement et
les conséquences de votre jugement parce
que ils sait qu'ils n'ont pas à le
craindre. Et là, c'est la même chose. Si
vous dites "Voilà, effectivement, j'ai
fait une erreur à un moment donné, je me
suis baladé avec mon téléphone portable
perso, j'ai passé un coup de téléphone,
j'étais en opération ou je l'ai ouvert
en arrivant près de mortier et puis je
l'ai laissé allumer dans mortier." Bon
euh voilà, c'est pas bien. Euh, il s'est
produit quelque chose. Si de vous-même,
j'allais dire vous dénoncez et que vous
expliquez le problème et qu'on règle le
problème, bah c'est bien mieux que si
vous craignez que vous craignez la
sanction et du coup vous cachez l'erreur
sous le tapis parce que là ça peut avoir
des conséquences. Souvent quand on
découvre le problème, on peut le régler
très facilement hein. Tout le monde se
bal pas balade pas avec les plans du
Scorpen sur son portable et quand bien
même avant que bon il y a quand même
plein de filtres avant qu'il puisse se
passer quelque chose de de dramatique
pour autant que ce soit découverta et
donc il faut des gens qui soient
totalement en confiance. Donc si vous
voulez la confiance ça se gagne aussi
par c'est le terme dépénaliser l'erreur.
On parlait de l'aviation euh il y a une
dépendant avant de rebondir sur
l'aviation. Vous avez vu que je vous ai
laissé terminer ?
Oui.
Avec bienveillance.
C'est vrai. Continuer.
C'est vrai. Ça annonce le pire. La
menace vient du ciel. J'ai fait un très
bon avocat du diable.
Je vous laisse terminer.
D'accord. On parlait de l'aviation.
Dépénaliser. Je veux pas dire de vêtes,
c'est le mot exact, c'est l'erreur.
C'est pas la faute, hein. Dépénaliser
l'erreur, c'est différent. Euh c'est
quelque chose qui qui a court dire voilà
en retour d'expérience euh j'ai fait
telle connerie dans l'avion euh pour x
ou euh Y problème euh dans X ou Y
situation, peu importe. Voilà, je suis
passé sous la hauteur de sécurité. Euh
j'ai en pétardé les minimas à
l'atterrissage. Les minimas c'est quand
on arrive près d'une piste, on doit
avoir
embrasser pour embrasser la piste.
Voilà, on doit avoir le visuel sur la
piste. Si on n pas le visuel parce que
il fait mauvais temps et ben on doit
remettre les gaz. Bon et ben je sais
pas, il y a peut-être des pilotes à qui
il est arrivé d'aller voir un peu plus
loin pour se dire tiens ben je vais
finir par la voir la piste hein au final
de coup du
voilà et puis euh où euh où vous avez un
petit problème parce que vous avez fait
une gestion carburant en revenant
d'opération du fin fond de du Tjikistan
et vous étiez tellement détendu
tellement détendu de revenir de de mois
d'opération du Tajikistan. Vous avez
volé en haut en voilà au-dessus de
au-dessus de l'indy couche et avec des
possibilités éventuelles de se faire
tirer. Bon, vous êtes détendu et du coup
voilà, vous avez pas fait pas bien pas
gérer suffisamment la météo, pas gérer
suffisamment votre carburant sans qu'il
y ait d'erreur mais les plaques de
reason, des petites des petites,
j'allais dire des petites négligences
par-ci parl un peu de relâchement.
Voilà, un peu de relâchement. Et vous
dites "Bon bah là, j'arrive au minimum,
soit je passe sous la réserve finale et
là je vais me faire avoir. Soit euh soit
après je cherche un trou et je me pose
n'importe où à côté de Château d'in. Bon
bah là, vous allez en dessous les
minimas et puis voilà. Bon cette erreur
là éventuellement si un pilote l'a faite
et ben et qui la reporte d'une part ça
peut servir aux autres qui se disent "Ah
oui, j'ai été confronté à ça et je
m'étais pas rendu compte que ou si un
jour je suis confronté à ça, je saurais
qu'il faut faire ça. Donc vous en faites
profiter les autres." Donc ça c'est
extrêmement bien, ça évite qu'il y ait
d'autres problèmes et puis vous n'êtes
pas forcément lourdement sanctionné.
Donc vous dites voilà ma carrière va pas
forcément en pâtir parce que j'ai fait
cette erreur-là. Alors que si c'est
l'inverse, bah vous dites rien. Et non
seulement ça peut se reproduire et là
les gens ne bénéficieront pas de votre
expérience,
mais en plus vous-même, vous vous
retrouvez avec une situation qui est que
bah vous portez ça assez lourdement
quand même. Donc voilà, dépénaliser
l'erreur. C'est très intéressant ce que
vous venez de dire.
On est à bord d'un avion qui a 3000
milliards de dettes. Il s'appelle Air
France One. D'accord. Le corps de
pilote,
c'est pas des pilotes, c'est des
politiques.
Alors, vous allez me dire qu'ils sont
aidés par toute une kirelle de
guirlandes, de fonctionnaires, de de
gens censés les aider qui vivent dans la
peur de
il faut que je dise ce que mon chef a
envie d'entendre. Sinon, vous comprenez,
c'est pas bon.
Quand le navire est le l'avion Air
Françoine,
le pilote qui se dit "Bon, on va à
vache, on va pas à vache. Faut surtout
pas que je dise que il faut je suis en
train de chercher un terrain de fortune
pour me poser sans visibilité,
sans point d'eau, sans possibilité de
joindre les secours. On en revient
où je vais démonter en arrivant sur le
sol mis en lambeau
et on en revient à la prise de décision
complètement.
Donc la stratégie quand votre élite,
votre corps de haut fonctionnaire la
courroie de transmission elle est plus
là. On fait quoi ? On continue à se
regarder en chien de faillance en disant
bon alors il faut faire changer les
choses doucement.
Il faut y aller doucement avec PP parce
que tu comprends, tu vas lui provoquer
une crise cardiaque. Puis bon, s'il se
réduit un peu, ça va être de ta faute.
Quand on est jeune avec les dents
longues
et ben la relève est là.
La relève est là.
Oui, parce que là pour le coup, c'est la
partie qui peut aller beaucoup plus
vite. Vous parliez, je crois que c'était
la première question de l'entretien.
Est-ce qu'il faut attendre un carton
pour que les gens dans l'avion
commencent à paniquer ou à s'énerver
pour dire "Oh coco, montre-moi ton
brevet pilote",
c'est pas le carton qui changera les
choses. Des cartons, il y en a à chaque
fois. On se dit qu'on recommencera pas
et puis le lendemain, vous savez c'est
comme l'alcoolique qui se dit qu'il
arrêtera de boire et puis le lendemain
mais on est tous comme ça. Familles
détruites, c'est des gens au chômage, ça
des gamins qui s'emmerdent à l'école,
c'est des parents qui arrivent plus à
gérer, c'est des parents qui sont
stressés et ça fait augmenter le niveau
de violence et de violence et de
violence. Mais ce que vous dites là,
pour autant
que ce soit effectivement vrai et je
remets pas en cause, le ne pèse pas sur
la décision qui est prise ou préparée en
ce sens que comme vous dites, celui qui
va porter tel ou tel dossier euh va
penser par cercle concentrique. Si vous
voulez, le poids des enjeux qu'il y a
sur la note opérationnelle qui a
vocation à instruire et à faire en sorte
que soit prise la bonne décision.
Euh ça reste des mots et je ne crois pas
qu'au moment où la note est portée et
présentée chacun à son niveau soit
pénétré de la gravité des problèmes euh
qui sont ceux que que vous décrivez. Il
y a effectivement tout un mécanisme de
décision qui fait que on a tendance à
être à avoir une inclination, à
présenter ce qui sera le plus audible.
Ça c'est sûr, c'est évident. Mais c'est
là où le changement peut arriver
rapidement, c'est que vous parliez de
courage et de la capacité à dire des
choses qui soient dissonnantes. Ça, je
le vois et je le mesure mais à chaque
fois en cours euh les jeunes sont les
les jeunes étudiants y compris de
sciences pot hein, dont on pourrait dire
bah oui, ils sont tout acquis à la cause
du pouvoir hein, pour avoir une vision
un peu manikenne comme ça.
Vous cherchez nous faire dire quelque
chose ou c'est pas du tout ? Pas du
tout. C'est que là pour le coup ce
courage là, il est là. C'est-à-dire que
je vois qu'ils sont beaucoup plus prs
que je ne pouvais l'être à leur place
euh à dire des choses dissonnantes.
Parce que moi-même quand ils me disent
des choses dissonnantes, je les comme
tel et je me dis tiens, j'aurais pas dit
ça à leur place, j'aurais peut-être pas
osé dire ça. J'aurais peut-être pas osé
demander ça à un prof, j'aurais
peut-être pas et cetera. Et je vois bien
qu'il s'entourent de beaucoup moins de
de précautions, il bouscule beaucoup
plus les choses. Donc si vous voulez, ça
c'est déjà en marche. Il est fort
probable que les génération bousculer
les choses. Euh euh vous avez entendu
parler du groupe Surcouf ?
Oui. C'est ça date ça quand même non ?
Ouais.
C'était quoi ?
Bah c'était en 2007 me semble-t-il à
l'époque de du président Sarkozy sur la
RGPP. C'était ça. Euh un groupe mais là
je parle je par oui dire hein pas plus
hein. Un groupe de militaires,
d'officiers, d'ancienes officiers euh
voilà je ne sais pas qui avait
exactement derrière qui avait euh qui
avait critiqué la politique de défense.
Voilà en substance c'était ça.
Il y en avait qui étaient sur écoute
d'ailleurs. Ça devait être marrant de
voir l'intérieur mettre sur écoute des
généraux. Non
mais ça vous me la prenez.
Et donc la question
la question que qui vient derrière c'est
à force de nonchalonce à force de
descripitude de notre pays, est-ce que
vous avez crainte queil y ait des
militaires français qui se disent "Bon,
c'est qu'une bande de
couteau pas affuté, il est temps qu'on
reprenne les choses en main." Est-ce que
vous avez peur de ça ? Est-ce que c'est
dans votre prospective que notre corps
militaire qui est l'équivalent de avec
tout le respect que je peux avoir les
femmes pour les femmes de ménage, est-ce
que le militaire est un peu considéré
comme une femme de ménage ou une
technicienne de surface d'erreurs
politiques et qui commence à en avoir
marre même si on leur a promis 400
milliards pour se rééquiper parce qu'ils
même. Ouais, d'accord. Ouais mais c'est
important quand même parce que là pour
un peu plus de cage. C'est un peu plus
de cirage sur les vbles de 14 juillet.
C'est ça.
Non, on peut pas dire ça. Non non, on
peut pas dire ça. Com c'est sur combien
de temps les
6 ans
2024 2030.
C'est combien le budget des autres ? OK.
Si c'est bien employé, on peut faire des
deux trois trucs à vous dire. Moi aussi
je peux me laisser là. Je suis m Non
mais allez-y allez-y.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Est-ce que
vous avez peur dans votre prospective
qui est des militaires ? Est-ce que
c'est envisageable ? Est-ce que vous
l'avez vu ? Est-ce que vous l'entendez ?
qui a des militaires qui en est qui en
ont assez d'être gouverné par des gens
qui tâonnent.
Écoutez déjà sur le constat,
vous me parlez d'un groupe surcouf,
c'était 2007 GP. C'était pour exemple he
oui. Non mais c'est important parce que
là pour autant on était j'allais dire en
plein des dividendes de la paix hein.
Voilà l'appareil militaire et là il y a
pas un politique pour vous dire le
contraire évidemment pas un militaire
pour vous dire le contraire a été quand
même assez méticuleusement déconstruit
pendant 30 ans. Voilà. Et là on a une
ELPM
programmation militaire. une ELPM qui
est présentée comme une ELPM de
transformation qui est à minima, si
c'est pas le cas, au moins une ELPM de
réparation, ce qui est déjà pas si mal.
Ce qui est déjà pas si mal. Je
reviendrai sur leur
je reviendrai quand même sur la
substance même et sur l'accueil. Très
concrètement, c'est la première fois
qu'il y a un sursaut. Vous parliez de
sursaut et celui-ci, il est quand même
rapide. Mais avant avant que vous me
regardiez sur le mode "Oh bah oui, mais
ce sursaut n'est pas suffisant." Il est
certes pas suffisant, mais il est à la
hauteur. Il est à la hauteur, il est à
la haute, attendez, il est à la hauteur
de ce que de l'effort que les Français
veulent bien consentir.
Il est jamais qu'à la hauteur de ce que
les Français veulent bien consentir. Si
les Français veulent consentir plus, il
y a pas de problème.
Est-ce que c'est à la hauteur,
c'est pas un problème lié à l'exécutif
ça ? Est-ce que c'est à la hauteur de ce
que les Français peuvent consentir ou
c'est à la hauteur comme dirait François
Fillon
veulent consentir ? On peut toujours
quand on veut, on peut
voilà c'est une question de priorité
peut faire de la dette aussi hein pour
faire une LPM plus forte. Pourquoi pas
hein ? Si on est Fillon dire je suis à
la tête d'un d'un pays qui est en
faillite
est-ce que de promettre des milliards à
notre armée, c'est une façon de leur
dire vous inquiétez pas, ça va être
tendu mais vous aurez un petit peu de
crème solaire, un ber et des nouvelles
Rangers.
Non, je crois pas parce que très
concrètement
partons des des besoins. En réalité, le
premier besoin, c'est quand même dans la
perspective d'une guerre qui aurait
toujours la même forme. Donc là, on part
d'une prospective, on n'interroge pas ça
là pour l'instant, on pourra en discuter
mais c'est un autre sujet. Voilà, la
prospective est fixée, on se dit c'est
une guerre telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire hybride mais
avec une dimension militaire de haute
intensité qui revient. Est-ce que c'est
vrai, c'est pas vrai ? C'est pas le
sujet. On a abouti à cette prospective.
Très bien. OK, on a fait le bilan des
menaces et donc par la même la
dissuasion nucléaire est renforcée s'il
en était besoin dans son lustre. Donc il
faut l'assurer et il faut l'assurer sur
toutes ces dimensions, y compris la
dimension aéronautique, la dimension
aéroportée, parce que c'est celle qui
permet, c'est sans doute la chose pas la
plus utile. On va pas hiérarchiser hein,
il faut une frappe en second massive euh
complètement euh qui qui disqualifie et
qui dissuade de tout hein à travers les
SNLE, les sous-marins nucléaires, l'
sort d'engin, la composante navale,
c'est indiscutable. Mais avoir une
diplomatie coercitive qui permet d'avoir
euh de la gesticulation, de la
démonstrativité, de la réversibilité
dans une situation où on pourrait avoir
à négocier en parallèle d'une rhtorique
nucléaire et ça la dissuasion et la
composante aéroportée peut le faire. Ça
ça a vraiment du sens. Voilà, donc il
faut effectivement sanctuariser le
nucléaire dans toutes ces composantes, y
compris la plus souple, la moins la
moins qui qui a l'impact le plus mesuré
mais donc le plus crédible. parce qu'on
peut se dire qu'on peut l'employer
véritablement. C'est pas la fin du monde
hein. Voilà la bah la composante
aéroportée peut raser une ville. Voilà.
Frappe frappe de d'intensité réduite.
C'est ça.
Frappe plus réduite pour parler avec les
mains. Voilà.
Nucléri
mais nucléaire néanmoins. C'est ce que
c'est
donc du nucléaire tactique.
Ah non non, ça reste stratégique. Faut
pas Ça reste stratégique. C'est-à-dire
que la composante aéroportée peut vous
éliminer une une ville monde par exemple
mais va pas vous détruire. Voilà par
exemple. Mais pas vous pas vous détruire
un continent ni la moitié de la terre
non plus. Voilà.
Et en face en face ils vont faire la
même chose non ?
Ah bah ça dépend là où vous l'appliquez.
L'idée c'est aussi c'est ce que je vous
disais c'est la force de cette
composante là. C'est aussi d'avoir une
dimension diplomatique et de diplomatie
coercitive. C'est-à-dire de se dire ça
va venir, ça peut venir en parallèle de
négociation
et donc peser dans le cadre de
négociation pour un retour à la paix
pour abaisser les tensions en disant
voyez il y a un raid nucléaire qui est
en train de se préparer. Voyez il a
décollé voyez il est sur le point de
lâcher un missile airol moyenne portée
un ASMPA. Très bien. Et donc est-ce
qu'on va jusqu'à but ou est-ce qu'on
s'arrête avant ? Peut-être s'arrêter
avant. Ce qu'on peut pas faire avec un
sous-marin quand ça partie. C'est parti.
Voilà. Ouais, on peut on peut l'arrêter
quand même.
C'est parti. C'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas le concept
c'est pas le concept d'emploi. C'est
frapp en second. C'est frapp en second.
Alors que la dissuasion dans sa
composante aéroportée, ça pourrait être
appelé le dernier avertissement. Ce
serait un peu ça l'idée. Dernier
avertissement.
Et en face, imaginez-vous parce que
et donc ça c'est sanctuarisé par la LPM.
Ça c'est sanctuarisé.
Je vous coupe en même temps. Gardez bien
le fil. Et en face de vous, il y a un
toc toc quelqu'un qui qui est vraiment
fâché. Il se dit "Bon,
il est en train de me raser une ville
monde." Versailles ?
Oui, pas vraiment une ville monde mais
enfin oui oui Versaill du monde pour
certains. Non.
Et l'autre, il va se dire "Mais moi, je
vais lui expliquer un petit peu, je vais
le remettre à sa place, je vais lui
raser son pays." Et tous ces petits
copains avec qui il s'est mis en
alliance là, comme je sais que derrière
je vais me faire fracasser, je vais
jouer la carte de "Est-ce qu'ils ont
plus de boomkers que nous ?" et je vais
raser le continent monde ? Est-ce que de
se donner les moyens avec ce type
d'engin, ce type de frappe, ce type de
diplomatie comerciive, c'est pas créer
ses propres démons en face ?
Non, parce que cette dissuasion repose
d'abord, là vous allez encore me me
découper en rondelle, mais ça ça repose
d'abord sur une dimension cognitive,
c'est-à-dire théorie des jeux et des
jeux avec des agents rationnels qu'on
estime rationnel à tort ou à raison et
dont on se dit qui mesure l'intérêt sur
le coût et le risque. Et donc c'est pour
ça que ça s'appelle la dissuasion.
D'ailleurs, ça dissuade, c'est-à-dire
que quand on emploie et qu'on frappe,
c'est un échec. C'est la seule arme qui
quand elle est employée constitue un
échec. Voilà.
Dans votre doctrine,
bah à peu près toutes les doctrines
liées au nucléaes. C'est même le cas
d'ailleurs en Russie. On a entendu pas
mal, on a entendu pas mal de conneries
sur la doctrine russe disant "Mais si
c'est une doctrine d'emploi, c'est dans
la continuité de leurs armements. Ce
n'est juste qu'un degré supplémentaire."
C'est pas vrai. C'est pas vrai. Là,
j'invite à faire du fact checking.
Regarder ce qu'est la doctrine russe. On
a laissé ça dire ça sur les plateaux
parce que pourquoi on a laissé dire ça ?
Alors, il peut y avoir plusieurs
analyses.
La première, c'est de dire mal nommer
les choses, c'est ajouté au malheur du
monde. Et quand on parle de tactique, de
nucléaire tactique, bah on se dit que
c'est pas vraiment du nucléaire. Donc ça
fait partie de la gamme des armes qu'on
peut communément employer. Sauf que le
nucléaire tactique, c'est 12 kilot,
c'est Hiroshima par exemple. Voyez ? que
hein ça ferait quand même un peu du buzz
là s'il y avait du nucléaire tactique de
d'employer 12 kn
c'est surdimensionné pour Versailles il
va falloir que j'appelle mon
voilà voilà donc c'est nucléaire
tactique en fait on s'aperçoit qu'en
fait c'est peut-être pas stratégique
mais ça fait quand même l'effet d'une
bombe c'estàd dans l'espace cognitif des
population hein si c'était employé je je
sais même pas comment on réagirait ce
serait comment surable donc voilà donc
mal nommer les choses c'est un vrai
problème. C'est aussi pour ça que du
coup on banalise. Après, il y a pu avoir
aussi une instrumentalisation
de certains catastrophistes qui disent
"Attention, ne nous opposons surtout pas
à la Russie parce que le nucléaire pour
eux, c'est un armement totalement
conventionnel, pardonnez-moi justement
de de du paradoxe dans l'emploi des
mots. Et donc ça pourrait cette
escalade, elle est tout à fait crédible.
Elle va arriver, elle arrive d'ailleurs,
elle est arrivée et voyez voilà et il
faut éviter qu'il y ait une aide
substantielle à l'Ukraine. On a bien vu
quand même que c'était pas le cas
puisqu'il a fallu et on a quand même été
assez loin dans l'aide à l'Ukraine. les
lignes rouges ont sans cesse été
repoussé et pour l'instant c'est pas un
défi que je lance à la Russie hein mais
pour l'instant
pour l'instant pour l'instant il y a pas
de recours au nucléaire même si la
rhtorique est toujours forte et même si
le risque demeure parce qu'effectivement
si on arrivait à une situation où d'un
point de vue existentiel le régime je
dis pas la Russie là je dis le régime de
Poutine s'estimait vraiment menacé et
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est Williams
Burn pouvez regarder novembre 2022
directeur de la CIA
Non, jamais. directeur de la CIA euh qui
dit "C'est des Russes,
je les connais pour avoir enfin les
cercle dirigeant autour de Poutine, je
les connais par fiche interposé pour
avoir travaillé
à l'époque en cabinet ministériel à
notre politique de dialogue et fermeté à
l'époque où c'était Pierre Vimont qui
était l'envoyé spécial qui d'ailleurs
est à l'origine de cette communauté
européenne
communauté politique européenne dont
nous parlions au début de l'entretien.
Voilà, donc j'ai quelques portraits
types de Choy quelques portraits types
de Guerasimov, quelques portraits types
de Patrouchef, quelques portraits types
et cetera de Sorovikin. Bref, voilà ce
qu'on peut avoir. Donc je les connais de
façon très académique, je n'ai jamais
fréquenté voilà ni même vu d'ailleurs
soit dit en passant
ce qu'on fait les fiches.
Ah bah dans la mesure où quand même on a
des capteurs humains et autres sur
place, j'imagine que c'est documenté par
des gens qui quand même sont au contact
et puis un attaché de défense en général
il est reçu quand même. Euh
pourquoi pourquoi le le responsable de
la DRM il a sauté ?
[Rires]
Ça, je ne sais pas. Si je le savais, je
vous le dirai bien volontiers mais je ne
sais pas. Est-ce que c'est pour un
problème ? Non. Est-ce que parce qu'en
fait j'ai lu comme vous les raisons pour
lesquelles il aurait pu sauter. Il y a
deux Moi, je alors là je parle en tant
que je reporte ce que j'ai lu hein, mais
je ne prends pas partie et j'ai même pas
d'ailleurs de
la direction du renseignement militaire.
Il y a il y a de
rappelez la situation à nos auditeurs.
Bah la situation c'est que je vous la
fait courte, les Américains eux ont été
capables de prévoir que il y aurait euh
une agression euh de la Russie sur
l'Ukraine, l'ont dit à Coré à CRI, n'ont
pas été véritablement entendus et il
semblerait que les services français,
mais pas que français, européens plus
généralement, enfin les services oui
européens, enfin des pays européens
parce qu'il y a pas de services
européens en tant que corps constitué,
mais services des États-membres étaient
un peu plus aveugle là-dessus et que il
semble semblerait que la direction du
renseignement militaire ait pas a pas eu
disons la une vision précise de cette de
cette invasion de cette agression
qui a eu lieu. Voilà. Après, c'était une
lecture possible et donc bah voilà, une
sanction comme il peut y avoir lorsque
il y a une défaillance. Bon, très bien
ça.
Mais il y a une autre aussi il y a une
autre vision qui était que ça pouvait
être le fruit d'une entente, j'ai lu
hein, je rapporte ce qui est dans source
ouverte dans les journaux, fruit d'une
entente et que le général Vidau, c'est
ça que j'ai connu pour le coup parce que
il était au cabinet de la ministre des
armées en même temps que moi,
voilà, aurait fait l'objet d'un d'une
incompatibilité d'humeur, ce que j'ai lu
dans les journaux. Je ne sais pas quelle
est la vérité dans tout ça et à vrai
dire je crois pas que ça ait beaucoup
d'importance.
On va discuter entre nous là. Quand vous
voyez une Russie depuis des années
chercher des solutions d'évitement pour
Swift,
le dollar se positionner sur l'or mener
des exercices de je me débranche de
l'internet venir.
Alors vous me voyez venir je vous écoute
tout de suite. Je vais où ? Bah, vous
allez me dire que on aurait peut-être pu
voir qu'elle allait préparer son
économie à être robuste, à vivre de
façon un peu autarcique, à se préparer à
l'économie de guerre et que par la même
elle se préparait peut-être à une guerre
et que tout ça ça aurait été des signaux
avant-coureur de il va se passer quelque
chose. Mais nous nous
pris de lecture.
Nous on l'a vu, on est des péquins
lambda. Si nous on arrive à voir que la
Russie fait des exercices pour se
déconnecter à notre petit niveau, c'est
qu'ils ont bien voulu communiquer sur ce
sujet-là ou que il y a une fuite qu'ils
ont laissé faire,
donc il lançait peut-être des messages
bien sûr. Et c'est là où la guerre
cognitive n'est pas un mot creux. Elle a
du sens. C'est-à-dire que oui, elle a du
sens. Pourquoi ? quand il quand il
faisait passer passer de de deux
bombardiers black jack sans transpondeur
devant notre base de sous-marin à Brest.
Mais ça c'est et qui et puis qui
ressortent juste au bon moment pour dire
"coucou les gars, on est là."
Ça c'est une stratégie d'intimidation.
C'est un message, c'est une stratégie
d'intimidation.
test les aériens ou c'est juste pour
permettre à leur diplomat de dire "Vous
savez, les Américains font la même
chose, hein."
Non, il y a il y a plusieurs choses là
euh et qui bon qui se répondent, mais il
y a quand même plusieurs choses. Il y a
le fait que ces stratégies
d'intimidation et ses vols de Bombardi à
très long rayon d'action qui viennent
lécher nos côtes, ça existe. J'étais en
cabinet ministériel en 2016, ça existait
déjà et c'était reporté quasiment toutes
les semaines, toutes les 15 jours, je
souviens plus mais c'était vraiment
courant. C'était mais oui oui mais bien
sûr ça fait partie des choses courantes.
Voilà de la même façon qu'il y a des
sous-marins en Méditerranée de
sous-marins russes en Méditerranée voilà
tant qu'il perc la surface bon voilà ou
bref qui sont qui sont là qui se planent
pendant un mois
qui sont là. Voilà donc si vous voulez
c'est la stratégie d'intimidation
classique si je sais pas si c'est le
terme qui convient mais pratiqué par les
Russes depuis très longue date et je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit un message
avant-coureur de l'agression qui doit
arriver. En revanche, et ça c'est le 2e
point, est-ce que c'est un moyen de
tester les limites ? Je veux dire, les
limites, il les testent pas avec ça. Les
limites, il les testent avec la chechen
qu'est-ce qui a été fait ? Pas
grand-chose. La limite, il est test avec
la Syrie. Qu'est-ce qui a été fait ? Pas
grand-chose. La limite, il était avec
2014, l'Ukraine, les petits hommes
déguisés en verre. Qu'est-ce qui a été
fait ? Un peu plus, mais pas
grand-chose. Voilà. Et là, il y a pas de
problème parce qu'on on est tous
d'accord sur ce constat là. Et donc
précisément, il y avait tout lieu de
penser que là en 2022, le 24 février,
qu'est-ce qui se passerait ? Pas
grand-chose. En plus, pas de zone
d'exclusion aérienne comme demandé par
les Ukrainiens dans les premières
heures. Donc, on pouvait penser qu'il se
passerait pas grand-chose. Mais là, ils
sont trompés. Voilà. Donc, ils testent,
c'est vrai, et là, ils se sont trompés.
Mais là où ils ont vraiment testé, c'est
pas tellement par la stratégie
d'intimidation que vous décrivez, mais
plutôt par les événements et les non
réactions.
Laissons les Russes se planter eux-même.
Quand nous les Français on a vu 50000
hommes, 75 100000 200 2500
le seul argument qu'ils allaient pas
frapper c'est vous vous rendez compte
les gars c'est juste des exercices parce
que quand on s'apprête à faire la guerre
on a des hôpitaux de campagne
qui sont arrivés au dernier moment
pourquoi on en est arrivé à ce moment-là
pourquoi on n pas
dit bon ils sont pas encore Voilà,
ils risquent de faire une annonce comme
quoi ils vont débarquer. Mettons une
force d'interposition. C'était un manque
de courage, pas de courage. C'était
peut-être
un piège.
C'est c'est le
Est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est la la
l'Ukraine ? C'est la nouvelle
Afghanistan
pour les Russes ? Est-ce que c'est
encore un piège où les populations
civiles vont morfler ? Encore une fois,
là, il y a deux questions dans votre
question. La première sur euh comment
fallait-il interpréter euh cette
massification euh des troupes. Euh là,
si vous prenez le prisme précédent qui
est ça s'inscrit dans la stratégie
d'intimidation,
bah vous pensez que précisément c'est
une stratégie d'intimidation et qui ne
passeront pas à l'acte. Et il y a tout
lieu de penser en prolongeant les
courbes qui ne passeront pas à l'acte.
vous ajoutez la dimension cognitive
forte mais la dimension cognitive forte
qui est que
avec des racines qui
il y a une forme de déniapacité
à penser la rupture et plus que la
rupture la stupeur. C'est-à-dire qu'on
se dit ce serait tellement terrible que
ça ne peut pas arriver. Et il y a quand
même cette cet atavisme là qui est fort.
Et c'est vrai à l'échelle d'un pays.
C'est vrai à l'échelle d'un homme. Quand
vous êtes confronté à une maladie, il y
a d'abord une forme de déni. Et on se
dit c'est pas possible, ça peut pas être
un mélanome. Ça peut pas être un
mélanome. Ah oui, mais peut-être que là
quand même un peu parce que la forme, la
symétrie et cetera. Et puis il faudrait
une intelligence artificielle froide
hein, percepton là, un réseau de
neurones qui lui se fasse l'analyse et
qui dis c'est un mélanome. Voilà. et un
bon dermato
ou un bon dermato. Mais dans tous dans
tous les cas, il faut être capable
d'objectiver et là on objective avec ce
qu'on a et on en revient aussi avec la
capacité à analyser, à donner du sens
aux données, euh à orienter la décision,
je vous coupe.
Et là, on en revient au courage aussi
avec ce qu'on a
au courage.
Je voudrais que vous déliez. Non non, je
les pas. C'est-à-dire que euh entre la
donnée,
on avait des chèvres derrière entre la
donnée de base chèvres des anes des
entre la donnée de base et la
connaissance, il y a tout un processus
et le processus au moment où on arrive à
l'aspect cognition, il demande un
courage. C'est-à-dire qu'il demande mais
un courage qui est plus que le courage
de dire à son chef quelque chose qu'il
veut pas entendre. C'est pas si simple
en fait. C'est le courage de penser
véritablement contre soi et de se dire
cette chose que je redoute, elle
pourrait avoir lieu et pourquoi elle
pourrait avoir lieu et cetera. Et c'est
ça en fait, c'est là où se situe le
premier courage. C'est d'abord une
volonté de penser les choses autrement.
Et ça, ça se fait à l'échelle de
l'individu. Et par petit renoncement,
par petit vendredi soir où on veut pas
forcément aller jusqu'au bout des
choses, aller jusqu'au bout des choses,
hein, comme un pote. Un peu, on est tous
un peu potaches, on est tous des grands
enfants malgré tout. Euh et bien euh et
bien on peut arriver dans le sens de la
pente à euh penser les choses telles
qu'elles ont toujours été pensées.
Voilà.
Question internet. Si la prospective est
une voie parallèle à la stratégie, alors
elle ne se rencontre jamais.
C'est pas une
de ce postulat. La prospective est-elle
vouée à n'être jamais n'être jamais se
traduire en mise en œuvre ?
Alors, c'est pas une voix parallèle,
c'est une voix amon. Euh si on faisait
les choses bien euh et non pas là on
fait les on fait bien les choses souvent
on fait bien les choses. C'estàd que le
vendredi soir on boucle les dossiers euh
et on part en paix. Mais là si on
faisait les choses bien
non si on les faisait bien
si on les faisait bien avant de faire de
la stratégie avant d'être prescriptif et
d'avoir des rapports avec 300 mesures,
on ferait une prospective amont. C'est
la partie qui coûte. Là encore aussi on
est dans le courage. C'est-à-dire qu'il
va falloir penser penser avant de
dépenser. Voilà. Et c'est pas un jeu de
mot de circonstances, c'est penser avant
de dépenser. Mais on l'escamote cette
partie-là parce qu'on n' pas le temps,
parce qu'on a pas envie, parce que ça
demande des ressources intellectuelles,
parce que il faut revenir au fondement
des questions existentielles avant que
d'en arriver au sujet qui nous est posé.
Voyez bien qu'on n'est pas du tout dans
la temporalité des problèmes de l'époque
et plus on avance et moins on sera dans
cette temporalité-là parce que la
tyrannie de l'immédiat hein c'est voilà
la formule est bien connue elle est elle
est criante voilà et donc on est dans
quand on est dans la stratégie c'est
déjà bien souvent on est déjà dans la
tactique voire dans l'exécution et on a
enjambé les trois mais si déjà on est
dans la stratégie bah on a quand même
déjà enjambé la prospective donc c'est
une voix vraiment àond voilà et moi mon
souci c'est par exemple
avec mes étudiants avant de de leur
faire des notes ou avec mes collègues
mais surtout avec mes étudiants.
Mon souci avant de leur faire une note
opérationnelle, c'est-à-dire on dit
voilà quel est le problème, voilà quels
sont les axes de solution avec qui on
peut le faire, quelles sont les limites,
comment négocier et comment arriver à
but ou un bon compromis. Avant de faire
ça, il faut une prospective à mon et
j'essaie d'articuler les deux. Et juste
une question euh est-ce qu'il vous
mettent si vous ne faites pas ça, vous
vous exposez à ça, ça ça avec des
perspectives de redresser la barre
équivalente au néant ?
Est-ce qu'il va le c'est qui là ?
Vos étudiants, vous administrez, vos
collègues, vos copains, ils vous font
monter l'information.
Oui. Les bonnes copies, les meilleures
copies font ça. C'est-à-dire oui,
si tu ne sors pas les poubelles
maintenant
si si oui, si tu n'arrêtes pas de fumer,
tu as tu auras un cancer. Oui, il oui,
ils le font. Oui oui la mise en garde la
mesure des risques et
le cancer il explique c'est-à-dire alors
va y avoir une petite métastase les
types de douleurs vont évoluer jusqu'à
la métastase osseuse. La métastase
osseuse c'est sur une échelle de combien
et les répercussions. Si tu prends une
petite chimiothérapie si ça marche
tu vas perdre tes cheveux. Tu risques de
perdre ça ça. Résultat des courses. Tu
seras fonctionnel mais tu seras mort.
Ça dépend de la richesse de la
prospective. Si la prospective amont, on
en revient là, est indigeante, bah
l'éclairage des risques et des gains,
parce que ça peut être aussi des gains,
hein. Et l'idéal c'est quand même quand
on arrive en fait à plutôt je vais vous
embêter encore mais Spinoza disait on
évite bien mieux le mal en mangeant de
bon appétit. Spinoza.
Bon, ça va alors de on mange
ça va pour qui ? Pour
bah pour nos relations et pour
l'entretien, on évite bien mieux le mal
en mangeant de bon appétit qu'en se
restraignant. Donc souvent les solutions
par le haut positives sont meilleures,
bien meilleures, mais le problème c'est
qu'elles demande vraiment de la
prospective à mon parce que c'est
toujours beaucoup plus facile de penser.
C'est ça. C'est je trouve ça vous êtes
profondément gentil.
Mais j'espère.
Non mais c'est un compliment bien sûr.
Mais
non, c'est pas un compliment.
Mais mais vous avez tort compliment du
tout.
Mais
c'est trop gentil.
C'est
vous avez deux solutions pour éviter le
cancer. Soit vous soit vous arrêtez de
fumer puis vous fumez moins et vous
fumez en arrêtant un peu avant le filtre
et puis après et cetera. Bref, vous
tournez autour de votre clope mais
toujours moins voilà mais quand même
autour de votre clope. Soit vous fixez
un objectif, un but impossible comme
diragut et vous dites voilà moi je vais
faire les vrest et donc ça implique de
me remettre au sport. Ça ça m'embête un
peu mais les vrais ça me fait rêver.
Donc ok je me remets au sport et puis ça
j'arrête. De toute façon, j'y pense même
pas parce que pour faire du sport, j'y
arriverai pas si je clope et cetera et
les choses se font toutes seules.
Et si on a déjà un ob
si si on a déjà fait les vestes,
si on a vu que la situation était
comment comment expliquer ça dans les
termes bien français ? Au lieu de
devenir dépressif, on a réalisé qu'on
était entouré de connards.
Non mais des fois il y en a dans
certains cabinets d'analyse viennent
dépressif mais en fait ils sont juste
entourés de connards.
Autant fumer et faire bonbon.
Est-ce que vous avez compris mon
raisonnement ? Euh je vois l'idée mais
je voudrais être sûr de bien cerner pour
pas répondre euh à l'emporte-pièce voilà
sur euh sur un mot comme ça que je chope
à la volée. Dans certains cabinets qui
doivent déprimer de voir le niveau de où
on où l'on va.
Je pense que dans nos cabinets
d'analyse, il y a pas que des
et encore ce serait insultant pour les
pour les mules. Je pense qu'il y a pas
que des mules ou des anes battées. Je
pense qu' y a il y a quand même quelques
pépites. Ils doivent déprimer. C'est
c'est pas possible. Ils ont dû changer
de boulot. Mais c'est vous qui me
parliez du courage. Ils
on courage aussi. Non mais le courage
c'est bien quelque chose. Après après il
y a il y a il y a aussi se préserver
parce que se sacrifier pour la batterie
c'est pas forcément se sacrifier c'est
euh quand je dis ça je fais vous allez
dire vous allez dire encore que vous
allez dire encore que je suis gentil
mais prenons les choses
prenons les choses caméra sur l'épaule.
On est dans le je vous cite hein, le
bureau de connard avec quelques-uns qui
entourés, voilà, avec quelques-uns donc
un au milieu qui est un peu moins
connard que les autres et qui se dit
dictionnaire
très bien non mais je vous cite, on
reprend votre contexte et avec un au
milieu qui l' un peu moins c'est le
phare éclairé, on sait pas pourquoi il a
lui mais admettons qu'il y en a un
effectivement et les autres sont un peu
perdus pour la cause. Admettons aussi,
je pars de là, pas de problème, c'est
l'exercice. Il est au milieu.
Si vous avez quelque chose à proposer
qui vous anime profondément, que vous
avez envie de communiquer, vous savez
que vous pouvez mais parce que vous êtes
quand même entouré de faux connards,
parce que vous avez quand même en face
des gens Mais oui, parce que vous avez
en face des gens qui sont quand même
intelligents, qui ont quand même des
cerveaux bien faits, qui sont animés
carriérisque qu' on un emprunt
complètement mais ils vont peut-être
aussi mais ils s'aps
en recherche d'une permanence d'une
permanente recherche de de comment de
reconnaissance de sens qui passe
mais mais bien sûr qui va
souvent vous savez le problème c'est pas
l'ambition c'est le manque d'ambition
donc si c'est celui qui veut rembourser
effectivement et partir le vendredi soir
à l'heure ça va être difficile va
falloir aller le chercher mais c'est pas
impossible mais ça va être difficile
pour passer sur les plateaux aussi parce
que l'ego
c'est pas du
exactement si vous les prenez là où
j'allais dire là en fait vous allez les
sauver ce
en activant un levier qui peut qui peut
sauver ou périr ou faire périr pardon,
c'est l'ego. C'est-à-dire que quelque
part, si vous lui montrez que on peut
davantage briller en portant quelque
chose qui soit véritablement alors en
l'occurrence disruptif, novateur, on met
on sait ce qu'on peut mettre derrière
maintenant.
C'est quand même autre chose, c'est pas
de la manipulation, c'est encore une
fois de la transmission. Après, il
prend, il prend pas
et il y en a qui prendront pas. Ouais.
Et ben oui, mais si sur les 3 4 5 il y
en a un ou deux quiad et j'ai des
exemples précis en tête. D'ailleurs, je
vais vous en citer un parce que ça ça
crédibilisera le propos et ça évitera de
et en l'occurrence, il y avait pas de
connard. Il y avait simplement
un état de fête qui est que bah on croit
pas trop au rêve. L'Europe de la défense
c'était un sujet de colloque. Je vous
parle de ça. C'était juillet euh dis pas
de bêtises, août 2016.
Quand on dit c'est un sujet de colloque,
ça veut dire que c'est déjà périmé.
Voilà, l'Europe de la défense, on sait
pas trop ce qu'on manipule. Il y a des
acronymes dans tous les sens, ça sert à
rien et cetera. Un bon sujet de
colloque. Voilà, boum, boum. Voilà. Et
malgré tout euh bah on sort de 2014,
l'Ukraine a été a été attaquée. La
Crimée, on sait ce qu'il en est et
cetera. Euh derrière, il y a eu 2015,
les attentats terroristes et puis il y a
une volonté euh de de se relancer,
d'avoir cette autonomie stratégique
européenne, bref de faire en sorte que
l'Europe ne soit pas qu'un sujet de
colloque. Et puis un peu plus tard, mais
là c'était un peu avant, donc je fais un
anachronisme volontaire, mais ça
participait de la même chose. Donald
Trump est élu président des États-Unis
et donc en gros l'article 5, ça devient
peu à peu l'article F35. Vous achetez
mes avions sinon pas de protection. Donc
les les Européens débrouillez vous seul.
Alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas,
l'article 5 c'est quand un état de
l'uton est attaqué, tout le monde
réplique en même temps.
Voilà. Voilà. Exactement.
Un déclenchement de la du mécanisme de
sécurité collective, voilà, assistance
mutuelle.
Et donc précisément l'Europe, même les
Allemands qui ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts sur la façon de s'impliquer en
opération commencent à se dire "Bon bah
finalement l'Europe de laence, il faut
faire quelque chose." Et donc on propose
des mesures concrètes, le fond européen
de défense, un début de quartier général
européen parce qu'en deux mots, il faut
savoir que quand on a un centre de
commandement et de contrôle pour les
opérations, c'est éminemment politique.
C'est vraiment chevillé au corps avec le
politique et le stratégique. Eston en
avoir un ou ne pas en avoir, ça change
tout. Quand vous utilisez celui de
l'OTAN, c'est pas comme s'il y en avait
un au niveau de l'Union européenne.
Voilà, on essaie d'avoir des mécanismes
de pour rendre plus robustes les
missions exécutives et non exécutive de
l'Union européenne. On pourra revenir
sur un tas de missions si vous le
souhaitez et cetera et cetera. Donc des
mesures éminemment concrètes. Ces
mesuresl 4 ans après, elles ont vu le
jour. Ben, je peux vous dire que sur un
coin de table, quand ça a été écrit par
le conseiller Europe de l'époque euh qui
sans doute était euh un peu rêveur, mais
il fallait qu'il le soit euh et puis euh
les quelques conseillers militaires qui
étaient là pour faire la jonction avec
les les administrations qui ont mis ça
en musique, bon bah on éétait pas
nombreux à croire que la lettre des
quatre ministres, France, Allemagne,
Espagne et Italie allait porter. Au
départ, le fond européen de défense,
c'est presque, entre guillemets, une
violation de l'esprit européen, vous
voyez, financer financer des armements
alors que le projet européen c'est la
paix, c'est un changement d'ADN, la
facilité européenne de paix qui permet
d'équiper en armement létau des pays à
notre voisinage, hein, jusqu'à hauteur
aujourd'hui de pratiquement 8 milliards,
c'est né aussi de ces initiatives là. Et
ben ça typiquement c'est quand vous êtes
dans votre scénacle avec que des en
l'occurrence qui n'en sont pas mais
j'allais dire des technocrates. Voilà et
c'est pas une c'est pas une une insulte,
c'est euh ça veut dire qu'ils sont là
pour faire fonctionner le système au
plus haut niveau, informer la décision
mais qui sont quand même pas là pour
rêver quoi. Bon et ben malgré tout qui
entendent que ces voieslà parce que le
Fond Européen de défense on en parlait
déjà depuis 2011 hein, c'était déjà
quand même quelque chose qui était pas
nouveau qui est venu d'une prospective
qui avait été développée aussi par
Thierry Breton, reprise par Thierry
Breton, mais ça avait été pensé avant,
voilà, je le dis quand même et qui
venait sur inspiration de bah tiens, il
y a le mécanisme européen de solidarité
de stabilité pardon, de stabilité
lorsqu'il y a eu de la crise des
subprimes. là et suite à cette crise des
subprimes et puis des dettes
souveraines, il y a eu Vous
avez compris quoi de la dette des la
crise des subprime ?
Bah, j'en ai compris que c'était une
crise financière qui a son ferment
d'abord sur une crise de l'immobilier
hein. C'est on a fait
quand vous avez dépassé l'écume des
choses, vous arrivez à quelle conclusion
?
Bah qu'on avait titrisé et complètement
saucissonné le risque et qu'on a infesté
en fait toute l'économie de produits
toxiques en faisant croire que que il
n'y avait plus de risque en matière de
finance. Comment vous faites pour vous
informer ? Je sois du cocalan. On va
revenir sur l'Europe de la défense.
Je lis, j'écoute, je consulte,
voilà, je mange de tout. C'est comme ça
que faut manger équilibré, je pense.
Est-ce que vous forcez même quand vous
aimez pas ?
Si ça m'apporte quelque chose en terme
de compréhension, ça me coûte pas. Donc
j'ai pas besoin de me forcer. Après, je
comprends pas forcément tout. J'en ai
qu'une compréhension limitée comme tout
le monde he de toute façon la la théorie
de la décision repose sur une
connaissance limitée hein. Voilà c'est
pour ça que le cognitif a son sens la
représentation j'en fais une parenthèse
dans ce que vous dites. Mon accès au
réel comme tout le monde est totalement
lacunaire parcellaire. On a et quand
bien même l'homme serait omniscient qui
n'aurait qu'une connaissance qui n'a que
il n'a que les représentations du réel.
On en revient à l'épistémé donc par les
fouo. C'est ça en réalité le réel. Donc
euh voilà et nous on en a quelques
tronçons. Bah quelques
c'est comme ça qu'on se fait intoxiquer
d'ailleurs.
Bah de toute façon on est euh tous
intoxiqués. La question c'est de savoir
à quel degré quoi. Voilà et l'idée c'est
de l'être sans doute un petit peu moins.
En tout cas
comment fait comment on fait pour le
voir ?
En fait on on le sait pas si on est
intoxiqué. On sait si l'intoxication
que l'on porte va dans le sens que l'on
souhaite atteindre
ou peut-être que les bilan économique
sont là pour pour parler d'eux-même.
Oui, mais un bilan économique c'est quoi
? C'est vraiment confondre les fins et
les moyens. Là, voyez, en terme de
stratégie, c'est véritablement confondre
les fins et les moyens. C'est
sous-estimer
le fait que quand vous avez un taux de
chômage qui est difficile, quand vous
avez 1/5e
des jeunes de moins
mais je vous arrête tout de suite dans
la prospe pardon. Allez-y. Non
dans
50e des jeunes en grande dép euh en
grand déprivation alimentaire.
Euh ouais mais là je je
quand vous avez tout ça, une économie
qui
a fouille,
c'est peut-être parce qu'il y a un
manque de prospective dans le réel. Non,
bah le premier manque de prospective là
pour le coup, c'est quand même de se
dire que là encore une fois pour prendre
cette question là, OK, on saute pas de
problème, euh celle du travail,
là très clairement, on va vers une
obsolescence du travail dans son
acception du mot travail. Mais oui, mais
si vous prenez pas ça, vous passez à
côté du sujet. Déjà, de toute façon, les
gens veulent plus travailler. Voilà.
Alors, c'est ni bien ni mal. Là aussi,
il faut euh faut arriver à dépasser,
hein,
par-delà le le bien et les mal. Mais euh
ouais, mais c'est pas ces agriculteurs
là qui font fonctionner véritablement
l'économie euh agroalimentaire
de grande ampleur. C'est pas ce qui
celui qui se lève, voilà hein, c'est les
grosses les grosses les grosses
exploitations qui sont dimensionnantes
sur la question et souvent elles sont
plus à la pointe de la technologie et de
l'innovation qu'on ne le croit. Et pour
le coup, je parle en connaissance de
cause parce que euh mon père est maire
d'une un petit village dans un petit
village Saint-Pierre Colamine, voilà,
euh dans le 63 à côté de à côté de Ba
dans le parc des volcans d'Auvergne.
Donc j'ai une petite idée de comment
fonctionnent les les comment les
exploitations et je vois bien qui est le
gros, qui est le petit en l'occurrence
mais c'est pas le sujet. Pour dire quoi
? pour dire que le travail va se
réinventer. Et quand je vous disais
qu'il faut pas confondre les fins et les
moyens, et ça c'est véritablement s'il y
a une chose à retenir en stratégie,
c'est de toujours bien penser quelles
sont les fins et quels sont les moyens.
L'économie n'est pas une fin en soi.
C'est par une erreur d'aiguillage
avec le progrès, la modernité sans doute
après-guerre qu'on est sur cette erreur
d'aiguillage, qu'on est sur une économie
qui devient une fin en soi.
Si je vous dis, il ne sert à rien d'être
bien adapté à une société profondément
malade,
et ben, on dit la même chose dans ce
cas-là. Donc, dans ce cas-là, faisons en
sorte que la société retrouve par un un
bon aiguillage cette fois-là le bon
sens. Et le bon sens, c'est quoi ? le
développement de l'économie et de la
mécanique de cette société hyper
mécanisée qui va jusqu'à une forme de
dématérialisation où la mécanique est
remplacée par le numérique. Mais peu
importe, on va pas voilà philosopher
là-dessus. C'est pourquoi ? C'est pour
toujours mieux permettre d'abstraire
l'homme des contingences du ventre et de
se consacrer au cœur et à la tête.
Voilà, c'est ça la finalité. En tout
cas, ça peut être une finalité plus
haute. Or, on n plus là-dedans et c'est
là où l'esprit et l'esprit européen me
semble bafoué et c'est là où il faut
remettre les choses dans le bon sens.
Donc le travail qui est ali nation n'a
pas de sens, n'a plus de sens. On n'en
veut pas et de toute façon, il
s'éliminera. Vous savez c'est he les les
fesses s'opposent à la cause qui lui a
donné naissance selon les lois immuables
pour l'instant immuable, elle aussi
changeront de tête mais les lois
immuables de l'univers, les fait
s'opposant à la cause, voilà, ce travail
qui devient alignation va supprimer
cette notion même du travail là. Voilà
et on le voit dans tous les secteurs, y
compris d'ailleurs les secteurs d'abord
les plus intellectualisés. On remplacera
les avocats avant de remplacer les
femmes de chambre dans les hôtels
pour autant qu'on aille toujours dans
des hôtels.
Commentaire d'Internet de JSR le premier
là.
Ouais.
Extraordinaire. Alors je vais le passer
euh il est un peu corrosif. OK.
Ah ben il faut Ouais.
Extraordinaire. Jamais de réponse de
prise de position claire. Trois points
de suspension inversion. Alors quel est
son retour d'expérience de ses propres
prospectives de ses propres erreurs ? Je
rajoute propre à chaque fois. Oui oui
oui.
De ces erreurs. Sinon, comment il
s'améliore ? Alors me dites pas oui, je
peux pas vous en parler parce que c avec
mes copains. Après tout, ne sommes-nous
pas mauvais parce que les autres ont une
meilleure prospective ?
Mais les autres, c'est qui ? Les
États-Unis ont-ils une meilleure
prospective ? Le modèle américain perd
son attractivité. La prospective
chinoise,
est-ce qu'elle est meilleure ? Elle est
sans doute en voie d'avoir plus de
puissance selon les termes actuels de la
puissance parce qu'en effet une vision
de long terme, la capacité inscrire son
action dans la durée, la capacité,
j'allais dire à défébriler et faire en
sorte que toutes les particules à
l'image du cœur fonctionnent tous dans
le même sens et pas de façon erratique
au sacrifice même de l'individu. On
revenait sur la notion d'individu.
Ça s'appelle comment ?
Si
sinon ça s'appelle comment ? Bah c'est
un infartus après he
myofibrillation ventriculaire gauche.
Bon ben voilà, vous l'avez dit donc
cette capacité-là la rend sans doute
plus puissante avec une prospective qui
est oui certains le dénit hein mais sans
doute moi je reconnais là je prends
position je pense que la la Chine se
donne un destin civilisationnel que les
routes de la soie c'est pas uniquement
économique comme ça c'est imposer une
vision de la société une vision de
l'homme peut-être remettre en cause un
peu aussi l'individu pour ce qu'il est
au profit de la collectivité vous savez
dans les les romans de de
science-fiction on voit toujours les
petits hommes verts comme étant des
collectivités connecté. Euh voilà, il y
a peut-être un petit peu de ça. Or,
l'individualisme tel qu'il est pensé en
Occident et qui est l'alpha et l'oméga
des droits de l'homme et peut-être lui
aussi en obsolescence là du coup pardon
en évanaisscence. À tort ou à raison, je
ne juge pas. Mais notre prospective qui
est celle pour faire aller à grand trait
euh imposer l'économie de marché euh la
prospérité et les droits de l'homme, bah
elle a peut-être elle s'est peut-être un
peu essoufflée hein et on voit bien
qu'après 30 interventions américaines
depuis la fin de la guerre froide, bon
euh on pe pas dire que ça a été
véritablement et là aussi hein, c'est
pas véritablement faire offense, mais on
peut pas dire que ça été couronné de
succès. Voilà,
je vais me faire l'avocat.
Voilà, donc je prends un peu position
quand même mais sur la base d'un constat
assez froid. américana, c'était bien
quand même.
Bah c'est c'est on parle de la même
chose là, on parle exactement de la même
chose. La pax americana, l'économie de
marché, la démocratie qui va avec, les
droits de l'homme, l'individualisme dans
le bon sens du terme hein. J'ai j'excite
les les comment les ambitions
individuelles pour faire progresser
l'ensemble avec une main invisible
d'Adam Smith qui va faire en sorte que
tout se régule et cetera. Bon, très
bien. Ça peut-être ça s'est essoufflé.
C'est de ce modèle économique là dont je
parlais en disant que le modèle
américain et la prospective qui le
soutend s souffle sans doute par rapport
à l'opposé du bipol dont on parlait le
bipol le bipolle chinois. Mais donc, il
doit y avoir une prospective européenne.
Et là, pour en revenir à et là, je vais
prendre position, je vous le dis quand
je vous dis qu'elle est en période
adolescente boutonneuse. Oui, parce
qu'elle est pas aboutie, parce qu'elle
ne peut pas exister et être plus
puissante sur les termes de la puissance
actuelle, même s'il ne faut pas
abandonner la réelle politique dans son
exception coutumière qui est d'avoir une
dimension militaire forte, une dimension
stratégique forte avec une industrie de
défense qui peut permettre de autonome
indépendante autonome et indépendante
qui peut se permettre de développer des
capacités qui elles-mêmes sont autonomes
et indépendantes. D'ailleurs, on devrait
aller plus loin en disant c'est pas
l'autonomie stratégique européenne qu'il
faut, c'est l'indépendance et la
souveraineté européenne. Et d'ailleurs,
c'est un mot qui est qui est employé.
Mais ça c'est pas un truc
galvodé. Non,
bah qui est pas c'est pas qu'il est
galvodé, c'est qu'il est pas rempli.
Pour l'instant, le costume est trop
grand. C'est ça le problème. Pour
l'instant, le costume est trop grand.
C'est que le costume d'un autre.
C'est le costume. Oui. Alors, si je file
la métaphore, sans mauvais jeu de mot,
mais enfin si je file la métaphore, euh
c'est le costume d'un autre. Si on se
dit bon ben voilà le costume, on veut
être les Américains à la place des
Américains, on veut pas être les Chinois
à la place des Chinois, mais on veut
être les Américains à la place des
Américains. Certains États qui prennent
le chemin.
Euh c'est possible et c'est vrai qu'en
Europe de l'Est, nombreux sont les les
pays qui ont fait la parbelle aux
nouvelles route de la soie, hein. Ça
c'est c'est vrai. D'ailleurs, il est
probable que quand
il est probable que quand la
le niveau de violence de la guerre en
Ukraine aura baissé, qu'on soit dans une
gestion du conflit ou dans un une
négociation d'une paix grise,
peu importe. Macron il a dit pas
possible à Pis.
Peu importe de toute façon euh et ça euh
le président ukrainien l'a décidé de
toute façon, il souhaite, il l'a dit
hein, 26 avril 2023, entretien avec son
avec Shishimpin, il a dit qu'il
souhaitait une relation bilatérale
puissante, forte ou puissante, je sais
plus exactement le mot, puissante, je
crois, avec la Chine. Et dans la
journée, il nommait quand même un
ambassadeur ancien ministre aux
industries stratégiques à Pékin. Donc
euh donc véritablement, il y a un moment
ou un autre où les routes de la soie qui
ont euh qui passent par l'Ukraine
reprendront. Voilà. Bon euh cela dit euh
les Allemands euh les Allemands ont des
intérêts commerciaux. C'est pas les
routes de la soi, mais c'est c'est autre
chose. C'est aussi des intérêts
économiques et mercantiles. Et de ce
côté-là, la France fait quand même
office un peu de de village gaulois
quand même sur le sujet avec encore
cette puissance d'inspiration qui dit
"Nous, on voit une Europe autrement."
Donc c'est pas la Chine quand même hein,
on est bien d'accord, c'est pas non plus
les Américains, même si ça reste des
alliés indéfectibles avec lesquels on
peut s'engager, mais on veut aussi
pouvoir ne pas s'engager. Voilà, donc il
faut rester sur notre axe avec le
développement d'une puissance, mais une
puissance qui ne pourra pas être le
costume des Américains. Déjà parce que
euh on ne répète pas les choses, on ne
les plaque pas, on ne les transpose pas
comme ça sans sans discernement. On a
notre voix propre. et elle est à
inventer. Et c'est là où la prospective
rêveuse, mais euh euh je le reprends
parce que je sais que vous allez la
qualifier de ce terme-là, à son sens. Et
voyez que c'est pas
on voà, on est là pouruse.
Et et oui, mais c'est pas être rêveur
que ce que de se dire que l'Europe peut
moissonner sur ce qui sera une
redéfinition de la façon de penser les
termes mêmes de la puissance. Une
redéfinition de la façon de penser le
monde est une autre matrice de sens. Et
ça ça a déjà court avec le droit, même
si aujourd'hui c'est assez inefficace,
c'està-dire que le droit court pardon
court après les nouvelles technologie en
essayant de les encadrer. Bon évidemment
mal là le dernier date c'est encadrer
l'intelligence artificielle.
Ah moi j'aurais pas plutôt penser les
allégal avec le pas légal qui devient
légal.
Oui. Alors effectivement après ça se
traduit en terme de légal pas légal. On
encadre on régule.
Si la prospective s'établit plusieurs
générations à l'avance, notre présent
a-t-il été anticipé avec quelle justesse
?
Oh, c'est une question forte et
difficile ça.
Ah bah c'est l'ours.
Ouais. Attendez, je prends 2 minutes
quand même avant de
Si vous avez quelque chose à chercher
sur internet ? Non non non mais le temps
de Non parce que c'est une question
c'est vraiment une question forte parce
qu'en fait pour vraiment y répondre
comme j'aurais envie d'y répondre là
tout de suite en fait il faudrait mais
je vais pas vous infliger ça euh que je
réalise à peu près une demi-heure du
bouquin que j'ai commis et sur ces
fondements là on
c'est comment le bouquin
c'est la prospective stratégique une
nouvelle approche pour améliorer la
prise de décision aux éditions Airman,
mon éditeur que je remercie pour la
confiance.
Combien
combien quoi
il coûte ? Euh 20 balles, 22 exactement.
Voilà.
Vous prenez combien par ouvrage ?
Je prends 10 % au-delà de 2000
exemplaires. Voyez, je vais pas
m'enrichir avec ça. Donc
donc voilà. Et oui, donc il faudrait que
j'oralise une bonne demi-heure du
bouquin pour qu'on ait j'ailleur tous
les mêmes bases et qu'on puisse
travailler là-dessus et répondre à la
question. Mais je vais quand même
essayer de l'affronter et d'y répondre
de façon intelligible. J'ai tombé les
bases. Allez-y tout de suite.
Ouais mais oui, je vais essayer. Euh en
étant intelligible. Est-ce que notre
réel présent a bien été euh alors je
vous avez eu quand même le culot de dire
à ma communauté non mais écoutez les
gars, vous avez pas les bases.
Non mais c'est pas les base. C'est que
en fait c'est quelque chose que j'ai
j'espère un petit peu nouveau. Sinon je
l'aurais pas écrit. Je me serais pas
fatigué à passer quelques années à
écrire ça à réfléchir ça.
Le prochain bouquin vous passez une
petite demi-heure avec nous avant.
OK,
ça marche. Voilà. Donc non, c'est un
truc voilà j'ai réfléchi vraiment. J'ai
j'ai creusé, j'ai voyez, j'ai poussé les
les murs de mon cerveau, j'ai pensé
contre moi-même. C'est pas du bloby
boulga resservi comme ça. Donc donc
forcément ça peut pas se lire en courant
et forcément ça demande voilà, ça
demande un faut se l'approprier. Bon
bref, donc tout ça pour dire vous savez
lire
ouvrez-moi ouvrez-moi une page et et
n'hésitez pas à me lire une page.
Bon on va prendre la première parce que
c'est quand même celle qui non ça triche
la prem. Non non, je triche pas parce
que il faut commencer par le
commencement hein. Faut faut commencer
par commencer. Voilà.
Donc
le pilote a toujours ses yeux. Ah oui,
alors pour essayer de répondre, je vais
essayer de trouver une phrase qui
réponde un peu à la question de qui à la
complété euh de notre auditeur.
J'en profite pas à nous soutenir sur
Tipi, à nous envoyer du Tipi, c'est ce
qui nous permet de faire des bonnes
vidéos.
Vous avez trouvé votre ligne ?
Voilà, la spécificité en fait du
bouquin,
c'est de dire que la démarche
prospective stratégique
envisage le futur à travers le
façonnement de la réalité présente.
Voilà, en comprenant puis exploitant
l'interaction entre les processus
cognitifs inhérents aux acteurs et à
l'exploitation qu'on peut qualifier de
multifactoriel toutes les thématiques
d'un contexte, mais c'est davantage le
façonnement de la réalité présente. Ce
qui signifie pour répondre à la question
de votre auditeur qu'en fait
quelle était la question ?
La question c'était est-ce que le
présent que l'on vit puisqu'il faut
envisager la prospective à une ou deux
générations, est-ce qu'elle a été pensée
? Est-ce que notre présent a été pensé
par d'autres ? C'était ça en gros en 25
ans ou 50 ans avant.
Avec quelle justesse ?
Avec quelle justesse ? Et ben en partie,
alors je vais vous la faire courte. En
partie oui, ça a été pensé et je vais
vous dire selon les quels termes et quel
quels axes se retrouvent dans ce qui a
été pensé. Et je vais vous montrer que
ça a été fait en façonnant la réalité
présente à grand trait hein, mais ça
donnera quand même une illustration. Et
donc en quoi il faudrait pour
investiguer le futur 50 ans devant en
partant d'aujourd'hui, faudrait-il
refaçonner ce que j'essaie de faire avec
vous la réalité présente en voyant les
choses sous un autre angle. Pourquoi
c'est le cas aujourd'hui ? Pourquoi ça a
été façonné 50 ans avant ? Quand on nous
parle de choc des civilisations, c'est
une prospective le texte du choc des
civilisations. Huntington
nous disant
vous êtes plutôt Huntictton ou plutôt
Fukuyama ?
Les deux mon général mais dans une
Moi, c'est pas mon général, c'est on va
commencer colonel.
Sky. Alors les deux
les deux mais euh les deux mais dans un
alors je je vous épargne le terme
intrication fractale mais les deux mais
dans une d'une une imbrication
c'est-à-dire qu'à toutes les échelles de
temps et d'espace on va retrouver un
motif d'une couleur qui est Huntington
et l'affrontement et une dimension
proprement polémologique. Et puis d'une
autre couleur, dans le même
enchevêtrement à toutes les les échelles
d'espace et de temps, on va trouver une
forme d'uniformisation. Et c'est vrai de
tout. Alors, je prends un exemple tout
simple. La démocratie par exemple, la
démocratie s'exporte. En s'exportant,
elle s'universalise. Donc, il y a une
convergence et autant de fois elle
s'univers autant de fois elle se
différencie, elle se fragmente. Il y a
autant de démocratie que de pays qui se
revendiquent démocrate. Par exemple, la
démocré démocratie illibérale, c'est
quoi ? Euh je ne connais pas vraiment de
enfin de démocratie, je connais des des
autocraties libérales mais des
démocratie illibérales.
Bon pour revenir au sujet de la
démocratie sans raffiner, l'Inde est pas
vraiment le même modèle démocratique que
la France ou que l'Allemagne, on est
bien d'accord, ou que la Suisse
d'ailleurs où il y a pas de démocratie
faiblement représentative. Voilà. Donc
voilà et les Indiens aussi. Voilà. Mais
donc
ça s'universalise et ça se fragmente. Et
donc on retrouve ces dynamiques que ce
soit le choc des civilisations ou que ce
soit Fukuyama. Fukuyama. Et c'est bien
de citer la fin de l'histoire parce que
cette fin de l'histoire c'est aussi une
prospective et c'est celle qui a quand
même pétri le présent. S'il y a eu les
dividendes de la paix et si on a
déconstruit l'appareil de défense, c'est
aussi parce qu'on a trop cru à Francis
Fukuyama qui nous dépignait une fin de
l'histoire au sens l'histoire par une
histoire égulienne, la dialectique, les
affrontements, la guerre, les grands
hommes qui incarnent la raison, la
raison dans l'histoire gnagnania gnien
et cetera. Et donc voilà, c'est ça cette
espèce d'affadissement des oscillations,
fin de l'histoire, il se passe plus
rien. Donc c'est une prospective qui a
largement pétri notre présent. Alors,
c'est notre présente. Il y a encore
élites
et mais par voix de fait non. Et par
voix de fait, vous êtes trop dur avec
les élites et pas assez avec le peuple
sans doute si je peux me permettre hein.
Parce que quand on dit qu'on a les
élites qu'on mérite, euh
on est très dur avec le peuple mais le
peuple
de peuple don voilà voilà avec les
citoyens, disons les citoyens, c'est
mieux comme terme, les citoyens, ils
essayent d'éduquer correctement leur
gamin, ils ont leurs problèmes de
boulot, leurs problèmes de vie. C'est un
sport d'être citoyen. C'est un sport
très dur surtout en ce moment quand des
élites prennent des décisions à
mais c'est un sport qui demande du
courage aussi hein.
De quoi d'être citoyen. Parce que ça
veut dire aussi être citoyen. Vous me
parliez de la manière de s'informer.
Vous me parliez de la manière de
s'informer. Vous me demandiez si je
mangeais de tout quand je m'informais.
Enfin, je vous disais je mange de tout
pour m'informer.
De temps en temps aussi. Voilà. Mais ça
me coûte pas de manger du brocoli parce
que je sais que ça va me faire du bien.
Donc quelque part c'est bien aussi. Et
un peu de timus.
Un peu
de timus.
C'est Timus.
Ouais. C'est un truc qui se fait
tranquillement.
D'accord. Donc c'est un sport d'être
citoyen mais ça demande du courage aussi
parce que il faut avoir le courage de
s'informer, faut avoir le courage de
faire preuve d'esprit critique, faut
avoir le courage de pas sauter sur le
dernier qui a parlé, faut avoir le
courage et je suis pas sûr que tous les
citoyens, moi compris parfois quand je
suis un peu fatigué fassent toujours
preuve de ce courage là.
Comment vous faites pour résister à ça ?
Voilà. Alors que je suis sûr d'une
chose, c'est que nos élites, on peut
leur reprocher beaucoup de choses, mais
notre président ou n'importe quel autre
président, je suis sûr qu'il mange qui
manque, pardon, jamais de courage en se
levant le matin. Et ça quand même, même
si c'est pour éventuellement faire une
connerie, et ben je trouve que ça ça
mérite d'être salué. Le fait de ne
jamais ne manquer de courage en se
disant aujourd'hui sera mieux que
demain, même si hier j'ai
il y a beaucoup de méal qui se lèvent le
matin, il s'estiment être les meilleurs
du monde.
Ouais mais il se lèvent et il se lève et
il faut saluer l'effort. C'est pour dire
que citoyen ça demande du courage aussi.
Voilà.
Ah ben citoyens ça demande du courage.
C'est pas parce qu'on est pauvre qu'on
est honnête. Vous connaissez la chanson
hein. Ouais mais c'est important aussi
de le dire. Pour revenir
fallait que je prenne position. Bah je
prends position là.
Ouais, si vous voulez
un peu
pour revenir à notre analyse.
Il y a des questions qui tombent. Je
vous jure que c'est pas piqué des
je vous fais confiance. Bon, ça laisse
pas indifférent au moins. Donc ça ouvre
à la discussion, c'est déjà bien.
Non, mais là, ils sont partagés entre il
parle bien, il raconte un peu de la
merde euh ou ou c'est quand même beau
mais ça reste quand même un peu
c'est loin quoi.
H
Donc, revenons à les questions de
l'ours.
Ouais. Je vous ai donné un exemple he à
travers les les prospectives qui
façonnent le présent.
celle des du choc des civilisations à
façonner toute la reconstruction ou
l'adaptation de l'outil de défense pour
ne parler que de ça mais le reste est à
l'avenant face au terrorisme qu'on a
brandi comme étant la menace du présent
une menace du présent envisagée bien
avant qu'elle soit reconnue comme telle
les par exemple en France euh on ne
s'est jamais j'allais dire autant euh
mobiliser et citoyen compris face au
terrorisme que depuis même a eu des
évidemment des attentats rue
Saint-Michel mais là vous parlez oui rue
Saint-Michel mais je suis sûr que la
plupart de vos auditeurs là s'en
souviennent même pas. Ils souviennent
essentiellement peut-être de 2015 c'est
ça qui fait date dans la restructuration
de notre outil de défense. À l'époque on
devait ne plus affronter que des combats
asymétriques, hein, à l'étranger et
c'était le continuum de sécurité
défendre de Kabou jusque au pourtour des
banlieux. C'était le continuum de
sécurité avec Vigie Pirate puis
Sentinelle puis et cetera. Bon donc euh
voilà et on est revenu à la guerre haute
intensité. Donc voilà, typiquement des
prospectives du passé et j'en finirai
par une qui est très importante, me
semble-t-il, pour répondre à la à la la
à la question de l'ours. Euh voilà, des
prospectives qui ont vraiment façonné le
présent. Et la dernière, c'est
typiquement quand Google a été lancé. Le
bouquin de prospective d'ailleurs, il y
avait pas de bouquin, hein. C'était
c'était les fondateurs de comment de de
Google. Donc son nom m'échappe
l'instant, mais c'était Smith. Je crois
son nom. Euh
Serge Ibrun et euh ah son nom m'échappe.
Serge Ibrin et le deuxè fondateur de
Google. Bon le fact checking fera son
œuvre. Voilà Serge Ibrin et
des rames
et euh qui lance en une phrase ce qui
façonne notre réalité présente
aujourd'hui. Si on veut bien la voir
comme telle. Là c'est presque une
évidence. Donc ça veut dire que pour
faire de la prospective aujourd'hui, il
faut voir d'autres évidences qu'on ne
voit pas. Ça renvoie tout ce que j'ai
dit là. Voilà, c'était on va réinventer,
on va réorganiser l'information du
monde. On va réorganiser l'information
du monde. C'était c'était au début des
années 2000. Qui pouvait comprendre
sonder l'insondable profondeur de cette
phrase et qui en effet fait sens ? Lag
Lar Page. Ah voilà, Larry Page et Serge
Ibrin qui disait maintenant, je crois
qu'ils ont commencé par maintenant,
virgule sous-entend du monde, arrête les
conneries, on va vous dire ce qu'on va
faire. On va réorganiser l'information
du monde. Ça c'est une phrase
prospective parmi d'autres
prospectivistes de c'est il y a ils
avaient de l'or dans les yeux.
C'est d'une puissance totale. Voilà.
Question.
Et ça façonne notre réel présent. Ouais.
Vous filtrez tout,
vous mangez du brocoli, des chou de
Bruxelles
en terme de collègue d'information ou
comment vous faites pour résister ?
Alors si vous me dites une alimentation
bien équilibrée, beaucoup de sport là
non mais c'est la base déjà pour
commencer à tirer entre guillemets parce
que qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on
s'informe et quand on essaie de se faire
une représentation de la vérité présente
? Le mécanisme quel est-il ? Essayer en
fait, prenez l'intelligence
artificielle, ça nous en apprend
beaucoup sur la façon dont on
fonctionne,
l'algorithme de recherche ou les
cookies.
L'algorithme de recherche mais le le le
plutôt le réseau de neurones. Je fais
juste une petite mais c'est hyper
important le réseau de neurones.
Une question qui était quelle est votre
capacité à maîtriser les
Oui. J'explique le réseau de neurones.
Le réseau de neurones, comment ça
fonctionne ? Ça fonctionne si on lui
donne beaucoup de données parce qu'il va
apprendre à partir de la donnée. Soit en
le supervisant, on lui dit voilà ce sont
des chats et tout ce que je te montre
comme ça avec une étiquette sont des
chats. Tu vas reconnaître les chats.
Soit mieux sans le superviser.
C'est-à-dire je lui montre des chats et
il a des lois, ce qu'on appelle des
hyperparamètres, des lois propres à
l'algorithme. Il règle les curseurs, la
forme, la couleur, le contour, le
contraste et cetera et il apprend à en
déduire lui-même des patterns et à la
fin le pattern chat, il va le retrouver.
Mais ça veut dire quoi ? Ça lui faut ça
veut dire qu'il lui faut suffisamment de
données et ben nous on est pareil. Si
vous essayez de généraliser en ayant lu
un coin de journal, c'est mort. Voilà,
il faut quand même suffisamment de
données après lesquelles vous
sélectionnez ou pas. Là, il y a une
question de volonté, il y a une question
de volition. Ça c'est un mot clé qui est
dans le bouquin. C'est quoi ? Ça veut
dire une sorte d'acte de foi par lequel
on détermine notre volonté à faire, à
croire, à penser, à se représenter
quelque chose. Parce que faut pas se
leurer, il y a toujours un acte de foi
dans toute vérité. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'on ne peut pas avoir une information
totale, elle est infinie et même quand
bien même on aurait toutes les données
disponibles que leur capacité que leur
pardon leur leur marge d'interprétation
elle-même est infinie. Et là, je vous je
vous passe les le détail du bouquin pour
voir ça. Donc de toute façon, on va être
mal informé. Donc de toute façon, il y a
un choix. Ça c'est le maître mot. Quand
on informe
un décideur, il y a un choix dans
l'information qu'on va sélectionner. Il
y a un choix dans l'interprétation qu'on
va lui donner. Il y a un choix dans
l'action qu'on va vouloir mener, il y a
un choix dans la valeur qu'on va vouloir
servir. Est-ce que ça va être les droits
de l'homme ? Est-ce que ça va être la
réelle politique ? Ça peut être les
deux. vendre de l'armement de défense.
Un jour, c'est bien parce que c'est pour
c'est bon pour les emplois et c'est bon
pour l'industrie. Et le lendemain, c'est
mal parce que ça arme l'Arabie Saoudite
contre le Yémen. Bon, au final c'est
bien ou c'est mal ? Un
moment de défense.
Au final, c'est bien ou c'est mal ? Bah
il y a une lecture, il y a une lecture
et une échelle qui peut nous montrer que
c'est bien et une lecture et une échelle
qui peut nous montrer que c'est mal.
Pourtant c'est la même information et la
donnée aussi éventuellement, mais c'est
pas la même connaissance, c'est pas la
même cognition, c'est pas la même
représentation. Et là, il y a un choix,
il y a un acte de foi. Forcément, ben il
est il est manifeste ici.
Et la prière de ça, c'est un sourire
coûte moins cher qu'une balle.
C'est pas ça le début de la prière.
Un sourire coûte moins cher qu'une
balle.
C'est un choix aussi. Non,
je suis pas sûr. Enfin, je je vois
vaguement ce que vous voulez me dire,
mais oui, effectivement, c'est un choix.
de la même façon que de choisir entre
euh un nombre de morts importants, une
statistique comme disait Churchill et
puis un drame quand il y en a qu'un. Euh
et là, je renvoie typiquement à la
gestion de crise du Covid. Bon, est-ce
qu'il faut soulever le soldat Ryan ?
Fallait-il sauver le soldat Ryan ? Moi,
je suis pas là pour bah
c'est les populations vulnérables.
Les populations vulnérables. Bon, ça
c'est un choix de société électoral
et je suis pas là pour dire quel choix
fallait faire. Je suis là pour dire
qu'il y avait un choix à faire et qu'il
y a eu des choix de fait et que nous
montrer que ça tout découle d'une
connaissance objective mécanique et
nécessaire, ça c'est pas vrai. En
revanche, qu'il y a un aspect nécessaire
hein dans cette espèce d'intication
fractale et en même temps de la liberté
des choix qui s'imissent dans des
interstices dans chaque tiret
rationalisé de il y a une maladie, ça
peut causer telle mort sur telle
population mais à chaque fois il y a des
choix. Voilà. Est-ce que vous pensez que
la plus grande maladie des des
militaires, c'est de ne pas comprendre
la pensée du politique ?
Je pense que je le dis là avec un peu
d'humour et on me pardonnera, on va
dire, cette petite désinvolture, mais je
pense que la principale maladie du
politique, c'est de ne pas comprendre la
pensée du militaire.
C'est-à-dire que quand un militaire
arrive et dit,
"On a rarement vu une boîte de vitesse
parler à un moteur."
Et ben ça dépend si la boîte de vitesse
exige du moteur la finalité. pour savoir
quel rapport adapter. Est-ce que tu
souhaites accélérer ? Est-ce que tu
souhaites accélérer ou est-ce que tu
souhaites un régime de croisière ? Quel
est l'état final recherché ? Ça parlera
à vos final recherché.
Le pragmatisme du militaire, est-ce que
s'opposer avec le pragmatisme du
politique
? C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, il y a deux
logiques pragmatiques. Il y en a une qui
est stratégique. La finalité, c'est
quelle finalité on souhaite et quelle
finalité politique déclinée sur le plan
militaire souhaitez-vous obtenir quand
on s'adresse aux politiques ? Et donc,
je verrai les moyens que je peux vous
fournir et les modes d'action qu'on peut
proposer. Voilà. Et puis il y a le
pragmatisme du euh du du politique qui
va être et voilà qui est une logique de
moyen qui est de toute façon je n'ai
qu'un marteau. Donc tous les problèmes
sont des clous.
Et c'est là où ça renvoie proverbe
américain ça.
Et ça oui mais ça renvoie à la puissance
du politique qui a véritablement la main
mise et un levier d'action à travers le
militaire qui est efficace qui répond
tout de suite. ce qui n'est pas le cas
de l'économie quand il faut régler les
problèmes économiques que vous remettez
sur la table de façon assez récurrente
et j'entends bien que vous voyez
peut-être pas
que je vois que je vois mais donc je la
même
dont j'estime dont j'estime en fait que
non
donc j'ai donc j'estime qu'en fait la la
solution la solution en fait ne peut pas
être apportée par les hommes que vous
pointez et probablement qu'elle ne peut
pas être abordée par les hommes tout
courts à l'échelle de temps auquel il
faudrait apporter la solution parce que
en l'occurrence les hommes qui font
l'histoire ne savent pas l'histoire
qu'ils font. Ils sont dépassés par cette
machine, par cette erreur d'aiguillage.
Les wagon sont passés devant la
locomotive. Elle s'est autonomisée parce
que je vous le disais au début, l'homme
a imprimé son esprit dans le monde et il
se retrouve un peu dépassé par là. Et
donc c'est pas le cas pour la chose
militaire qui reste quelque chose de
simple au sens euh j'allais dire au sens
des systèmes. Là je prends un peu le la
la la mécanique systémique. Il y a des
systèmes complexes et puis il y a des
systèmes plus simples. Un système simple
peut avoir sa complexité propre, mais il
a une certaine simplicité en ce sens
qu'on en maîtrise tous les contours. On
maîtrise pas tous les contours de
l'économie. On a découvert à quel point
l'économie russe, et c'est quand je dis
on c'est les économistes hein, là euh
vous pourrez euh voir toutes les écoles
d'économie qui s'accord sur ce sujet-là.
euh pour dire on a découvert euh le FMI
aussi d'ailleurs que euh l'économie
russe était aussi résiliente et il se
l'explique seulement maintenant et il
redécouvre seulement maintenant que la
croissance qui affaiblie en Russie avec
euh avec la guerre en Ukraine
aujourd'hui repart à la hausse. Il
découvre cette fabuleuse autonomie
finalement cette non interdépendance que
l'on croyait être avec le commerce
mondial et cetera et cetera et cetera.
Bon,
c'est la surprise.
Oui, il y a quand même une forme de
Donc quand on se fait surprendre, on a
déjà perdu. Est-ce que ces gens-là, ils
ont été virés ?
Mais ces gens-là, mais de de qui vous
parlez là aussi ?
Ceux ceux qui sont dire on avait pas
anticipé que l'économie russe était
Mais je ne vous apprends pas que ceux
qui font de la recherche fondamentale ne
sont pas dans les S tank et que les S
tank ne sont pas dans les cabinets
ministériels et que les cabinets et
cetera et cetera. C'estàd que la
courroie de transmission entre c'est
peut-être un problème, vous me parliez
de reconfiguration institutionnelle et
euh c'est pas une réponse de
circonstances. J'y crois vraiment.
D'ailleurs, je l'ai même écrit euh dans
dans des rapports euh que j'ai contribué
à commettre. Euh je
continué à faire des lettres au Père
Noël.
Bah dans le rapport sur l'économie
positive auquel j'ai contribué pour
c'était pour le président Hollande et
c'était sous le sous le la présidence de
de Jacquali. Il y a une mesure, j'ai
plus le numéro mais vous pourrez
regarder, qui s'appelle le HCLT. C'était
le haut commissariat au long terme.
L'idée c'était quoi ? C'était pas de
faire euh un organisme pour récompenser
un pote et le nommer à la tête de ça.
C'était pas ça. Non, parce que oui, avec
les rapportés auules, les choses comme
ça.
Vous vous devancez mon commentaire.
Ben évidemment, je vous Mais voilà. Donc
c'était pas pour faire ça, c'était pour
faire en
sorteer la la perche,
c'était pour faire en sorte que le Céer
qui est en le CE pardon, le C
conseil
économique euh environnemental euh
économique, social et environnementale,
voilà, avenue d'en
et qui est censé représenter
Frieland, non,
pardon,
ils sont pas à Friedland, je crois que
c'est venu d'ENA, pas loin du palais de
Tokyo dans le 7e.
Voilà. et qui représente qui est censé
représenter la société civile dans
toutes ses composantes et penser les
problématiques d'avenir bon puisse
retrouver un peu de dynamis et de et de
lustre précisément à la faveur d'un
organe qui soit souple, agile et qui
soit directement en prise directement en
prise avec la recherche fondamentale. Le
problème typiquement des cabinets de
conseil en stratégie, c'est pas d'avoir
des marchés auprès de l'État. Ça c'est
pas très grave. c'est surtout de fournir
des conseils qui euh honnêtement euh
sont très perfectibles. Pourquoi ? Parce
que euh parce que c'est des slides, des
pensées euh des pensées cadnassées par
les slides avec des schémas préconçus,
sans prospective et qui est très éloigné
des domaines les plus actifs de la
recherche qu'on le retrouve en recherche
fondamentale et qui parfois même n'est
pas présent même dans les sign tank.
C'est ça le vrai problème. Là, j'ai
ouvert une parenthèse moi-même, pardon,
que je referme, mais c'est pour dire que
c'est ça le vrai problème du conseil en
stratégie qui irrigue les sphères de
l'État. Est-ce que ça ressemble un peu à
un horoscope
le
le les les les questions de prospective
en bullet point ? Euh, ça ressemble un
peu à ça ou genre
le la prospective que fait qui ?
Bah, des cabinets privés.
Mais ils font pas de prospective. C'est
là alors là, il y a de la stratégie
avale qu'adé et de la prospective à
inexistante. Voilà.
C'est c'est le vrai problème des
cabinets de conseil en stratégie
que je cite pas par voilà par politesse,
voilà, par politesse, mais c'est leur
vrai problème. C'est pas tellement euh
c'est là où on regarde pas les bons
problèmes. C'est pas parce qu'ils ont
des contrats avec l'État qui d'ailleurs
probablement partient pas de le dire,
j'en sais rien, les enquêtes font leur
œuvre qui probablement ont été je ne
sais pas mais qui probablement ont été
décrochés de façon tout à fait
régulière. C'est même pas le sujet. Le
sujet que ce soit le cas ou pas le cas,
c'est pas mon sujet et c'est pas le
sujet. Le vrai problème, c'est de savoir
ce qu'il fournissent comme produit.
Voilà, c'est pas qu'il fournisse un
produit, voilà, et même qu'il soit cher.
Et à la limite, s'il était plus cher, ce
serait pas très grave s'il était bon.
Voilà. Donc euh si c'est pour apporter
moins bien que ce qu'on peut faire en
interne, c'est pas la peine. Voilà. Bon,
donc ça c'est un vrai sujet là parce
qu'on est encore sur la préparation,
l'aide et à la décision. Voilà. Donc la
prospective dont vous parlez en
l'occurrence là, elle est absente.
Voilà. Après, est-ce que ça ressemble à
l'horoscope, c'est-à-dire aux doigts
mouillés ? Si vous cherchez à prévoir,
j'allais dire là effectivement ça
ressemble à de l'horoscope parce que
c'est pas de la prévision. La prévision,
il y a d'un quantitatif au sens où euh
vous allez avoir recours à des modèles
qui eux-mêmes sont quantitatifs. Là, on
peut faire de la prévision pour que les
gens comprennent, imaginez-vous
le coût du baril de dans une un truc
complètement fictif.
Le prix du barol le prix du baril de
pétrole monte monte monte genre 147 147
90. D'accord ? Et là vous dites ou
qu'est-ce que ça va faire sur les prix
alimentaires
ou mais qu'est-ce que ça va faire sur
les pays de la ceinture méditerranée
ou est-ce que ça va mettre de la
l'instabilité ? Vous allez voir votre
patron vous dites écoute mon coco, si le
prix du baril il continue à monter comme
ça à la moindre étatcelle ça pète. Tous
nos call center ils vont sauter tout de
machin. La seule chose qui nous restera,
c'est de proposer nos capacités à
maintenir la sécurité locale avec nos
techniques de maintien de l'ordre. On
enverra par hasard un ministre
au-dessus d'un pays en période
insurrectionnelle bien sûr avec l'aval
de nos services extérieurs et on
proposera ça comme business. Si vous
aviez dû prénon
que vous sentiez la ceinture méditenne
en instance de cramage,
que vous vous étiez projeté sur place
pour aller prendre la température,
vous remontez avec de l'information de
première main. Un os
parfaitement renié. Vous le présentez à
votre patron et votre patron, il fait
bon écoute, tu es gentil mais nous on a
des gars sur place, on nanticipe pas ça
du tout.
Vous faites quoi ?
Vous faites quoi ? Vous prenez la
bouteille de Gigondas qui est en train
de crever sur son bureau et vous lui
fracassez la tête avec ?
J'exclu cette option là.
Ah pourtant ça soulage.
Vous lui dites "OK, mon pote reste dans
ton machin et vous changez de branche
ou vous utilisez vos propres
informations pour manger ce que vous
racontez."
Cette option là. Ah ça marche bien ça.
Bah oui, j'utilise mes propres
informations et je
fais en sorte de trouver des voix où je
peux être entendu. Après, on l' ou
écouter au moins entendu, je sais pas
mais écouter écouter, il faut faire
comme une diplomatie cognitive
coercitive,
il faut avoir un peu de courage et un
peu tenir un peu de don qui chotte,
voyez, mais en se disant que c'est
vraiment du courage, il faut y aller, il
faut arriver jusqu'à l'absurde. C'est ça
Don Kyot l'enseignement de Don Kyot
c'est arriver à à
à trouver une représentation du réel qui
à la fin éventuellement peut confiner à
l'absurde. Absurde pourquoi ? parce que
vous arrivez à quelque chose qui semble
faire vérité pour vous, qui n'est pas
entendu et qui finalement
est écarté
et laisse les choses aller comme elles
vont et vous assistez entre guillemets à
une à une forme de naufrage. Alors, vous
avez dépeint les aspects, les
différentes dimensions dans lesquelles
on peut être confronté à ce naufrage. Le
premier d'entre tous, vu de ma place,
c'est quand la prospective est
désaffectée. C'est-à-dire que quand le
l'intention prospective initiale, celle
de Gaston Berger par exemple, a été
complètement corrompue
et que vous vous obérez toute
possibilité en aval de faire un peu de
bonne stratégie et de faire en sorte que
les moyens servent les fins et que
s'agissant de la chose militaire,
qu'elle serve à un intérêt politique
euh un intérêt politique qui a dans le
sens des valeurs qu'elle portent, et
Bien précisément
c'est qu'il y a un maillon manquant et
ce maillon prospectif il faut le
restaurer, le réinvestir et c'est un
travail de donky shot parce que
parce que vous êtes gentil. Mais oui,
mais vous êtes trop gentil mon bon
monsieur.
Mais c'est pas c'est pas que je suis
gentil, c'est que moi mon fond de
commerce c'est de vrai euh dans l'espace
qui aujourd'hui fait l'objet d'une
inflation terrible et qui aujourd'hui
pervertit euh notre capacité à apporter
des réponses adaptées à demain. Si
tentez que demain est encore un sens,
mais on le pense.
Est-ce que je peux traduire notre
corporation subit une inflation terrible
? Ah bah l'inflation cognitive, une
déferlande d'information dont on sait
plus comment se enfin par rapport à quoi
se positionner, ce qui fait vérité, ce
qui ne l'est pas. Le statut même de la
vérité, c'est le statut même de la
vérité qui est ébranlé. Donc vous parlez
après de s'informer. Euh
alors merci.
Donc quand vous vous informez, comment
vous faites pour résister avec la masse
d'information que vous prenez dans le
crâne avec la charge émotionnelle qui va
avec ? Et mais ça c'est pas le pire mais
avec vos capacités d'extrapolation de la
situation par rapport à l'information
que vous êtes capable d'ingurgiter. En
gros, le flash vous le prenez avant,
pendant ou après ? Ou la claque.
Alors là, ça par vraiment prétention de
dire ça, mais moi je vous dis les choses
telles que je l'ai vent. Euh
je suis pas doué de précience. J'aurais
pas cette cette euh cette bah de de
savoir avant, mais je sens les choses et
je sens la vérité que j'ai envie de me
faire et autour de ça, je fais les choix
qui permettent euh non pas de
sélectionner, mais d'ordonnancer
l'information que j'ai pour lui donner
le sens
que je veux au sens volontaire du terme
lui donner en disant que ma vérité vaut
bien celle d'un autre. Ça veut pas dire
le relativisme et que tout se vaut.
L'ignorance n'est pas égale à une
connaissance positive. C'est pas ce que
j'ai dit. Mais ça veut dire la
relativité des points de vue.
C'est-à-dire que tout dépend de
l'échelle à laquelle on se rapporte. Le
fait que la Terre disparaisse demain à
l'échelle cosmique, on s'en fout. un
crime de guerre quand vous le
voilà maintenant un crime de guerre à
l'échelle d'un pays ça peut pas être
écart ou oui enfin parce un crime de
guerre dit guerre donc état donc voilà
parce que la guerre entre individus je
veux bien mais le terme serait un peu
galvodé pour le sens ou peut-être très
en avance mais c'est un autre sujet
peut-être très en avance la guerre de
tous contre tous peut-être qu'un jour ce
sera pas qu'une expression obsienne mais
peut-être une réalité
je note d'ailleurs.
Mais euh voilà, pour en revenir à votre
propos,
euh il y a un choix et il y a un choix
autour d'une relativité de points de vue
qui impose une échelle de référence et
un référentiel culturel pour savoir ce
qui fait sens et ce qui ne fait pas
sens. Par exemple, euh à l'occasion du
Covid, on a complètement révisé ce qui
était notre vision du travail. On a
révisé euh ce qui était notre sens
finalement
des priorités. C'est-à-dire que c'est
peut-être la première fois où on a
privilégié
euh al je vais essayer de de pas dire de
conneries là où on a
on a relégué en priorité seconde les
jeunes. C'est-à-dire on a relégué
l'avenir au rang du passé. Ça c'est
c'est peut-être le paradoxe, l'absurdité
prospective la plus forte. Comment vous
pouvez pas compris pourquoi d'ailleurs
comment vous pouvez privilégier ou
reléguer au second plan
ce qui représente l'avenir ?
La réponse est très simple
en en faisant une priorité seconde donc
du passé.
Vous avez la réponse ?
Bah non, j'ai pas la réponse. Enfin,
j'ai ma réponse mais pour le coup elle
est en cours de gestation.
Bah si vous voulez euh
il y a je pense que la réponse est pas
simple là parce que il y a Non, c'est
moi le temps de réfléchir. Je vous
donne des éléments comme ça ça vous
permettra de réfléchir. D'accord. Ou
oui, dites-moi.
OK. Quand vous êtes obligé de trier les
vieux, que vous avez pas de respirateur
parce que vous avez rien anticipé, parce
que vous avez pas de masque, parce que
vous avez rien du tout et que vous ne
pouvez pas les laisser mourir, vous êtes
prêt à injecter 500 milliards dans
l'économie
parce qu'il faut soulever le soldat
Ryan.
Il faut sauver le soldat boomer.
Mais vous savez pourquoi ? Ah bah
c'était important de les sauver quand
même. Non mais c'était surtout super
important que les familles qui allaient
être enillées, elles me tiennent pas
comme responsable politique.
Comprenez la
Je le formule autrement mais on dit la
même chose. Euh simplement là je vous
laisse la la paternité du propos, c'est
que on privilégie
le passé, l'immédiat
sur l'avenir et le long terme. et on
peut être capable de compromettre
l'avenir et le long terme pour des
besoins immédiats et présents tout en
sachant que l'on agit dans ce sens là.
C'est là où malgré tout je mets quand
même un bémol, je mets quand même un
bémol, c'est que on peut être aussi faut
toujours juger comme on dit inconcréto,
hein, c'est-à-dire avec les
connaissances du moment. Voilà. Bon,
question internet. Bonjour. A-t-il
entendu parler du pic de ressources ?
Oui. Oh là oui, faut trop rapport
sur le pétrole, le gaz du chiffre
project, les métau critiques.
À la lueur de ces sujets, bah
le pic de ressources, vous savez bien
pas fini la question.
Le p le pic tout quoi
c'est a-t-il entendu parler de la des
pics des ressources pour l'interrogation
ou il y a autre chose là ? Bien sûr
qu'il y autre chose. Mais
quand on vient sur Servie, on n'est pas
là pour pousser un cadib.
Que pens-t-il de l'évolution future de
nos sociétés une fois que les
contraintes d'approvisionnement en
énergie se profileront de l'évolution
future de notre position géographique
géopolitique pardon
du niveau de prise en compte de ces
contraintes dans les prospectives
réalisées aujourd'hui par ceux qui nous
dirigent.
Bah là pour le coup le travail
prospectif à Hman
pardon pour alors oui, j'ai entendu
parler du pic de ressources et du pic
pétrolier naturellement je sais aussi et
votre auditeur le sait aussi que on ne
cesse de le repousser s'agissant du pic
pétrolier parce qu'on découvre de
nouveaux gisements parce que des
gisements qui n'étaient pas rentables le
deviennent le gaz de chiste et cetera et
cetera parce qu'on étend les zones de
bon et cetera. Bon, tout ça pour dire
que déjà ça fait partie des données
dites objectives qui s'imposent à tous
qui convient déjà de réinterroger le
corps, hein, dans la prospective. Bon,
après, qu'est-ce que l'on peut enturer
euh avant l'esprit et le récit et donc
la prospective en tant qu'elle ?
Qu'est-ce que l'on peut en tirer en
terme d'animation ? C'est-à-dire vers
quelle voix on peut euh vers quelle voix
on peut s'orienter ? À quoi on peut
penser ? Bon, là, le travail, il est
fini. Il y a plus de travail prospectif
là-dessus parce que on tient pour acquis
le fait qu'il y a un monde fini dans ses
ressources et qu'on compose avec ça, ce
qui est une prospective parmi d'autres,
mais on n'est plus qu'après dans la
stratégie comment faire face au mieux à
cette donnée. vrai travail prospectif
qui est de reconsidérer, je reprends la
question de l'ours, le réel présent
d'aujourd'hui pour façonner le futur
le futur d'aujourd'hui, ce qui est
devant nous et que les générations
futures du futur qui est devant nous se
disent le réel que je vis, il a été
pensé avant. Et bien, il faut être
capable de dresser un récit qui aille
au-delà de cette finitude inexorable. Si
on prend ça, il y a plus de prospective.
Il n'y a plus qu'une stratégie pour
faire face à cette situation et cet état
de fête. Voilà. Si on veut faire de la
prospective autour de la question du pic
et plus généralement de la finitude du
monde physique, voilà, et bien il faut
se poser la question de savoir si ces
contraintes seront toujours des
contraintes. Encore une fois, Elon Musk
a répondu à la question en disant "Non,
parce que moi le monde ne me suffit pas,
j'en invente un autre et donc j'agrandis
les limites." C'est simple mais c'est
une prospective. Elle vaut ce qu'elle
vaut. On peut pas dire qu'il se donnent
pas les moyens en terme de stratégie. et
sur le plan opérationnel d'incarner et
de donner corps à cette prospective hein
et il y a il y a un récit fort et un
récit qui se qui s'appuie sur ce qu'on
appelle des faits aujourd'hui hein dur
solide avec des fusées avec des
constellations de satellites euh et puis
on peut aller plus loin on peut se dire
aussi qu'on pourrait arriver à
euphémiser l'homme mais sans que ça soit
une contrainte c'està-dire que l'homme
toute chose égale par ailleurs qui a
besoin d'autant de pétrole, qui a besoin
d'autant d'énergie, qui a besoin
d'autant de d'alimentation et qui
consomme le la même alimentation. Soit
ditit en passant, je tiens j'y tiens pas
là tout de suite, mais les insectes
représentent une alternative, on le
sait, à l'alimentation, à celle de
Lubœuf, j'en parle même pas, vu que ça
consomme en en quantité d'eau et ce que
ça émet comme méthane, heureusement que
tout le monde tout le monde mange pas
des entrecôtes de 300 g. Mais c'est pas
un c'est pas un jugement moral. C'est
pour dire que là on arriverait forcément
aux limites si l'homme reste égal à
lui-même. Mais par chance, si vous
faites de la prospective et si vous
regardez un petit peu au bord du
spectre, un petit peu les signes noirs
qui se dessinent, on voit que l'homme
est en train de se redessiner lui-même.
On voit que l'homme moderne, mais si il
est en train de se refondre, il est en
train de se de se fém
les pulsions les plus euh vœux, les
primitives sont en train de ressurgir,
on est d'accord ?
que ce soit à l'échelle locale ou à
l'échelle internationale.
Donc
et ben déjà ça si vous pousse
question internet
si vous poussez plus loin vous allez
arriver du soldat Ryan se fout de notre
ou c'est juste un naïf.
Si vous allez plus loin rapport
rapport Louano, vous connaissez cette
prospective là ?
bah qui disait que voilà le monde est
fini et donc et donc il faut faire en
sorte qu'il y ait moins d'hommes qui
consomme des ressources et donc on
invente un virus qui permettra de
réduire le problème. Bon après il y a
une autre façon de faire. On c'est c'est
quoi ça ?
La prospective de
c'était un roman. C'est voilà c'est
c'est un roman qui de suite a fait
naître des fantasmes complotistes en se
disant "Ah mais tiens, si c'était pas
ça, si on cherchait pas d'une façon d'y
autre à réduire la population du monde,
que ce soit par des virus, que ce soit
par des guerres, que ce soit par tous
les moyens qui écrêtent les les la qui
écrètent les les pics démographiques."
Bon et qui écrite la démocr la
démographie, pardon. Bon, si euh on
prend ça, il y a une façon de se réguler
qui est beaucoup plus euh qui est
beaucoup plus euh
qui est beaucoup plus naturel et c'est
celle que vous décrivez. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait, et ça c'est pas du
complotisme, les bas instincts à vous
écouter ressurgiraient de sorte à ce que
entre guillemets l'homme s'élimine au
moins dans une forme de darwinisme pour
les moins puissants d'entre eux.
En latin, ça donne quoi ?
Homo omini loupous est.
Voilà, l'homme est un loup pour l'homme.
Euh très bien. Bon euh c'est une
prospective, pourquoi pas ? Euh mais euh
j'allais dire c'est pas la mienne, c'est
pas le choix que je fais. Et avec les
informations euh que je vois, le spectre
que je j'allais dire que je moissonne,
je vois plutôt euh un homme dont
l'individualité est sans cesse
questionner. Et si vous questionnez
l'individu, vous questionnez l'ego. Et
si vous questionnez l'ego, vous
questionnez les bins instincts. Si vous
questionnez les bins instincts, vous
questionnez les représentations du
monde. Vous questionnez le monde
lui-même et la façon de vivre dans ce
monde-là. Et ça c'est une autre
prospective qui prend corps tout
doucement, c'est Neural Link par
exemple. Et ça aussi c'est Elon Musk
parce que le jour où ce sera je prends
corps âme esprit le jour où ce sera on
se passera du langage ça vous fait rire
mais on
réinvitez réinvitez-moi dans 10 ans.
D'accord.
Réinvitez-moi dans 10 ans.
L'année prochaine. Question
internet.
Si si je suis encore en vie.
Ça dépend. Vous risquez d'être rappelé
là. Non.
Tu fais ton malin ici. Non,
vous avez un ancien de la DGSE, cabinet
ministériel, science pot, armée de l'air
et de l'espace et cetera. Peut-on avoir
son avis sur l'un de ces acteurs à l'ône
de l'ctu ou sur un plan prospectif ?
Je vous ai dit que j'étais une particule
élémentaire, c'est-à-dire la
superposition de tous ces états. Et un
point important dans notre vision
rationaliste du monde où les causes
produisent des effets selon une chaîne
que l'on n'interroge plus et tout le
monde est pétri de cause à effet et on
veut des causes qui produisent des
effets avec un responsable en bout de
chaîne et un impact à l'autre bout de la
chaîne. En fait, c'est pas ça. C'est
l'émergence. C'est-à-dire que le tout
est la plus que la somme des partis et
le tout vous l'avez devant vous qui est
plus que l'armée de l'air à une époque,
la DGSE peut-être
à une autre, le cabinet espériel encore
à une autre. C'est le tout et plus que
la somme des parties. C'està-dire qu'il
y a toujours quelque chose qui surprend
précisément et qui en fait est la
composition de tout ça. Vous retrouverez
peut-être dans ces prospectives là le
côté l'audace de l'aviateur et puis son
côté précurseur. J'ose j'ose le dire
hein. Euh
c'était les cavaliers les précurseurs et
ensuite sont venus devenus aviateur.
Ouais parce que vous avez pas
suffisamment lu Saintxupéri. Voilà un
roman prospectif parmi d'autres. Voilà
un roman prospectif parmi d'autres. Bon,
c'est un aviateur euh peut-être un peu
rêveur. C'est vrai que les couleurs
étaient pastelles, mais regardez bien et
regarde l'élecho du Petit Prince. Bon
euh et les enseignements qui sont
dedans, c'est comme Paul Valérie, ça a
toute son actualité aujourd'hui.
Question internet. Dans la démarche
prospective,
n'y a-t-il pas un risque de s'enfermer
dans ces certitudes entre parenthèses et
donc parfois à tort ? Bien sûr, il y a
il y a le risque euh je même plus plus
que ça. Il y a le risque je mesure le
mot hein, mais
il y a peut-être le risque d'une forme
de
j'allais dire de fanatisme, non, je
l'assume pas celui-là, mais de
solipsisme. Voilà, il y a il y a
peut-être le risque de se dire voilà euh
tout n'existe que par le fait de ma
conscience.
Et quand on regarde bien, ça donne le
vertige. Et ça donne le vertige parce
que c'est pas si faux. C'est-à-dire
qu'on on s'aperçoit qu'il suffit de
changer. Je vais prendre un exemple très
concret parce que là sinon trop
ésotérique pas bon. Pris dewaska là.
Non non mais il y a un exemple très
concret. Prenez les anamorphoses. Vous
connaissez les anamorphoses là ? Bah
selon l'angle et selon l'état d'esprit
dans lequel vous êtes. Alors selon
l'angle avec les anamorphoses, vous
voyez quelque chose, vous voyez autre
chose. Et pourtant cette chose est déjà
là. Elle a une seule et même réalité et
pourtant elle a une réalité plurielle.
C'est vrai pour la vérité et c'est vrai
pour la vérité prospective. Et donc il y
a un risque à trop vouloir de se
effectivement un peu j'allais dire de se
fanatiser au sens de ne plus voir que la
réalité qu'on s'est construite mais qui
n'a pas vocation à être prescrite et
pluguée telle qu'elle mais encore une
fois à élargir leur point de vue pour
avoir des stratégies plus fortes
derrière. Et puis il y a aussi, vous
connaissez les tableaux avec les
tableaux en relief là où vous regardez,
c'est pointilliste et de temps en temps
voyez apparaître le relief et la forme
qui surgit où vous la voyez pas.
Qu'est-ce qui change ? C'est l'état
d'esprit en fait dans lequel vous êtes
et qui va commander à vos corpuscules et
en dernière instance à votre cristallin
et à votre rétine et qui va faire que
vous allez voir ou vous allez pas voir
que les choses vont prendre leur relief
ou pas. Et si vous êtes daltonien,
bah ça veut dire que vous me privez une
partie de l'information et que quel que
soit votre état d'esprit, vous ne
pourrez pas vous positionner sur le
sujet. On va dire que ça tient du
handicap mais
ou de l'intoxication.
On peut faire en sorte que vous ne voyez
jamais effectivement ce tableau en
relief. C'est possible aussi. Mais dans
tous les cas, il y a quand même l'idée
que les choses existent par le fait
sinon total. Pour répondre à la question
d'autres additeurs, quand c'est total,
c'est un peu fanatique, c'est un peu
spétrire de certitude et ça confine un
peu à la folie en effet. Mais si c'est
que partiel, il y a cette idée que vous
participez de la de la réalité que vous
vous faites, de la réalité à laquelle
vous confrontez. Et ça pour le coup vue
de l'esprit parce que on le voit au
quotidien sur ne serait-ce que le
conflit ukrainien où la sphère cognitive
remplace la réalité, j'allais dire euh
transcendante, exogène s'il en est une
qui préexisterait à toute connaissance
s'il en est existe une. Voilà. Et ça
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas de la
science-fiction, c'est de la
philosophique. C'est un phénomène
d'élision. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, on
oublie que le sujet observant, agissant,
décidant, choisissant, tout ce sujet-là
et bien il est partie prenante de la
chose observée. Et ça, qu'est-ce qui
nous le dit que c'est vrai ça ? Bah,
c'est toute la réalité à l'échelle
quantique qui nous dit que la chose
n'existe pas avant la mesure. Voilà.
Alors, vous allez me dire, vous allez me
dire "Ouais, mais l'échelle quantique,
on s'en fout un peu avec le
stratégique." Bah non, on s'en fout pas
parce que d'une part, c'est une échelle
qui a tout autant de valeur que
l'échelle cosmique ou l'échelle
classique dans laquelle on vit. Et il y
aurait pas de frappe de précision s'il y
avait pas le GPS et il y aurait pas de
GPS s'il y avait pas de relativité et il
y aura pas d'ordinatoire quantique si on
ne croit pas au quantique. Donc, il faut
y croire. Et quand je vous disais que le
monde entier scientifique compris est
jugé sur un premier acte de foi qui est
celui du libre arbitre et que le libre
arbitre, il y a quand même un théorème
connu en théorique quantique qui dit que
le libre arbitre se propage jusqu'aux
particules. Autrement dit, les
particules ont une forme de libre
arbitre. Ça vient une liberté de choix
dans leur état. Ou alors si c'est pas le
cas, l'homme lui-même qui théorise en
laboratoire n'est pas libre. Cette loi,
ça relie le libre arbitre des hommes au
libre arbitre des particules. Ça
s'appelle le théorème du libre arbitre.
Bon et tout ça pour vous dire quoi ? Et
ben pour vous dire que précisément
effectivement comme il y a une préance
de l'état mental sur la réalité qu'on
observe et la prospective qu'on brosse,
oui, il peut y avoir une forme
d'enfermement à un moment donné dans ces
certitudes. Très clairement.
Politiquement, vous êtes de quel bord ?
Ni pour ni contre, bien au contraire.
Non mais c'est pas le sujet. Je crois
que tout le monde aura Je crois que tout
le monde aura compris. C'est important
de savoir d'où est-ce qu'on part. Non.
Est-ce qu'une prospective d'ultra gauche
équivaut à une prospective d'ultra
droite ou la prospective ne doit pas
être politisée du tout ?
Elle est politisée mais avec un grand
paix. Un grand paix au sens Mais oui, je
m'explique rapidement. La politique
c'est quoi ? C'est
ça fait ça va faire 3 he qu'on est
ensemble.
Ouais mais 5 minutes de plus c'est pas
grave.
J'ai on a fait perdre beaucoup de temps.
J'ai pardon, j'ai fait perdre beaucoup
de temps à vos auditeurs. Donc ils sont
plus à 2 3 minutes près. Euh voilà,
allons jusqu'au bout comme ça. Vous
laisser vous enterrer. On est combien en
direct là ? Tiens, tu peux me montrer ?
Continuez. On est 689. Combien
?
2689.
D'accord. Donc on en a perdu
quelques-uns en route. Alors
parce qu'il reverront après en ils
reverront après en replay ou
on est monté en régime à peu près en 30
minutes.
D'accord. Et donc euh
il y a euh
revenez reposez votre question si vous
voulez parce que là j'étais sur autre
chose. On va poser votre question sur le
bord politique. Oui, ça y est, j'y suis.
Oui. Est-ce qu'elle est politisée ? Oui,
j'y reviens. La politique, c'est
conquérir le pouvoir et le garder. C'est
ça la politique. Mais c'est la politique
au sens des Grecs déjà. Donc c'est pas
la politique polémiste pour dire "Oui,
ils veulent tous le pouvoir." Non, c'est
pas ça. C'est que le politique par
définition plus philosophique, c'est
conquérir le pouvoir et le garder. Donc
forcément par nature même le politique
choisit ses vérités. Il y a pas de
politique puissante et deux politiques
puissantes sans une bonne prospective,
c'est-à-dire sans une vision. On dit
toujours il manque de vision celui-ci.
Toujours gouverner c'est
c'est prévoir mais c'est se préparer. On
devrait dire plutôt se préparer. Ce qui
implique prévoir et ce qui implique
d'explorer et ce qui implique de se
faire
et bah notamment dans cette des dans
cette dimension là qui est la dimension
militaire. Mais c'est d'abord
effectivement se forger une vision. On
attend de politique qu'ils aient une
vision. S'ils ont une vision s'ils ont
une vision forcément qu'ils ont un
prisme ils ont un angle sur
l'anamorphose. Il n'éclairient qu'une
partie de leur vérité. Et c'est là où la
prospective de gauche ne vaut pas la
prospective de droite, c'est que
forcément il y aura un choix des
information pour attester d'une vérité
et construire une vérité. Et c'est là où
Michel Fouco avait déjà vu que plus
généralement les vérités de l'homme sont
entièrement construites et les sciences
humaines sont une construction. Bah la
vision politique est une construction et
même si elle revendique la vérité
objective, ça ne peut être qu'une fable.
Mais c'est euh donc effectivement l'une
ne vaut pas l'autre.
Vous parliez de
réseau neuronal,
hm
d'intelligence artificielle,
de pipe de data. Non, pipe de data, je
le rajoute.
De big data.
Ouais. De parlait de volum pipe de de de
canaux de data.
Ouais. De capteur ou
de data stocké depuis une quinzaine
d'années
maintenant qu'on a la capacité de
traitement.
Est-ce que vous pensez que les États du
moins les États costaud ou les gros ce
se capables de se battre dans le sur les
chiquiers des nations, ils sont en train
comme ils sont complètement désemparés
par rapport à la prospective et le côté
non chalant des prospectivistes ou le
côté un petit peu sous stupéfiant de
certains prospectivistes.
Est-ce qu'ils sont pas en train
d'essayer de se trouver un nouveau dieu
avec l'intelligence artificielle ?
C'est-à-dire que notre système est
tellement intriqué que la
pensée politique est tellement étriquée
et que le reste ne suit plus parce que
complexité que consensus pas consensus.
Est-ce que ils sont pas en train de se
remettre
corps et âme à l'intelligence
artificielle dont ils n'ont aucune
connaissance
et ils vont prier un nouveau dieu pour
leur trouver des solutions ?
C'est intéressant cette question parce
que je ne suis pas sûr pour répondre à
question, je ne pense que non. C'estàd
je ne pense pas que ce soit un choix
conscient, délibéré, organisé et donc
qui serait d'une certaine manière
bien ou mal orienté
empreint d'une force de complotisme.
Non, le complotisme demande beaucoup
d'intelligence et de coordination et
souvent n'existe pas.
Et donc il peut y avoir de la collusion.
La question la question c'est
c'est pas la même chose.
Non, vous avez je me suis mal exprimé,
vous avez pas compris ma question.
Est-ce que le politique va tellement se
retrouver coincé sous une montagne de
problèmes venant de toute parts et que
il ne comprend pas Sunzu et queil ne
sait pas identifier dans quel terrain il
est ? Est-ce que peut-être
inconsciemment il a émet l'hypothèse que
une intelligence artificielle pourrait
l'aider
à éviter de courir le 100 m en 9
secondes parce qu'il y a sa population
qui commence à avoir un peu ralbol ? Et
ben euh là il y a deux niveaux de
réponse. Le premier niveau c'est oui
mais en ne sachant pas ce qu'il cherche
à obtenir. Pour ma part et je pense que
c'est un élément important et de la
théorie prospective que je développe
là-dedans et de la prospective elle-même
que je propose en illustration, c'est
que LIA est un peu l'enfant, c'est nous
qui l'avons enfanté hein, qui nous
conduira si vous voulez sur le chemin de
notre essence. C'est-à-dire qui va nous
permettre de savoir véritablement qui on
est, de nous réinterroger, de nous
transformer et peut-être par la même de
nous sauver. C'estàd que ça nous sauvera
pas parce que ça trouvera mieux que nous
des solutions à des problèmes présents.
Même si l'A on attend beaucoup pour les
problèmes d'optimisation, c'est la base
en fait la base de l'IA, c'est
l'optimisation, hein, on est d'accord ?
Bon voilà, on laisse de côté. Euh non,
ça nous sauvera parce que ça va nous
permettre de redéfinir les termes du
terrain de jeu sur lesquels on ne peut
plus évoluer parce que les limites sont
finies par exemple pour reprendre voilà.
Donc oui, mais pas en visant le but que
l'on croit viser. Et non, pour répondre
à la question aussi parce qu'à mon avis,
on n'est pas à ce niveau de de
conscientisation sur ce que pourrait
faire l'IA. Pour l'instant, c'est
surtout quelque chose qui
sur c'est quelque chose qu'il ne faut
pas rater parce que sinon on serait
déclassé
et on veut pas être déclassé. Voilà,
c'est plutôt en terme de déclassement
que ça se pense sur un plan de
conscientisation et de coordination
politique sur lesquels, j'allais dire
les instances ont la main. Et l'idée
c'est de rattraper le retard
technologique, c'est d'encadrer par le
droit abus et cetera, de penser la
responsabilité et à tout point de vue
pour l'instant, y compris sur les armes
les salas, vous savez, les systèmes
d'armes létales autonomes, les les
robots tueurs, pour dire les choses
clairement. Euh pour l'instant, personne
a franchi le Rubicon en se disant que
l'homme serait en dehors de la boucle et
que la décision finale ne reviendrait
pas à l'homme.
À la frontière de la Corée du Sud et
Corée du Nord, il y a pas des trucs qui
traînent un peu par là ?
Euh, soyez plus, dites-moi parce que il
y a pas des robots tueurs avec prise de
décision autonome à la frontière ?
Euh, question.
Non, mais là pour le coup, vous me la
prenez euh sans peut-être, mais il faut
que je me renseigne,
faut que je me renseigne là parce que
là, non, ça me
euh en tout cas euh pas européen et pas
français, ça c'est certain. Vous avez vu
le le l'exercice avec euh du moins la
simulation avec une une intelligence
artificielle
à la tête d'un drone, on dit à
l'intelligence artificielle, "Tu
repères, tu détruis."
Et et quand que l'intelligence
artificielle avait repéré, elle a voulu
détruire mais l'opérateur humain,
j'ai vu ça. Alors
l'opérateur humain lui a dit "Bah, tu
rentres à la maison parce que on veut
juste repérer ça nous allée
aujourd'hui." L'intelligence
artificielle un petit peu c'est comme
mon chat, mon chat estime que je suis le
dernier des stupides de la maison. il
préfère me neutraliser.
Donc l'intelligence artificielle a
neutralisé l'opérateur humain pour
pouvoir aller finir sa mission et et ça
a été un peu poussé même en lui
expliquant que c'était pas bien, que ça
allait gagner moins de points. Vous avez
suivi ça ?
Oui. Alors euh
vous avez un chat
pour être tout à fait honnête. Euh
faudrait
pas de chat.
Alors déjà j'ai pas de chat. Il faudrait
que je regarde plus dans le détail
exactement les conditions dans
lesquelles sont sont déroulées ce que
vous relatez. Néanmoins, le premier
enfin le principal problème de l'IA ne
réside pas là-dedans. C'est-à-dire que
le vrai problème, c'est surtout
l'explicabilité. Mais la capacité, mais
si la c'est de savoir pourquoi il a pris
telle décision. par exemple euh il faut
être capable si vous avez une IA qui euh
joue euh au bridge, bah euh d'être
capable d'expliquer pourquoi il prend
telle décision euh de sorte à euh
pouvoir refaire le cheminement et euh
allier la force de l'homme avec euh une
partie qui est psychologique et
rationale à ce stade non saisissable par
l'UA et la force exploratoire de l'IA.
Je peux vous troubler ?
Oui.
La différence entre les échecs et le jeu
de go, c'est quoi ?
Ah !
Alors, je joue au deux. Euh
fondamentalement, il y a pas de
Fondamentalement, il y a pas de
Alors, si il y a pas de différence pour
UNIA en ce que ça reste un jeu
exploratoire et combinatoire. Il y a pas
de transformationnel. C'est-à-dire qu'on
va pas chercher à discuter les règles, à
faire évoluer ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie, c'est-à-dire les mots.
Vous devriez prendre un chat. Bon, mais
euh il y a quand même une différence,
c'est que euh au jeu de go, rien n'est
véritablement irréversible. C'est-à-dire
que vous pouvez avoir tous les pions
blancs et puis par un coup de génie, les
noirs vont en posant le dernier pion
convertir convertir tous les pions à
leur couleur. Aux échecs, vous
capitalisez. Aux échecs, un moment, si
vous avez moins de matériel, vous avez
moins de matériel et il y a des abandons
beaucoup plus rapides. Voilà. Mais
fondamentalement, ça reste de
l'exploratoire, ça reste du combinatoire
et il y a pas de transformationnel.
Votre poète préféré, c'est qui ?
Poète préféré,
j'aime bien Théophile Gautier.
Pourquoi ?
Bah d'ailleurs, il y a un passage où je
cite Théophile Gautier. Faudrait que je
le retrouve.
Il est fort. Il est fort.
Oui, parce que c'est de la prospective.
Alors, je vais avoir du mal à le
retrouver là et je peux pas faire une
recherche mais en gros, c'est en gros en
quelques mots, je vais peut-être les
corner. pardon à Théophile Gautier mais
il dit et ça représente bien mon idée de
la prospective
sculte lime siselle que ton rêve
flottant se selle dans le bloc résistant
voilà et ça pour moi c'est la
prospective c'est-à-dire qu'il faut se
faire une idée
du présent de la réalité présente de
quelque chose qui est encore en
gestation qui s'impose un peu à soi mais
qui en même temps est en recombinaison
il faut arriver à le traduire
de façon concrète et intelligible et de
faire en sorte que ça pèse et que ça
change le monde avec une forme de
postérité. Et pour reprendre ce que
posait la question de votre auditeur,
faire en sorte que la réalité présente
soit le fruit d'une prospective passée.
On a vraiment ça dans ces trois vers là.
Voilà le sculte limisel que que ton rêve
flottant se dans le bloc résistant.
Voilà. Donc Gautier, je dirais.
Bon, il faut que je demande à mon
Mais j'aime bien les aikou aussi.
Faut que je
faut que je demande à mon équipe
technique. Est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
lui file le record de durée ou ou non ?
Faut savoir les gars. À toi de voir.
Oui, non. Oui oui. Bon, vous avez de la
chance, il vous aime bien. Donc nous
sommes à environ 3h1 minutes.
Soit vous prenez le record de la chaîne
en durée,
soit je vous pose deux autres questions.
Bah l'un n'empêche pas l'autre a priori.
C'est c'est même plutôt si vous me posez
de deux questions, on va deux fêtes
prolonger un petit peu et donc voilà.
Bah ça me va bien. Ouais. OK. Ça marche.
Ça me va bien.
Vous avez regardé des interviews de
notre chaîne ?
Est-ce que vous voulez que je sois je
réponds honnêtement ?
Il y a intérêt sinon je vous pète les
genoux.
J'ai survolé pour voir quel était le
grain au sens la couleur, la texture,
votre voix.
Et c'est pour ça que vous m'avez taqué
et c'est pour ça que vousz votre bouquin
avec la R Corporation sur Twitter. Je
veux pas être je veux pas me devoir
imiter un modèle. Je veux être essayer
d'être complémentaire de ce qui est
donné. Donc euh
vous avez vu quoi ?
J'ai vu des noms, j'ai vu des débuts de
phrases, j'ai vu des silences, j'ai rien
regardé une extino. Bah non sinon parce
qu'après on on se là vous vous Non mais
non mais quand je vous le dis, vous
voulez pas me croire mais je vais vous
le redire. Vous êtes dans une rupture
là, vous vous êtes en en train de de
provoquer ce qu'on appelle euh une
rupture d'indétermination quantique.
C'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment où
vous observez la particule, vous
l'obligez à avoir
comme les truffes. C'est ça.
C'est c'est ça. Vous obligez à avoir un
spin donné, une polarisation donnée et
cetera. Et c'est mort. Si vous voulez
garder cet état d'indétermination, il
faut pas l'observer avec un projecteur
qui la met comme un lapin pris dans des
phas. Et donc, je me suis bien gardé de
regarder euh inextin euh l'une de vos
émissions, surtout pas, mais j'ai
survolé suffisamment pour me dire "Bon
bah voilà, ça ressemble un peu à ça et
voilà, je vais essayer de de livrer mon
point de vue
sur j'allais dire sur cette tonalité. Je
l'ai vu comme une tonalité. Voilà.
Et plutôt quelle tonalité ?
et ben celle qui correspond bien à votre
slogan et qui correspond un peu vision
de la prospective. C'est-à-dire que là
on est dans une réflexive pure. Alors
là, je vais essayer je vais essayer de
faire comme avec Théophile Gautier. Non,
c'est je crois que c'est l'idée c'est de
d'ouvrir la voix à des visions
alternatives du monde. C'est vision
alternative.
Il ne faut pas compter sur ceux qui ont
écré les problèmes pour les résoudre.
Ah c'est B. Alors c'est pas le bon
slogan. Mais j'ai vu aussi j'ai vu aussi
alors c'est peut-être pas le slogan mais
c'est un peu la la finalité et votre
projet c'était ouvrir la voix des
visions alternative et des voix
alternatives qui ne seraient pas entendu
forcément par ailleurs et à qui on
laisserait pas le temps de pouvoir aller
au fond des choses.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre
Oh là là et ben il y en a deux déjà ne
peux pas ne pas les conseiller
puisqu'ils ont servi de conseiller le
son bou
montrez-moi un peu parce que je trouve
la couverture très jolie. Ah bah c'est
gentil
et ça faisait très longtemps que j'avais
pas vu une belle couverture.
C'est très aimable à vous.
Enlevez votre main. Euh
pardon. Je dois remercier euh
caméraman, tu peux zoomer un peu ?
Je dois remercier l'équipe de de
création de d'Herman
euh qui sans me consulter mais à la
lecture du bouquin en fait m'a proposé
un certain nombre de couvertures dont
celle-ci était quasiment dont le
président Arthur Cohen que je remercie
m'a dit c'est à mon avis celle qui
croque le mieux le bouquin
et ce sont des espac-temps voyez.
alternatif
avec qui vibre selon des fréquences
propres mais qui au final
par le fait d'un choix se détermine à
quelque chose parce qu'il faut quand
même agir, il faut quand même peser sur
le monde même si on essaie de peser sur
le temps long et que ça peut paraître un
peu rêveur et si j'allais dire c'est à
dose homéopathique si vous poussez sur
un pétrolier longtemps il va bouger
beaucoup mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
attendre longtemps ça veut pas dire que
c'est pas efficace mais il faut une
échelle de temps un peu plus longue.
Voilà. Donc un peu comme les voiles
solaires, c'est ça
exactement. Bah merci pour merci pour
l'analogie là. Voilà, c'est exactement
ça.
Et et euh j'allais faire une vanne
et donc les trois bouquins les
effectivement forcément je le dis parce
que ça sert de socle, je pense
à la bonne compréhension de ce bouquin
là, c'est euh bah le constat de départ
que j'ai essayé sur lequel duquel j'ai
essayé de repartir qui est la crise de
l'esprit 1919 de Paul Valérie et la
liberté de l'esprit. Alors là aussi les
mots c'est pas liberté au sens où on
l'entend parce que et là il est très
proche de vous parce que il l'entend au
sens économique du terme. Il dit en deux
mots vous savez l'esprit utilise
l'organisme même qui a fait l'économie
et il y a pas un un organisme pour les
choses nobles et les la pensée puis un
un organisme pour les choses qui ne le
seraient pas l'économie et les choses du
ventre. C'est le même qui a fait les
choses et voilà à quoi ça conduit. Voilà
à quoi ça conduit. Voilà. avant avant
donc
et puis le trisème ce serait les mots et
les choses
avant avant
les mots et les choses de Michel Foua
voilà donc le bouquin qui certainement
de Michel Fouco a eu le moins de succès
mais qui me semble-t-il mais c'est toute
humidité à mon avis le
dont toute la portée philosophique a pas
été entrevue et c'est de là que j'essaie
de repartir en toute humilité hein. Je
vous lis un commentaire qui n'est même
pas une question et j'avais dit dans la
section, c'est les questions mais
exceptionnellement je vais lui lire, je
vous donne l'occasion d'y répondre,
d'accord ? Il a pas donné une
prospective à lui quand même en parlant
de 3h.
Alors il a pas assez écouté.
Elle est dedans. Elle est dedans. Et je
vais dire non pas ce qui est la
un petit peu à la fin on survit ou pas ?
Bien sûr qu'on survit. dans
quel fin
on se survit mais pas forcément dans la
forme accoutumée. Voilà et ça c'est
important mais ce qui est pas fatal
tragique pour autant vous savez quand on
posait
contre contre l'archiviste l'archiviste
exactement quand le le l'animateur
disait en 19 ça quand il a fait passer
sa réforme des retraites
vous allez survivre mais pas dans la
forme accoutumée voilà et donc là pas
dans la forme accoutumée et en fait
toute la théorie sous-jacente
à la prospective telle que je la vois
plus plus généralement à cette
philosophie de l'action
et que je décris là converge vers la
prospective même que je dresse en
illustration. Et c'est là où il y a une
intrication entre les deux. Et j'allais
dire je ne pouvais pas en faire moins
parce que sinon c'est peut-être toute la
pensée que j'essaie de forger qui se
serait invalidée d'elle-même, incapable
qu'elle eû été sinon de penser sa propre
pensée. Et c'est ce que nous disait
Fouco en 66. qui disait bon euh on lui
disait bon c'est bien votre bouquin là
euh le mythe de l'homme déchu Sartre
doit se rabiller. Vous nous dites qu'il
reste plus qu'une trame de nécessité.
Moi, je dirais plutôt une trame, une
intrition entre nécessité et liberté
avec la liberté qui est un hasard pur
qui n'est rien, ce qui est à la fois
très optimiste mais en même temps
vertigineux à voir. D'accord, il reste
rien. Mais du coup, que fait le
politique ? Que peut faire encore cette
pensée-là pour le politique ? Et Fouo,
il disait très simplement avant de
prescrire, c'est bien d'avoir une pensée
qui se pense elle-même. C'est ce que
j'ai essayé de faire ici mais j'ais dire
sans aller jusqu'à prescrire, j'explore
quand même un scénario qu'on appelle
Maya, most advanced yet acceptable,
c'est-à-dire aussi avancé, aussi
vertigineux, aussi disruptif que vous
voulez, qui ouvre vraiment les chakras
mais encore racontable et audible,
c'estàd compréhensible par les gens de
par nos concitoyens. C'est-à-dire qu'il
faut pas être compréhensible d'un
martien ou de quelqu'un qui n'aurait
plus de langage, mais être
compréhensible ici et maintenant. Et ben
c'est cette espèce de tension extrême
que j'ai essayé de ménager et l'un
répond à l'utre. Comprendre.
Voilà. Maya
comment le film se termine. Est-ce que
vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Quelque chose
d'impérissable ? Ah, je vais vous dire
une banalité mais d'une
non que j'ai découvert
à la force de
de la persévérance et d'y croire, c'est
qu' il faut
il y a pas loin entre l'amour et la
volonté et il faut véritablement
aimer. Non, il faut aimer ce que l'on
fait mais on n'y croit pas. On se dit
oui mais on est quand même obligé de
faire des choses qu'on aime pas et puis
finalement il vaut mieux apprendre à
aimer ce qu'on fait parce que comme on
peut pas faire ce qu'on aime il vaut
mieux aimer ce qu'on fait. Ouais, mais
non, parce que si vraiment vous voulez
faire quelque chose qui vous anime, qui
puisse permettre de sceller un temps
soit peu quelque chose dans le bloc
résistant, de croire en ce pari
impossible d'une forme de postérité, au
moins celle de son échelle, à son
échelle, il faut faire quelque chose que
l'on aime. Si vous n'aimez pas ce que
vous faites vraiment,
il peut pas devenir quelque chose de
bon. Moi, j'ai fait des sacrifices
énormes pour me lancer sur cette voie
improbable et ces réflexions improbables
et pour donner corps à ce qui restera
peut-être comme des élucubrations
peut-être, mais c'est les miennes et
j'ai dépensé des années de ma vie et
donc j'y crois et je les aime. C'est mes
élucubrations et je les aime. Voilà.
Rappelez-vous un truc, les gens qui vous
ont perdu à ce moment-là s'en morderont
les doigts.
En tout cas, puissent-ils le comprendre
parce que vraiment, c'est ce qui sauve.
C'est ce qui sauve. Après le succès
incident, il vient ou il vient pas. Bon
ça peut être long, c'est souvent long et
puis de toute façon on n pas besoin de
d'or en réalité on n pas besoin des
laassè ça fait vraiment du bien. Une
bonne assè ça fait vraiment du bien. Euh
une bonne retraite spirituelle ça fait
vraiment du bien. Et donc non l'amour au
sens aimer vraiment ce que l'on fait et
être animé par ce que l'on fait avec
cette oui cette volonté d'une d'une
petite parcelle de postérité. Je pense
que c'est s'il y a quelque chose de
l'homme moderne, de l'homme positiviste
qui doit rester et ben ça doit être ça.
Voilà.
Un tout petit peu d'ego,
c'est ça ?
Oui. Mais qui sera complètement
redistribué et redisséminé. Donc
peut-être que ces élucubrations sont
celles d'une nous sphère, hein. Euh euh
là, l'avenir de l'homme, tu es l'art des
jardins. Si c'est pas le les mots et les
choses, ça peut être le 4e livre parce
que je suis indiscipliné, sera pas trois
livres mais quatre livres. Tayard de
Chardin qui nous disait "On va vers une
ascension, vers plus de conscience. Si
ça c'est pas de la prospective, après
sous quelque forme que ce soit, là aussi
il faut avoir une idée de ce que c'est
que la conscience. C'est certainement un
des termes les plus euh galvudés pour le
coup pour reprendre votre terme et le
plus mal connu aujourd'hui. Avant la
psychanalyse s'intéressait à
l'inconscient et on pensait que le
conscient était parfaitement connu.
Aujourd'hui, l'inconscient avec
l'inférence balésienne a pas beaucoup de
secrets pour nous. Mais la conscience
que c'est fondamentalement au-delà de
l'acte réflexif, c'est fondamental.
Voilà. Et c'est ça qui est en train de
se produire, c'est l'ascension vers plus
de conscience.
Jérôme Cllèche. Merci.
Merci à vous. Sky.
[Musique]